[Musique]
Rima Hassan. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Oui, bien
sûr. Donc euh Rima Hassan euh 33 ans. Je
suis
Ah oui, effectivement euh donc je suis
euh députée européenne française depuis
1 an maintenant, depuis juin euh juin
dernier. Je suis euh d'origine
palestinienne. Donc je le précise
puisque effectivement c'est le combat
sur lequel je suis le la plus investie
au Parlement.
Euh je suis juriste de formation,
donc peut-être qu'on y reviendra, mais
moi j'ai travaillé euh près de 10 ans
avant de m'engager en politique, mais
sur d'autres sujets avec la même colonne
vertébrale qui est celle du droit
international mais sur la protection
internationale des réfugiés, la question
de l'encampement dans les migrations,
les migration les migrations
internationales,
à l'Office français de protection des
réfugiés des apatrides, également à la
cour nationale de droit d'asile. on
pourra y revenir aussi sur leur fonction
euh sur la question de l'accueil et la
délivrance des protections
internationales en France.
Euh et donc je suis d'origine
palestinienne avec une spécificité quand
même qui est peu connue en France et qui
est peu abordée.
C'est le statut des réfugiés
palestiniens descendants de la Nakba
puisque je suis née dans un camp de
réfugiés palestinien qui est le camp de
Nérab qui se trouve dans la banlieue
d'Alep et
à en Syrie
à effectivement en Syrie et on a on y a
été installé j'y suis née parce que
trois de mes grands-parents ont vécu la
Nakba qui
renvoie à un moment pour le coup
catastrophique. Le terme la traduction
en arabe du terme Nagba, c'est la
catastrophe
du récit palestinien qui qui est
l'expulsion de près de 800000
Palestiniens. Donc ça c'est documenté
notamment par Ilan Papé, un historien
israélien qui a eu accès aux archives et
d'autres. Mais le livre le plus éloquent
sur ce sujet, c'est le nettoyage
ethnique de la Palestine qui est
exclusivement dédié à la documentation
de la Nakba et
près de 500 villages qui ont été
détruits pendant la Nakba. Et donc on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec des millions
de Palestiniens, de réfugiés
palestiniens qui vivent dans ces camps.
Euh alors je reviendrai peut-être plus
en détail tout à l'heure, mais c'est un
statut très particulier parce qu'on est
réfugié et apatrie. Euh donc là, ça fait
aussi référence à l'actualité sur la
déchéance de nationalité qui a été
convoquée par Bruno Rotaillo me
concernant et d'autres. et finalement il
s'est rendu compte que j'étais apatri
donc voilà il connaissait pas vraiment
le statut mon statut initial avant
d'avoir mon ma nationalité française.
Donc voilà, c'est stati particulier et
cette identité, cette histoire aussi
particulière et qui je sais pas par la
force des choses aujourd'hui fait que je
suis un peu au croisement entre ces deux
identités palestinienne, française et et
j'espère réussir à faire pont entre ce
qui est pour moi la France et et ce que
doivent être aussi les droits du peuple
palestinien et
voilà, j'espère l'investir comme il le
faut dans ce mandat.
Député européenne, ça gagne combien ?
Euh 8000, c'est une indemnité de plus de
8000 €. 8000 euh 8100.
Vous cotisez en France ou pas en France
?
Oui, bien sûr. Oui, bien sûr. Oui.
Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Oui.
Lequel ?
Et bien pour les musulmans, c'est le
même. C'est-à-dire que pour les
musulmans, c'est euh on a simplement
trois les trois prophètes s'inscrivent
dans la même religion en réalité. et
Mahomé est est présenté comme le dernier
le trè donc à apporter une version la
plus disons actualisée mais dans nos
prières on a une sourate qui est dédiée
à Marie Mariam on a on prie pour Jésus
on prie pour Moïse. qui sont cités dans
nos prières. Donc euh donc c'est le même
Dieu en réalité. Mais
dit la sourate de la vache ou le verset
du trône ou
Oui, la sourate sourate al Baqara. Donc
c'est la sourate de la vache et sourate
al corsé c'est la la la sourate de
Vous êtes pratiquante.
Oui, j'en ai besoin mais je suis pas
très assidu mais je sens que c'est un
refuge
manger du cochon.
Non
vous avez tort. C'est bon le cochon.
On n'est pas les seuls sur ce point sur
ce point-là. On est avec les juifs, on
est on est d'accord sur cette pratique
là. Mais mais voilà, en fait, c'est un
c'est un refuge. Je pense que pour euh
c'est un moment de sérénité quand j'y
vais. C'est vraiment un moment de
sérénité quand j'y vais et surtout quand
je me sens dépassée par des choses. Et
je pense que c'est pareil pour toutes
les personnes croyantes quoi. C'est un
moment où on essaie de de s'en remettre
à quelque chose qui nous dépasse.
Un ami imaginaire. Oui, un confident, un
ami, un Oui, c'est un peu tout ça, je
pense. On y trouve on trouve un peu tout
ça dans dans la spiritualité. Quel qu'à
soit d'ailleurs, je veux dire, c'est pas
que c'est pas que pour les musulmans ou
les religions monothéistes, je veux
dire, il y a il y a d'autres formes de
spiritualité. Le yoga aujourd'hui qui
est super démocratisé comme étant une
pratique à la mode et cetera,
initialement la salutation du soleil,
c'est une prière. Donc je veux dire, il
y a plein d'autres formes de
spiritualité qui sont aussi un peu des
sasses de sérénité, de coupure
de contrôle.
Ça dépend qui d'où ça vient.
Pourquoi les musulmans ils mangent pas
de porc ?
Euh pour les mêmes raisons que les
juifs,
c'est pas une réponse
euh pas une réponse, c'est une après
c'est ça fait l'objet d'interprétation
euh des textes et cetera, mais
c'est un il y a plein d'animaux en fait
qu'on a pas le droit de manger,
c'est-à-dire que
con, on a pas le droit de les manger.
Non mais par exemple, on a on considère
que tous les produits de la meral, donc
on a le droit de manger tous les
produits de la mer mais on peut pas
manger des animaux qui sont pas
herbivores par exemple.
Donc les animaux carnivores, on ne peut
pas les manger. Un
mangez pas de chat
de
de chat.
Non
non non. Bon de toute façon moi la
question est vite réglée. Je mange très
très très peu de viande et
c'est vraiment très ponctuel et j'aime
bien savoir d'où ça vient. Et puis en
fait la pratique même du hal, je veux
dire sur la question éthique, moi j'aime
beaucoup en débattre parce que
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment réduit à un
étiquetage, à un commerce aussi hein.
Euh effectivement, mais pour moi la la
la pratique du halal, c'est vraiment une
éthique d'abord et c'est euh le respect
de l'animal. C'est on n pas le droit par
exemple de sacrifier un animal si
d'autres animaux ou d'être d'autres
animaux enf être vivant. Mais en fait,
il y a quand même les humains qui sont
là au moment du sacrifice, mais on ne
pas on n pas le droit de le faire si on
a un autre animal qui est qui est
présent et qui peut en avoir conscience,
ne serait-ce que par le bruit, l'odeur,
par le le le fait qu'
rituel pour vous euh c'est pas cool.
Euh encore une fois, le sacrifice c'est
un moment où on est on témoigne aussi,
je veux dire un remerciement. Il y a une
prière qui a accompagné ce sacrific là
dans dans la dans la je dire dans les
dans les villages musulmans, dans les
dans le camp où moi j'ai grandi, quand
mon oncle quand mon oncle sacrifiait un
mouton ou un poule ou et bien c'était
euh c'était avec tout le respect, la
considération qu'on a pour ces animaux
qu'on a qu'on a dont on a pris soin
pendant plusieurs plusieurs années. Donc
c'est absolument pas des finalités
rentables capitalistiques
et c'est très ponctuel. Je veux dire la
pratique qu'on a dans le camp de manger
de la viande, c'est vraiment une fois
voilà puis une fois toutes les toutes
les de semaines 3 semaines à un moment
on va avoir un repas, il va y avoir de
la viande et c'est un moment assez
particulier et le sacrifice est
accompagné d'une prière et c'est
vraiment un moment où on a on n pas le
droit je dire le halal encadre vraiment
ça. On n pas le droit de le faire devant
un autre animal. on doit préserver les
autres animaux de cette de ce moment de
sacrifice. Donc vous voyez en fait enf
c'est pour dire qu'il y a plein de de
choses qui accompagnent le halal qui
aujourd'hui sont totalement déconnecté
de la pratique qui est une pratique
quasi exclusivement
industrielle. industriel effectivement
et donc de toute façon je veux dire que
ça soit sur l'aspect religieux ou pas,
que ce soit pour les croyants ou pas, la
la
tout le secteur industriel autour de la
viande est problématique et pose des
vraies questions aujourd'hui. Donc euh
il faut revenir à toutes les
recommandations qui sont celles de
moins manger de viande, avoir enfin je
revenir à ce qui est le cheminement
naturel d'un animal tout au long de sa
vie, son alimentation traditionnelle
donc éviter de le bourrer avec des de la
poudre faite de de d'hormones, de
médicaments et de voilà. Donc je dire
que ça soit pour le côté halal ou pour
le reste aujourd'hui on est dans une
vraie dérive en fait dans le rapport
même au vivant quel qu'il soit quoi.
Ta même.
On va passer à des sujets un peu plus
euh lourds même si l'abattage rituel
c'est un sujet un peu lourd.
On commence par l'économie.
C'est pas du tout mon domaine mais
vas-y, je je peux essayer de
Quelle est votre lecture de la On
parlera du conflit israelopenir bien
entendu après et de ce qui se passe à
gauche et à droite.
Ouais.
Mais pour comprendre les arcanes de
votre pensée, on va vous poser des
questions légères sur ce qui se passe en
ce moment.
Ouais.
La situation économique européenne,
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Où est-ce
qu'on va ? La France, où est-ce qu'elle
va ? Est-ce qu'à l'Europe on en discute
? On en discute pas ? Comment ça se
passe ? Alors bon, moi je vais être très
euh transparente, donc on va on va
aborder le sujet, mais c'est absolument
pas le sujet de mes commissions. Donc il
y a des commissions, pour le dire aux
gens euh qui nous regardent, on a une
vingtaine de commissions euh au
Parlement européen et quand on est élu,
on en a généralement deux au un député
peut siéger généralement dans deux
commissions. Donc pour ma part, c'est la
commission affaires étrangères et droits
humains. Et donc, ce sont des
commissions qui travaillent
exclusivement sur les relations disons
de l'Union européenne avec le reste du
monde. Donc on traite pas de la
situation des droits de l'homme au sein
de l'Union européenne, par exemple. Ça,
c'est la Commission Libée qui va traiter
de la question des libertés des par
exemple la question des violences
policières et cetera, ça va être traité
plutôt dans la liberté de manifestation,
d'expression qui des questions qui
peuvent se poser encore aujourd'hui dans
l'Union européenne puisque tout n'est
pas acquis. Ça va être traité plutôt
dans la commission de l'IB. Et donc euh
là, ces questions-là vont plutôt être
traitées dans la commission disons budge
qui traite vraiment du budget de de
l'Union européenne. Euh la situation de
la France pour commencer,
bon on est je crois que les prévisions
de la Banque de France pour 2027 c'est
une dette à 120 %. Je crois savoir que
les recommandations de Matriich, c'est
60 %. Et je crois savoir que la moyenne
européenne c'est autour de 80 87 %.
Donc ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une
tendance qui est bien au
plus haute que la recommandation
formulée par les Européens au-mêmes qui
est celle de 87 %.
La faute à qui comme dirait Berou c'est
la dette c'est un peu la faute de tous
les Français parce que c'est les
Français qui ont tout mangé. C'est c'est
la faute du fait que on a des
planificateurs en carton avec une prise
de un prisme de lecture comme ça.
Un prisme de lecture aussi pertinent
qu'un filet d' tiède. Ça vient de quoi ?
clientélisme politique.
Ce qui est très délicat avec la dette et
je pense que le régime présidentiel dans
lequel on est fait que on peut avoir une
succession d'hommes. Bon là que des
hommes
femmes
bah pour le moment c'est que des hommes.
Des hommes qui sont commande du pays et
puis qui vont faire un passage de 5 10
ans et puis qui viendront
systématiquement avoir le discours qui
consiste à dire mais je n'y suis pour
rien en fait. Moi, je récupère l'état du
pays tel qu'il est et puis je ne fais
que composer avec des trous à boucher,
quoi. Et donc, j'hérite de la politique.
S'il est de gauche, il va dire que c'est
la il hérite de la politique de la
droite, puis s'il est de droite, il va
dire qu'il a hérité de la politique de
la gauche. Donc donc c'est un problème
qui est beaucoup plus structurel et
malheureusement, il est trop souvent
instrumentalisé à ces finalités là.
C'est-à-dire on va avoir ce régime
présidentiel vraiment va toujours
présenter le président comme le sauveur
d'un moment mais qui va absolument pas
poser les questions structurelles qui se
posent. Et la question de la dette est
une question structurelle et le niveau
de la dette aujourd'hui euh j'ai pas le
chiffre exact, je sais qu'elle est à
3000 3300 mais j'ai pas le les deux
derniers. Oui 3300 effectivement
euh 9
3300 mais juste j'ai pas les deux
derniers chiffres 3000 325 je sais plus
exactement mais c'est
si on ajoute la dette privée on est à
combien ? Je sais pas du tout,
honnêtement. Euh je sais pas du tout.
Donc et cette dette là maintenant, il
faut quand même dire aussi
une chose, c'est que on ne il faut aussi
faire attention, je crois pour les
citoyens qu'on est au discours qui
consiste à convoquer cette question de
la dette pour soit dissuader l'opinion
de se mobiliser sur les questions
sociales, on en a besoin. On le voit
avec la retraite, on le voit sur la
question de la la précarité, on le voit
sur la la situation de la jeunesse, on
le voit sur la question des sans-abris,
on le voit sur la question du travail,
des soins effectivement, je veux dire
l'école, l'état des hôpitaux, enfin il y
a plein de sujets sur lesquels on a
intérêt à se mobiliser, se structurer en
tant que citoyen. Et je trouve que la
question de la dette est souvent aussi
convoquée pour empêcher ou justifier des
politiques d'austérité ou dissuader
enfin les présenter un peu comme des
irresponsables quoi. C'estàd que s'il
vise à demander un peu plus d'argent
public dans tel ou tel secteur, on va
tendance à voir enfin à les ridiculiser
à leur dire mais vous êtes complètement
inconscient, vous voyez pas le niveau de
la dette en France. Donc effectivement,
ça peut dissuader certains de
Si je vous dis que les intérêts de la
dette française par jour, c'est
l'équivalent à notre consommation
énergétique physique par jour.
Ouais.
Ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
Bah c'est vertigineux ça. J'ai pas je me
représente pas vraiment euh
les chiffres mais je crois que c'est une
proposition également de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de supprimer justement les euh
ces taux-là. Donc
quel taux ?
Mais les taux d'intérêt qu'il y a sur
sur cette dette là. Donc pour pouvoir
les réinvestir,
un coup de baguette de magique, on
répudie la dette. Comment ça se passe ?
Je sais pas franchement honnêtement je
pense qu'il faut faut quand on est en
politique, faut aussi faire preuve
d'humilité. Euh moi, je me présente pas
au présidentiel et je n'ai pas vocation
à à répondre à toutes les tous les
enjeux auxquels on est confronté,
citoyen, euh homme ou femme politique,
il faut s'entourer. Ça c'est c'est le
reproche que j'ai peut-être à formuler à
euh pas que à la à la macronie, je veux
dire, c'est une tendance qu'on a, c'est
de pas suffisamment s'entourer
d'experts.
Non mais je veux dire je veux dire
d'experts qui sont pas
qui ont pas un agenda politique de
droite ou de gauche de et la la société
française elle est riche de de d'experts
dans tous les domaines. Il faudrait
voilà sur la question de la dette par
exemple pas consulter un ou deux experts
sur ces questions économiques qui
seraient de son bord politique et qui va
en fait plutôt nous présenter un agenda
plus politique que
d'intérêt de de biens commun.
Sur cette questionlà, il faudrait voilà
réunir les plus grands experts sur ce
sujet et les mobiliser pour un intérêt
commun qui serait pas politique, qui
serait pas pour une politique voilà
guidée par l'agenda du du parti qui est
au pouvoir,
l'intérêt général, l'intérêt de la
patrie. Mais bien sûr, enfin je veux
dire la question de la dette, comme je
le disais, c'est une des questions qui
doit qui doit vraiment dépasser
l'appartenance des uns des uns et des
autres à un app à un appareil à un
mouvement. Euh donc c'est une des
questions sur lesquelles il faut
urgemment se réunir.
La défiance au gouvernement.
Oui.
Oui. Non non. Oui. Berou vous l'aimez
bien. Vous allez voter pour lui vous
voteriez pour lui.
Ça vous fait marrer
? Parce que vous Non mais parce que vous
vous l'avez écouté il y a 24 heures ou
48 he Oui oui. Je pense que il y a plus
tellement de doutes sur le fait queon
est sur un départ effectivement de
François Bairou. Bah là quand on regarde
les dynamiques de vote sur le vote de
confiance qui va présenter qui va
soumettre euh
on est on est sur
Est-ce que c'est un tour de magie ?
C'est un départ vraiment plutôt
plausible quoi.
Est-ce que c'est un tour de magie pour
dire voilà les agences de notation, je
crois que c'est le 10 ou le 12, ils vont
nous dégrader. Bah c'est parce que vous
avez pas voter la confiance et il faudra
vous en prendre qu'à vous-même. Oui, je
pense qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
instrumentalisation de l'échec politique
dans lequel et est et vraiment de
fonctionnement institutionnel presque
euh de ce blocage dans lequel on est euh
depuis euh la dissolution post
effectivement élection européenne euh
convoquée de mon enfin par Emmanuel
Macron, le président Emmanuel Macron.
Donc on est vraiment dans ce blocage, ça
fait maintenant quasiment 1 an. Euh et
euh je pense que la personne qui doit
vraiment rendre desc devant les
Français, c'est Emmanuel Macron. Et euh
je le dis euh de la façon la plus
sereine possible. Euh c'estàd que mais
c'est-à-dire que je pense que on l'a
déjà eu affaire à Barnier qui est parti.
On je je pense pas que ça va résoudre
grand-chose en réalité le départ de
Bairou. Je pense qu'il faut qu'il est
vraiment temps que Emmanuel Macron se
soucie aussi de l'opinion. C'est-à-dire
que là, on parle pas juste de la France
insoumise ou de cette gauche qui serait
qui serait fortement mobilisé sur cette
question. Si on regarde le dernier
sondage euh sur l'opinion des Français
sur ce sujet, c'est 67 % des Français
qui veulent le départ d'Emmanuel Macron
si Baou est
est destitué. enfin, je veux dire, s'il
a il perd cette confiance justement euh
qui va être voté euh le 8. Donc voilà,
je pense qu'en responsabilité, dans une
démocratie, dans un état qui fonctionne
bien, euh quand on a à plusieurs
reprises des gouvernements qui ne
fonctionnent pas, qui sont
dysfonctionnels, je veux dire que on
narrive pas à faire avancer le pays, on
narrive pas à composer avec toutes les
forces politiques en présence et que par
ailleurs, on n pas su respecter le
résultat des élections législatives. Je
veux dire, on peut dire ce qu'on veut
aujourd'hui de l'état du Nouveau Front
populaire et des discordes qu'il y a en
interne et désaccords et et c'est c'est
le jeu aussi démocratique de le
commenter et j'entends très bien, je
veux dire, les les les critiques qu'on
peut formuler sur cette union de la
gauche qui qui euh qui peine vraiment à
voilà à consolider une base euh une base
pour tenir sur cette union, sur cette
dynamique d'union. Euh donc ça c'est un
autre sujet mais euh il y a quand même
un sujet fondamental qui est celui de la
du respect en fait de des élections et
qui a un autre sujet aussi derrière qui
est celui de la de l'abstention.
Et moi je je pense qu'il y a deux
alertes en réalité là qui qu'il faut
absolument regarder. C'est premièrement
que nous sommes dans un pays qui euh
est prêt à faire voilà qui est prêt à à
s'asseoir en fait sur les résultats des
urdes. Pour moi, c'est vraiment un
danger, c'est un signal. Et le deuxième
le deuxième point d'alerte c'est le
niveau d'abstention. C'est près de 50 %
de de Français qui qu'on pas voté sur
les dernières élections.
Ça dépend des coups.
Oui, bien sûr, mais je veux dire là,
c'est une moyenne. Donc on peut vérifier
parce que j'ai pas une source très très
précise mais de tête, je sais que c'est
à peu près 50 % 48 ou 50 %.
Donc ça pour moi c'est aussi une vraie
alerte puisque tout le système euh
politique repose justement sur cette
mobilisation citoyenne visant à élire
ses représentants.
Si ça ne fonctionne plus, il faut aussi
qu'on avance vers d'autres choses.
Enfin, il faut il faut il faut vraiment
ouvrir le chantier de la démocratisation
de la politique.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on va avoir
des révoltes, des émeutes, un pays
paralysé d'ici 12 mois ?
Pourquoi d'ici 12 mois ? Parce que là,
on a déjà les chances du 10.
Le 10
c'est une mobilisation. Le 10,
je vous parle d'un M68 sous stéroïd avec
des camions de la gendarmerie qui
ressemble plus à des vabs avec des
mitraillettes sur le le toit plutôt
qu'autre chose.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'il y a une
tension euh une colère
et
une une un sentiment de trahison aussi.
pas que de la macronie de d'une classe
politique plus large euh
et qui se comprend qui se comprend et je
raison pourquoi
pourquoi parce qu'on a eu affaire à des
promesses non tenu parce qu'on a eu
affaire aussi à des gens qui sont au
pouvoir et qui sont qui ont un
fonctionnement de cast enfin je veux
dire la défense des intérêts privés
parti confondus
Oui. Oui oui oui oui oui totalement
totalement
tout parti confondu et puis des
promesses je veux dire qui sont pas tenu
la trahison aussi récente de de
d'Hollande sur
ennemi c'est la finance on s'attendait à
avoir vraiment presque quelque chose
quasi révolutionnaire de
voilà contre ce système capitaliste
néolibéral qui qui précarise de plus en
plus déjà les plus précaires et qui
donne de plus en plus au plus plus
privilégiés au plus riches et on s'end
on s'attendait vraiment à quelque chose
qui allait voilà mousculer un peu tout
ça et en fait pas du tout.
Charles Pasquis vous vous rappelez de
lui ?
Oui bien sûr.
Les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les
écoutent
les écoutent les croient.
Oui oui ben oui bien sûr.
Est-ce que ça vient d'un manque de
maturité de l'électorat français ?
C'estàd qu'on les on les a bercé de
douces mélopé pendant des années. Moi je
suis le président du pouvoir d'achat.
Moi je suis le président contre la
finance. Moi, je suis machin, je suis
bidu. Ouais,
mais déjà on a un problème sur sur ce
régime présidentiel. Moi, il me pose un
vrai problème et peut-être qu'on y
reviendra aussi tout à l'heure, mais
moi, ça fait un an que je suis en
politique et je l'ai souvent dit à
d'autres journalistes, mais je suis très
gênée par deux aspects. La
diabolisation, la place que je prends
dans les médias dans lesquels je ne
m'exprime jamais. Et quand vous
exprimez, des fois ça ça cartonne.
Oui, mais je veux dire,
je veux dire des il y a quand même des
médias comme le point JDD qui ont sorti
respectivement 45 et 60 papiers sur mois
en un an. C'est
vous faites vendre du papier.
Oui, mais je veux dire c'est c'est des
papiers où je m'exprime jamais. Ils me
disent pas "On fait un papier parle sur
votre vote, sur tel sujet, qu'avez-vous
à dire ?" Jamais. J'ai jamais eu la
possibilité de dire un mot dans ces
papiers. Donc et c'est des papiers quand
on les ouvre qui sont quand même très
problématiques sur certains angles. La
Jean-Marie Le Pen est revenu, il
s'appelle Rima Hassan. Euh la pieuvre de
l'Iran euh c'est des titres comme ça.
Pourquoi il vous appelle la pieuvre de
l'Iran ?
Euh parce que je suis régulièrement
sur fond vraiment de racisme et je pense
que le fantasme aussi qu'il y a autour
des Palestiniens euh on connaît pas très
bien les
Palestin ou du Esbola. Non, non, mais
attendez, les Palestiniens, on les
connaît pas très bien.
C'est une toute petite diaspora en
France et c'est une petite diaspora en
Europe et encore plus petite, plus
minuscule en France. Euh
combien je dirais euh mais je sais pas
exactement euh là, mais je j'ai une
étude récemment que j'ai lu sur ce
sujet. Euh
l'auteur palestinien qui a dirigé
l'étude mais chop mais dans les années
2000 c'était 5000 5000 Palestiniens.
Donc là on doit être je dirais dans les
20 25000 peut-être quelque chose comme
ça. Euh on pourra revérifier mais tout
ça pour vous dire que c'est une toute
petite diaspora. Sachant que le peuple
palestinien c'est plus de la moitié qui
est en exil et en diaspora. Euh peuple
palestinien, c'est au total c'est 15
millions à peu près. 15 millions. Vous
avez 6,8 millions de réfugiés. Donc
sous-statut de Lunoi, on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure, c'est l'agence
onusienne mandatée pour assister les
réfugiés palestiniens. Et donc si vous
allez sur son site ou sur le site duer,
il y a 6,8 millions de réfugi pal de
l'Iran. Pourquoi ?
Mais tu pour dire que déjà la la
Palestiniens sont très peu connus. Il y
a eu très peu de voix palestiniennes. Il
y a eu la shahid mais je veux dire
c'était une voix d'une autorité
palestinienne, donc une voix
diplomatique, une voix très voilà mais
je veux dire une palestinienne française
aussi euh qui euh enfin je veux dire ça
ça quasiment peu existé dans le débat
public. Donc je suis souvent soupçonné
de d'avoir un bah d'être un agent de
l'étranger ou d'être, ça a été titré par
ailleurs par ces journaux d'être un
ennemi un ennemi de l'intérieur.
Vous avez porté plainte ou pas ? Dans
certains cas, oui, maintenant je vous ai
donné la proportion 65 40 articles plus
tout le reste. Je je pas passer mon
temps
à travailler sur ça quoi. Donc j'ai
aussi mon travail moi au quotidien au
Parlement. Donc on essaie d'aller à
l'essentiel avec l'avocat pour se
protéger au maximum. Mais je veux dire,
je peux pas euh malheureusement je peux
pas non plus contrer tout ce qui tout ce
que je prends dans la gueule quoi.
Pardon pour du terme mais c'est un peu
cette réalité-là. Mais tout ça pour dire
que je reviens à l'origine présidentiel
pour pas perdre le ch
pour répondre à ça. Est-ce que vous avez
eu un régime de clarté face à ça ? C'est
vous avez déclaré vos finances, vous
avez publié cont
enquête de la DGSI ou de la DGSE ?
Est-ce qu'ils vous ont posé la question
si vous aviez été tamponné en Jordanie
ou vous avez été tamponné à gauche par
les J'aimerais bien qu'il présente des
conclusions d'enquête comme ça ça
clarifierait je pense les choses. Non,
mais pour être tout à fait transparente.
Oui, quand on arrive au Parlement, donc
on doit donner les indications sur ces
deux ces comptes bancaires, si on en a,
peu importe combien on en a, mais il
faut donner un compte bancaire en Suisse
?
Bah non,
au Luxembourg
non,
en Irlande ?
Non,
non, non, sûrement pas.
Est-ce qu' on vous a fait sauter vos
comptes en bananque en France ?
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que vous reveniez pas à votre
agence. Ah !
Ah non, non, mais non, non, j'ai
vraiment pas Non, non, j'ai vraiment pas
eu de
On compte ça en France. Oui oui bien
sûr. Euh oui je peux me donner la
banque. Bon je dire c'est pas c'est pas
un secret quoi. Mais hein on
donne pas de nom.
Ah on donne pas de nom mais voilà mais
oui ils sont en tout cas ils sont
publicité
ils sont en France euh
là actuellement
qui vienent dirant est-ce qu'il y a des
millions ? Il y a pas de millions.
Comment ça se passe ?
Non non il y a rien de qui viennent de
l'étranger. Il y a rien qui vienne de
l'étranger. Vraiment j'ai que mon
indemnité et c'est tout. Mais enf je
veux dire moi je serais très heureuse
qu'il y ait une enquête éventuellement
fouillée pour en finir mais ce que je
veux dire aussi c'est que vraiment c'est
bas c'est vraiment ça correspond au
moment dans lequel on est j'apprends
rien à personne. Quand on cite l'Agence
européenne des droits fondamentaux qui
dit que cré d'un musulman sur deux dans
son dernier rapport un musulman sur de
ciblé ou en tout cas ce à un moment dans
sa vie se retrouve confronté à des
discriminations. que ça soit contrôle
abusif, que ça soit une discrimination
de travail, que ça soit voilà mais donc
on est vraiment à un niveau je je pense
que hallucinant de cette construction de
l'ennemi de l'intérieur et qui est
concentré autour du du musulman, de
l'arabe, de l'immigré de et donc
la pie de l'Iran
donc forcément quelqu'un qui un peu mon
profil à un moment où on présente la
question palestinienne que sous l'angle
de la lutte contre le terrorisme. Donc
c'est vraiment une construction de
narratifs aussi très proche de la
propagande israélienne. On pourra y
revenir mais moi j'ai je l'ai dit depuis
le début, la moitié de mon travail sur
la question palestienne, j'entends pas
au Parlement mais la moitié de mon
travail c'est un travail de pédagogie et
de resituer le narratif palestinien.
Donc de redire en fait que ce ne sont
pas des terroristes, ce n'est pas un
peuple composé de terroristes qu'il y a
eu un mode d'opératoire terroriste qui
n'est pas exclusivement par ailleurs euh
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par mode
opératoire terroriste ? Bah le 7, j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire, c'est un mode
opératoire terroriste, mais je veux
dire, c'est euh comme les Algériens
quand ils font péter euh euh des cafés
euh des cafés ou des Français euh euh
des cafés de français en Algérie parce
qu' arrive à un moment où le FLN en fait
se dit "On est à plus de 100 ans de
colonisation, on se fait massacrer, on a
près d'un million de martyr."
Ces Français n'ont pas l'air de
comprendre que on a on veut notre
indépendance. Et donc je crois que il
faut resituer en fait aussi ces ces
mouvements. La NC de Nons Mondella a été
aussi classé terroriste. Vous avez vu
les vidéos euh vous parlez de
terrorisme, vous avez vu les les vidéos
juste je veux juste terminer, ça dérange
pas parce que je j'ai fait une toute
petite parenthèse sur moi mais ce que je
voulais juste conclure sur la le ce
qu'il y a de problématique dans ce
régime présidentiel euh où on a tout
doit être incarné par une personne et je
crois que c'est aussi ce système là qui
pousse les uns et les autres à dire
"Moi, je vais sauver la France, moi je
vais sauver le peuple français, je fais
des promesses et puis je pense que c'est
les équipes
font dire à ces à ses candidats un peu
tout et n'importe quoi. Alors si tu vas
aller convaincre les jeunes, il faut que
tu dises ça. Tu vas aller convaincre les
immigrés, il faut que tu dises ça.
Tu vas aller convaincre les écologist
les convaincre. Voilà. Exactement. Et en
fait je crois que c'est aussi la nature
du régime présidentiel
euh dans lequel on est.
C'est pour ou contre le fait que Macron
a fait fermer Fenonheim ? euh
forcément contre, je veux dire,
je veux dire les les conséquences que ça
a sur le plan social.
Faenheim
euh
nucléaire, tout ça, tout ça.
Oui, voilà. Mais je dire le le détail de
nombre de personnes concernées, je je
pourrais pas vous le dire, mais
production énergétique aussi.
Oui. Oui, mais je dire le nombre de
personnes concernées dans dans les
fermetures, j'ai j'ai pas le chiffre
exact. Si vous l'avez, je je le veux
bien. Mais on est dans une dynamique qui
date pas de Macron d'ailleurs qui
partait de Macron mais quand il était
pas président puisqu'il travaillait déjà
sur Mercy.
Oui. Oui. Quand il était à Bervait déjà
sur certains dossiers sur lesquels il
était déjà en en confrontation avec
notamment.
Son bureau était à côté de l'ascenseur
pour aller sur le lip
avec Montbourg. Je me souviens qu'il
avait déjà eu des conflits à ce
niveau-là. Donc euh on est dans un he le
problème de de l'industrie en France.
Oui, c'est un vrai c'est un vrai sujet
et pour moi c'est aussi une perte de
l'indépendance.
Une perte d'indépendance très concrète,
très euh très concrète et réelle en plus
des questions sociales que ça pose.
C'est-à-dire euh
revenons sur la pieuvre de l'Iran.
Oui, la pieuvre de l'Iran.
Donc la pieuvre de l'Iran. Euh pourquoi
on aurait imaginé ça comme titre à votre
avis ? Est-ce que l'Iran a financé tel
groupe, tel groupe, tel groupe ? Parce
que ils ont vu des mouvements financiers
sur votre compte, parce qu'ils ont vu
des gens qui traînent avec les Iraniens
qui sont venus vous voir le point JDD.
Non, je crois pas. Non, je s'il y avait
eu quelque chose, je pense que ça aurait
été largement relayé par des médias un
peu plus sérieux et d'investigation. Je
sais pas, je dire médiia part ou le
monde enfin un peu plus. Euh donc là,
c'est vraiment des articles très vides
et c'est des accusations qui sont
fondées sur rien. Moi, si vous voulez,
j'ai pas tellement envie de rentrer dans
les explication dès lors que je
considère que c'est une posture raciste.
Voilà. Enfin, je veux dire, on n' pas
expliqué le racisme. Pour moi, on est
dans ce que Sophie Bessie décrit comme
étant
la construction du nouvel autre en fait
en Europe qui est historiquement était
le juif qui était
autour du qui on a construit tous les
fantasmes
antisémites
et là on est dans une dans une pente euh
plus ou moins enfin qui reprendre ces
codes là et c'est une historienne, elle
l'explique très bien dans son livre sur
le sur la la convocation de du terme la
civilisation judéo-chrétienne où elle
elle explique que c'est vraiment euh
c'est plutôt convoqué à des à des à des
fins politiques en réalité justement
pour isoler ou laisser penser que ce
nouvel autre aujourd'hui en fait dans
nos sociétés c'est le musulman. C'est le
musulman et alors que la situation
judéocchrétienne démontre qu'elle n'a
jamais vraiment existé et qu'en fait
vous parlez latin
l'antisémitisme non j'ai fait latin mais
je ne parle pas
ça veut dire quoi franchement j' revenon
revenons au mode opératoire terroriste.
Nous on a on a vu les vidéos qui avaient
été tournées par les mecs qui
débarquaient en ULM pour aller massacrer
des gamins qui faisaient un concert.
On a revu
la même symbolique
que les mecs qui allaient massacrer les
les radicaux islamistes qui allaient
massacrer des gens en Syrie.
C'est-à-dire l'hypercératose sur le
front, la bear qui descend bien loin,
les mêmes gestes, les mêmes expressions
et ainsi de suite. Et je rentre pas dans
les détails de pauvre gamin de cadavre
désarticulé au fond au cul des 44 et on
rentre en détail.
Ça c'était qui ? C'était le Hamas.
C'était des mecs du Hamas qui avaient
été recrutés dans d'autres mouvements
djihadistes. C'était quoi ?
Alors ce qu'explique très bien euh
l'historien Jean-Pierre Filiou ou euh
d'autres mais c'est que ce n'est pas que
le Hamas qui a commandité et préparé
l'attaque du 7, c'est vraiment toutes
les composantes politiques de la société
palestinienne.
Qui est-ce qui les a coordonné ? Oui,
bien sûr que le Hama c'était le le
parti, disons ou le mouvement le plus le
plus le plus structuré, on va dire, dans
Mais c'est une coalition.
C'est une coalition.
et les différentes composantes de
politiques de la cité palestienne
présente à Gaza ont participé à la
préparation de ces attaques. Donc
maintenant, le vrai sujet
autour de cette question
du 7 octobre
et de la qualification du terrorisme,
c'est de resituer
euh historiquement
un les conditions de création du Hamas,
de les modalités de les conditions de
son développement parce que c'est pas
tout de créer un mouvement, je veux dire
Après, il faut
financer,
il faut savoir comment il se développe,
qui le soutient, à quelle finalité
et euh
resituer, je veux dire,
l'hypocrisie aussi et
l'instrumentalisation qu'il y a
notamment des occidentaux. Donc je vais
juste développer ces trois points.
Le Ramas, l'injustice du peuple
palestinien, elle commence en 1948 voire
même avant. Si j'ai un peu le temps de
dérouler, je pense que c'est c'est très
important de le comprendre.
l'injustice du peuple palestinien. Donc
il y a l'émergence du mouvement sioniste
qui est un mouvement politique et
national, nationaliste disons, qui a euh
qui émerge. La figure qui fait émerger
cette pensée, c'est Théodore Herz qui
est un journaliste hongrois qui fait un
constat très juste. C'est-à-dire qu'il
dit "C'est de plus en plus compliqué
pour les juifs de vivre en Europe qui
sont de plus en plus persécutés."
Ça, on est dans le quand il écrit son
livre l'état des juifs, c'est en 1880
euh
16 ou 14 96 je crois. Et c'est quoi
l'élément déterminant pour pour
C'est quoi l'élément déterminant pour
Thoder Herz ? C'est l'affaire Defus
qui a lieu
en 80 1884
et il publie son livre en 96.
Et l'élément déterminant pour lui, c'est
l'affaire de Rfus. C'est vraiment le le
l'événement qui va le paralyser euh dans
sa enfin dans sa pensée qui consiste à
dire il va il va il va il va penser ce
ce sionisme politique.
94 voilà 94 il va penser ce cynisme
politique et il va le baser sur
plusieurs piliers. Parmi ces piliers,
c'est l'impossible
assimilation des juifs dans les sociétés
européennes.
La nécessité, la spécificité du peuple
juif et la nécessité de créer un foyer
national juif. Et parmi ces pilers-là,
il y a la création d'un nationale juif
en Palestine. Et il va être aidé par les
britanniques qui vont avoir accès avec
un mandat colonial, il faut le rappeler
qui est très répressif, un mandat
colonial en Palestine à la fin de la
chute la chute de l'Empire ottoman et
qui va être un mandat qui va être imposé
avec des accords secrets conclus avec la
France. C'est les accords Sispico de
1916 où il va avoir un découpage de la
région et et qui vont défaire en fait
les Arabes qui eux appelaient à à qui on
avait promis par ailleurs les
Britanniques et les Français avaient
promis aux Arabes euh on va vous aider à
vous défaire de l'Empire ottoman pour
que vous ayez cette fameux grand état
unitaire arabe et finalement on va les
trahir et on va découper le territoire
comme on a fait par ailleurs sur le
continent africain ou sur d'autres
régions et on va réprimer massivement et
dans le sang les révoltes de ces peuples
là. Pour les Palestiniens, c'est 369. La
grande révolte palestinienne, le quier
palestinien que je porte va devenir un
symbole de la résistance palestinienne
bien avant la création de l'État
d'Israël. C'est à ce moment-là, il va y
avoir une grève de 6 mois de tout le
pays qui va être paralysée par les
Palestiniens qui contestent justement à
la fois l'immigration juive qui est
impulsée par le mandat britannique en
euh alliance avec le mouvement sioniste
et euh le mandat colonial britannique
qui les réprime dans le sang et qui fait
obstacle à leur revendication
d'indépendance et nationaliste. Donc
tout ça tout pour dire que il y a quand
même ce ce contexte là où les paliens
sont d'ors et déjà ciblés, massacrés,
pas consulté. Le plan de partage de 1947
aux Nations-Unies, les palissiens ne
sont pas consultés. On leur impose un
plan de partage. Et je veux dire dès
maintenant, on y reviendra peut-être
après, que les deux propositions qui
sont formulées par les Nations-Unies, le
comité d'experts des Nations- Unies,
quand il voit effectivement tous les
conflits qu'il y a générés entre le
mouvement sioniste et qui va devenir euh
l'État d'Israël et les Palestiniens, ils
vont proposer deux solutions.
Aujourd'hui, tout le monde parle de la
solution à deux états, mais en réalité,
le comité d'experts propose deux
solutions. Et la première, c'est un état
unique. Et cette solution va être
rejetée par le vote des États euh
présents. Et c'est une 38 États, je
crois, qui votent à ce moment-là. Il
faut rappeler quand même que tous les
pays du sud global euh étaient encore
colonisés, hein. Donc euh ils avaient
pas, on vo au chapitre, ils pouvaient
pas s'exprimer. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut quand même resituer l'agenda aussi
occidental impérialiste dans le soutien
au mouvement sioniste au moment où la
Palestine est sous mandat colonial. Donc
pour revenir au fait que l'injustice du
peuple palestinien, elle commence même
bien avant 48. La grosse plie du peuple
palestinien c'est souvent cité 1948
parce que c'est la reconnaissance de la
création d'État d'Israël et l'expulsion
de plus de la moitié du peuple
palestinien qui ne pourra jamais revenir
sur cette terre. Et pire que ça, il va
littéralement être pillé les biens de ma
famille. Il y a une loi euh qui a été
adoptée en Israël qui s'appelle la loi
des absents cyniquement en 1951. Donc on
est très peu de temps après l'exode des
Palestiniens. Israël qui se défend
toujours de ne pas avoir voulu expulser
les Palestiniens, de ne pas avoir voulu
les défaire de leur terre. Bah on
s'étonne quand même qu'elle a que
c'était ce même état adopte 2 ans après
la Nakba au moment où les Palestiens
sont encore dans la boue et dans les
tentes.
Vous parlez de votre famille du côté
maman côté papa.
on
j'ai trois grands-parents. On a le temps
de venir revenir en détail mais j'ai une
grand-mère qui est syrienne
qui est
On dit que votre papa est syrien.
Ah non non non.
Il il est de où votre papa ?
Non non c'est du côté de ma mère
justement.
Pu dire à gauche à droite sur internet
que votre papa était syrien qui
travaillait pour Bacher et la salle.
Oui j'y reviendrai. Je veux juste dire
que je revien juste après.
Maman était riche et que machin
ça serait. Donc je veux juste revenir
sur ça, donc la la l'historicité
vraiment de de de cette question de la
de l'injustice faite au peuple
palestinien euh il y a eu un un cumul
important. Donc le le Hamas, on
reviendra tout à l'heure peut-être sur
euh toutes les grandes étapes et
l'autorité palestinienne, les accords
d'Ol, toutes les tentatives faites aussi
par les les Palestiniens visant à
négocier avec les Israéliens qui, je le
redis, sont quand même leurs
colonisateurs, sont quand même leur les
occupants de leur terre. C'est c'est
assez
Israéliens.
Mais bien sûr, enfin, je veux dire les
Palestiniens,
quand on écoute les Israéliens,
on remonte à l'empereur machin.
Non, mais attendez, la Bible n'est pas
un cadastre hein, sinon on est on est
proche de Daesh, je veux dire, on est
proche de de Daesh qui se pointe dans
des régions pour dire on va mettre le
Khalifa, on va réinstaurer le Khalifat
et puis les textes disent et non, je
suis désolé, la Bible n'est pas un
cadastre. Et par ailleurs, Ilan Papé qui
est lui juif et israélien qui a fini par
quitter Israël parce qu'il ne pouvait
même plus enseigner l'histoire de la
Nakba
ce thème est censuré. Il dit les
sionistes,
Jésus c'est pas le roi des juifs.
Il il résume ça en une phrase très
intéressante. Il dit les sionistes ne
sont ne croient pas en Dieu mais ils
vous diront que Dieu leur a promis la
terre. Et ça c'est c'est très drôle
parce que c'est vraiment ce qui se passe
avec Israël, c'est que Théodore Herz
lui-même n'est pas
J'ai jamais fait shabbat avec des juifs.
Théodore Herz. Non mais on sépare deux
choses qu'il y ait des croyants d'une
part. Voilà. Mais
vous az déjà fait shabbat avec des juifs
?
Bah j'ai j'ai oui j'ai des connaissances
juives dans ma vie.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez déjà fait
chabbat ?
C'est le le
déjà été invité. Euh non
non mais je veux dire ça je vois pas ce
que ça apporte. Je veux dire, c'est
comme si je disais pour comprendre une
région d'un pays arabe, il faudrait que
tu étais fait le musulman ou laï avec
avec un musulman, ça n'importe rien.
Et faire le ramadan avec les musulmans
ça n'importe rien. On a incompréhension
parce que là c'est très dangereux. Là
c'est très dangereux parce que tu fais
je parce que le ramadan avec les
musulmans, c'est pas intéressant. C'est
intéressant, mais je veux dire là, en
terme de compréhension de la question
israélo-palestinienne, c'est pas ça qui
est important, c'est la question du
sionisme politique. Vous avez reçu Rony
Broman et Alain Grèche ici qui ont été
très
pertinents sur ce sujet et il faut faire
attention aux amgames qui sont faits
entre confession et adhésion à une
idéologie politique. L'idéologie
politique qui porte le projet israélien
jusqu'à aujourd'hui, hein, c'est le
sionisme. Et donc c'est ça qu'il faut
euh c'est à ça qu'il faut s'intéresser.
Et euh ce sionisme-là euh la dimension
nationale à la limite. Même moi si vous
voulez réfugi de la l'INKba, descendante
de la Nakba, je peux comprendre je peux
comprendre que une population bien que
ils aient été contredits et contestés y
compris par les juifs eux-mêmes. Je veux
dire, c'est très minoritaire
initialement le mouvement sioniste quand
il émerge. Il est même perçu comme un
mouvement comme une réponse de la
bourgeoisie libérale là où tu as le
bound par exemple sous l'empire qui est
l'Union des travailleurs juifs qui
s'oppose fermement au mouvement
sioniste, qui dit "Mais en fait notre
libération viendra pas de ce petit
cercle de de d'intellectuels qui pensent
que on va retourner vivre ou
aller refaire un état pour le peuple
juif en Palestine.
Ils pensent que leur libération va se
passer dans les luttes internes en
réalité, c'est-à-dire penser vraiment
des sociétés qui ne soient plus
antisémites. Donc donc ça, je veux dire,
il faut aussi le resituer. Je voulais
juste citer un homme que je trouve très
intéressant sur ce sujet qui est Abraham
Shalom Yahoua qui est un juif
palestinien qui a rencontré à plusieurs
reprises reprises Théodore Herz et qui
s'est opposé au sionisme que c'est un
linguiste expert des questions
euh euh des des
même langage interreligieux. Enfin son
profil est assez passionnant et c'est un
juif palestinien et qui va dire à
Théodorell,
il est voué à l'échec en fait votre
projet du sionisme et puis il leur
reproche de vouloir occidentaliser les
juifs orientaux. C'est-à-dire que lui en
tant que juif oriental, il ne se
reconnaît absolument pas dans le
sionisme. Et ça c'est quelque chose de
fondamental pour comprendre tout le
racisme qu'il y a aujourd'hui dans
l'état d'Israël. Il est pour moi, pas
que pour moi, il est structurellement
ancré dans la doctrine sioniste
elle-même. Et pour ça, il faut regarder
le traitement qu'à réserver l'État juif
au euh aux juifs orientaux, que ça soit
aux yéménites, aux juifs yéménites où on
sait que euh il y a eu des euh des
plusieurs milliers d'enfants qui ont été
arrachés à leur famille. C'est une
affaire d'état quoi en Israël vraiment.
on a il a fallu déclassifier des
archives et il y a eu des grosses
associations qui se sont structurées
pour obtenir justement l'accès à ces
archives là et qui documente qu'il y a
eu plus de 60 60 établissements de santé
officiels hein de l'État qui ont été
impliqués dans euh dans la la comment on
appelle ça ? la le kidnapping vraiment
enfin pas des kidnappings parce qu'on
faisait croire aux familles que les
enfants étaient morts. C'estd qu'on les
gardait dans des crèches, on faisait
croire aux familles que les enfants
étaient morts et en fait après on les
réutilisait pour des adoptions à des
familles juives européennes. Il y a
aussi le cas de la stérilisation forcée
des femmes juives éthiopiennes qui est
là aussi parfaitement documenté. J'ai
pas les chiffres dans le détail mais je
veux dire ça aussi c'est une affaire
d'état. Vous retrouvez très facilement
des sources là-dessus. Et il y a euh un
film que j'ai vu il y a quelques années,
le nom de la réalisatrice Messia mais
peut-être peut-être le retrouver pendant
qu'on discute euh qui est porte sur les
misraim donc qui sont les les juifs le
nom qu'on donne aux juifs orientaux et
Sophie Bessi est elle-même juif juive en
fait. Et elle explique elle aussi très
bien que euh
Israël en fait dès le début a eu un
racisme envers les juifs orientaux.
C'estàd qu'on voyait comme des Ben
Gouron qui est le fondateur, le premier
ministre d'Israël qualifiait justement
les juifs éthiopiens de de de de
primitif de primitif et donc il ils ont
ils avaient un un jusqu'à maintenant il
y a un racisme entre les séparates, les
askenages et et donc et le ces misraim
en fait qui sont les juifs orientaux ont
été très très discriminés et les juifs
du Maroc pareil qui ont été concentrés
dans des des camps de transit à
à HOD justement et c'est c'est un
l'élément historique pour moi qui permet
le mieux de comprendre ce qu'il y a de
racisme justement dans
la doctrine sioniste qui a été pensée
par des juifs occidentaux et qui euh
s'est inspiré des nationalismes
européens
qui à l'air de la colonisation quoi.
Donc c'était parfaitement normal au
moment où Théodore Rel pense un projet
colonial, c'est parfaitement normal pour
lui de dire "Bon ben on va aller
s'installer là-bas et puis on va
s'occuper des barbares palestiniens qui
sont là-bas et nous on est la
civilisation." Et jusqu'à maintenant
cette rhtorique est convoquée par
Nathanahu lui-même qui dit quand il fait
une interview en France, il dit "Nous
faisons avec les Arabes Palestiniens ce
que vous vous devriez faire avec vos
banlieux, avec les noirs et les Arabes
de vos banlieux." C'està-dire si tu lis
c'est sourcé ça.
Ah oui oui, c'est c'est l'interview
qu'il a donné à LCI en visio
au moment où nous avions manifesté par
ailleurs pendant la campagne pensant
qu'il était là présent. En fait, c'était
un enregistrement qu'il avait fait. Il
dit "Nous nous faisons avec eux ce que
vous aimeriez faire en fait avec ces
Arabes et noirs qui sont dans vos
banlieux." Et donc l'article de Alain
Grèche que je vous recommande vraiment
de lire,
l'article de Alain Grèche que je vous
recommande vraiment de lire qui est
intitulé de la colonisation
à l'appartide,
il retrace justement tout ce qui a guidé
le projet sioniste et israélien
politiquement, j'entends euh
sur cette question du racisme parce que
si aujourd'hui on parle d'apartide
depuis quelques années, si on parle
d'apartide, c'est quoi le l'apartide ?
On c'est euh la communauté des experts
qui travaillent sur ce sujet. Donc je
peux vous citer le rapport d'Amnistie
International, je peux vous citer le
rapport de Human Red Watch, je peux vous
citer le rapport de Betselem qui ONG
israélienne, je peux vous citer le
rapport de l'ONG Al-Hak euh qui est une
ONG palestinienne et plus encore plus
encore les Sud-Africains eux-mêmes qui à
la tribune euh de leur plaidoirie à la
CJI disent en plus de la question du
génocide qu'on présente au moment où ils
ont présenté l'affaire du sur le risque
de génocide, disent eux-mêmes ce que
vivent les Palestiens, c'est un
appartide voire même il est plus
grave enfin plus
avancé que celui que nous nous avons
connu. Et on a également la dernière le
dernier avis de la Cour internationale
de justice portant sur les conséquences
de la colonisation
euh euh la colonisation et de
l'occupation par Israël en territoire
palestinien. Et la CJ dit en fait, une
des conséquences, c'est qu'on arrive à
un régime de séparation, quoi. Donc,
c'est-à-dire des routes pour les
Palestiniens, des routes pour les colons
israéliens, un tribunal militaire pour
les Palestiniens, un tribunal civil pour
les Israéliens et et on a vraiment une
architecture vraiment de l'appartille
d'aujourd'hui qui est parfaitement
documentée pour laquelle il faudrait
vraiment revenir en détail parce que
c'est un sujet moi que sur lequel j'ai
beaucoup travaillé et qui euh
juridiquement il faut vraiment s'y s'y
attarder. Donc là, je veux pas faire
trop long si on veut revenir là-dessus,
mais juste peut-être conclure sur le
fait que il faut avoir à l'esprit que la
bataille que mène le peuple palestinien,
c'est bien entendu contre une entité
coloniale.
Et moi je peux vous dire est-ce que
c'est une raison pour être
et qui projette sur eux du racisme et un
nettoyage ethnique depuis le début
depuis le début. Est-ce
est-ce que c'est une raison, si je vous
entends bien, est-ce que c'est une
raison pour être plus bourreau que le
bourreau ?
Nous, on a été profondément choqué
avec les momes qui dansaient au concert
et et il voyait des ULM débarqué. Nous,
on a regardé toutes les vidéos des des
gamins qui filaient les ULM. Est-ce que
c'était une raison pour aller attraper
la petite la petite allemande la
désosser au fond d'un 44, mettre le
doigt en l'air en faisant est-ce que
c'était une raison
pour aller faire ça ?
Non, clairement non. Moi, je l'ai déjà
dit euh tenter de contextualiser et
d'expliquer. Moi, ce que je reproche
surtout aux autorités françaises et plus
largement aux occidentaux, c'est euh
l'hypocrisie autour de ce sujet.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ont tenté de
bayonner vraiment euh euh ces libertés
qui consistaient, enfin, je veux dire
même de de d'opinion ou d'expression qui
consiste à un moment donné à
recontextualiser et à expliquer. Mais
expliquer n'est pas justifié. Moi, je
peux vous dire et ça fait pas de moins
une hypocrite, vous dire euh
premièrement la lutte armée est
légitime. Deuxièmement, c'est pas parce
que la lutte armée est légitime qu'on a
le droit de tout faire. Troisièmement
que effectivement on caractérise ça en
crime de guerre
bien entendu, que les responsables
doivent être poursuivis. Bon,
aujourd'hui, ils sont tous morts mais en
tout cas sur le principe si.
S'ils sont tous morts, pourquoi il y a
encore des otages ?
Non, mais je veux dire sur les
commanditaires. Euh
c'est qui les commanditaires ? Ben, il y
avait effectivement sinois, il y avait
les haut responses responsables, je veux
dire. du des des branches armées du du
Hamas, du islamique et cetera. Donc
ensuite euh la question enfin donc moi
je peux très bien vous dire comme je
disais que la lutte armée elle est
légitime. La résolution de tête, je vais
juste m'assurer pour pas dire de bêtises
devant tout le monde, la lutte armée,
c'est la résolution des Nations-Unies
3070, tout le monde peut s'y référer
de 1973.
D'accord. la lutar.
Non, attendez, je termine sur ça parce
que c'est très important s'allé avec des
djihadistes.
Non mais attendez, ça c'est il faut
comprendre aussi l'évolution du
désespoir palestinien.
C'est une raison désespéré. Alors, il y
a un proverbe malien qui dit quand tu te
couches le soir avec le diable, le
lendemain matin, tu sens encore le
diable. Quand je vous quand quand on on
dit que la question de l'injustice du
peuple palestinien commence
dès euh dès 1920,
est-ce que c'est une raison bourou que
le
bour mais attendez, dès 1920, on est
déjà dans une forme d'injustice parce
que là, les accords saisp sont conclus.
On a la déclaration de Balfour,
c'est-à-dire la promesse des
Britanniques faite au mouvement sioniste
de on va créer un état et puis les
Palestins sont réduits à une communauté
alors qu'ils sont alors qu'on est à 5 %
de population juives sur tout le
territoire de la Palestine à ce
moment-là. Donc quand on est à des
décennies, des décennies de meurtre, de
violence,
de pillage de terre, de d'injustice, je
veux dire les Palestins, moi je viens de
des Palestiniens disent de l'extérieur
des camps, qui s'est un jour souci de du
fait que mes grands-parents soient
enterrés dans un camp de réfugié. qui
s'est soucié que euh mes parents étaient
nés dans ce camp de réfugié, que moi mon
père il vit encore et que il va très
probablement être enterré dans ce camp
de réfugié et que de toute sa vie, il
n'aura rien vu d'autre que ce camp de
réfugié et il n'aura pas vécu autrement
que comme un un apatride, c'est-à-dire
un un indésirable. Donc qui se soucie de
ça depuis 75 ans ? Donc il faut
comprendre que le Hamas
bénéficier du rapprochement familial.
Non mais moi je suis arrivé dans un
contexte particulier. Ma mère a divorcé
de mon père, elle est venue d'abord
toute seule et
elle a pris la charge des enfants et lui
rester dans le camp. Mais de toute
façon, il n'en sortira pas. Je veux
dire, je l'ai retrouvé justement il y a
après 20 ans d'exil, 20 ans de
séparation parce que la situation
administrative et cetera faisait que
c'était pas possible d'y aller et la
situation de la Syrie faisait que
c'était très compliqué d'y aller. Donc
je l'ai retrouvé après 20 ans d'exil et
puis
il me dit
m'a dit quelque chose de très
intéressant.
Il m'a dit "Oui, pour nous c'est dur
ici, pour vous c'est pire."
Je dis "Mais
vous venez traversé, il y a eu il y a eu
quand même des conditions très
difficiles dans les camps palestiniens.
Le camp d'yarmou et le camp de Damas a
été sous siège a été bombardé par le par
le régime de Bachar Alassad. Et le camp
dans lequel moi je suis né ou dans
lequel j'ai grandi, il a failli être
détruit parce qu'on est collé un autre
camp qui s'appelle euh le camp de
Handalat. Et lui, il a été totalement
euh
qui a un autre nom qui est le camp de
Aeltal qui a été totalement détruit. Je
l'ai visité 80 % totalement détruit
parce qu'il y a eu des affrontements
dedans. Et donc les réfugiés de Haneltal
sont venus euh se réfugier dans notre
camp et il y a eu plusieurs fois euh
voilà des sièges, des checkpoints
imposés et cetera. Et il me dit "Pour
nous ça a été dur et c'est toujours dur
mais pour vous c'est pire." Et je lui
dis "Mais comment ça ?" et il me dit
il me dit vous avez vous êtes dans un
2uxe exil c'est-à-dire que pour lui et
je comprends et ça on on pourra
l'aborder aussi tout à l'heure c'est que
les camps palestiniens les camps de
manière générale et ça c'est Michel
Algerier qui a beaucoup travaillé euh
sur cette question des camps de
l'encampement du monde. C'est un
anthropologue passionnant sur cette
question.
Vous avez lu Jean Zigler ? Oui, oui. Et
puis il a fait une grosse critique oui.
Euh des camps notamment euh en Europe.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Mais Michelet, c'est
vraiment sur les camps gens, si tu nous
entends, on t'embrasse
la dynamique des camps euh dans le
monde. Et donc les camps palestiniens,
c'est vraiment des microsciétés,
presque des micro états dans l'État
quoi. Et donc, il y a une solidarité, on
a c'est des bouts de Palestine en fait.
C'est des bouts de Palestine errantes
avec des bouts de Hamas à l'intérieur.
Non, pas des non parce que les comités
ce qui la présence politique dans les
les camps palestiniens, c'est les
comités populaires palestiniens. Donc il
dépendent de le
politique ou armée ou les deux
comités populaire. Alors, il y a bien
sûr des camps où il y a des armes et
d'ailleurs les Palestiniens
effraent
souvent les régimes arabes parce qu'ils
sont connus pour je c'est c'est nerveux
mais ils sont connus pour
je pense pour être aussi très déterminé
dans leur lutte.
C'est pour ça que les pays autour ne
veulent pas des Palestiniens.
Oui. Non mais oui bien sûr parce que
quand ils ont été en Jordanie c'était
presque un état dans l'état. et euh et
donc il voulaient destituer le roi
et ils sont très jusqu'au bouthiste quoi
dans leur lutte les Palestiniens et ils
font et je pense aussi que la cause
palestinienne de par
c'est un sondage que j'ai partagé là il
y a quelques quelques semaines sur sur
mes réseaux c'est un sondage fait par un
institut la censure arabe de Washington
je crois qu'il faudrait juste rechecker
l'intitulé
je sais pas je pense que c'est public
que c'est rattaché a des recherches
universitaires donc qui selon lequel 98
% de la population de l'opinion publique
arabe est euh
très euh
proalestinien considérant que la cause
palestienne est une cause euh arabe
commune plus encore que euh
qu'il s'oppose à la normalisation. Et
donc je pense que les régimes aussi
arabes ont très très peur de leur
opinion et ils savent pertinemment que
la présence des Palestiniens ou des
injustices répété contre les
Palestiniens peut vraiment faire
basculer un pays quoi.
Est-ce qu'ils ont peur aussi parce qu'il
y a des frères musulmans qui se cachent
chez les Palestiniens et que il y a des
des djihadistes qui se cachent au sein
des Palestiniens ?
Oui. Alors ça vraiment la convocation
pour revenir sur l'histoire de la lutte
palestinienne. La lutte palestin
est-ce que la lutte palestinienne c'est
pas aussi un cheval de 3 ?
des djihadistes, des islamistes
radicaux.
Ouais. Non, mais bien sûr, je pense
qu'il faut avoir une critique objective
de la convocation de la référence
religieux de la question palestinienne.
Euh, ça, il faut être
complet là-dessus et il faut être
complet dans la manière aussi de s'y
intéresser, pas non plus caricatural
qu'on considère à dire c'est des barbus,
c'est des djihadistes et puis ils disent
Allah Akbar. Il faut faut être plus
précis que ça, plus minutieux que ça.
Historiquement,
ça veut dire quoi l'hypercarotose sur le
front ?
Euh
et bien bah c'est la pratique
rigouriste de la prière, c'est le
frottement répété de du front au tapis.
Donc historiquement, la lutte
palestienne, c'est une lutte qui
s'inscrit qui est plutôt une lutte euh
qui s'inscrit dans les traditions plutôt
révolutionnaire, marxiste
et très très loin de convoquer le
lexique religieux, voire même il y avait
des oppositions très très fortes entre
les leaders de la cause nationale
palestinienne et ceux qui voulaient
convoquer
le prisme religieux, disons de la cause
paltienne, c'estàd c'est une cause
religieuse. chose. Donc pendant très
longtemps, c'était inexistant ou très
minime. En tout cas, ça pesait pas dans
le dans le dans l'opinion palestinienne.
En 87, date de création du Hamas, c'est
effectivement dans un contexte régional
où il y a les sorts du des frères
musulmans.
Euh votre avis sur les frères musulmans.
Les frères musulmans, il faut reprendre
ce que certains sociologues disent,
c'est qu'il faut distinguer
votre avis. Oui, mais bon, je suis de
cet avis-là, c'est qu'il faut distinguer
les frères musulmans de là-bas et d'ici.
Ils n'ont absolument rien à voir.
C'est-à-dire que vous avez les frères
musulmans qui sont dans les pays arabes
qui sont euh
pour les pouvoirs en place, une menace
parce qu'ils peuvent avoir recours
effectivement à des
au terrorisme, des modes opératoire
terroristes. ça a été le cas, compris
pour Nasser qui leur avait pour autant
euh offert une tribune dans des
coalitions et cetera et qui ont fini
par le considérer
comme un traître parce qu'il était pas
allé au bout de leur demande et cetera.
Et elle s'adapte, elle s'adapate qu'il
va succéder à à Nasser. Donc euh mais
donc les frères musulmans de là-bas sont
structurés politiquement. C'est des
partis politiques qui mobilisent des
millions et des millions de gens. Il se
finance comment ?
Euh par
je sais pas précisément là aujourd'hui
dans l'état des lieux dans chaque pays
et cetera, mais
je pense comme beaucoup de parties par
les adhésions, par les événements, par
je veux dire, c'est pas rien. Je veux
dire, les frères musulmans dans dans
certains pays, c'est quand même des
millions des millions de gens qui qui
sont mobilisés. Donc
quel pays ?
Ben ça a été le cas de l'Égypte. Vous
avez aussi des influences récemment post
printemps arabe, ça a été le cas en
Tunisie.
Vous avez voilà des influences qui ont
émergé.
Non, il faut vraiment distinguer si vous
voulez l'influence qui peut y avoir euh
dans des opinions
euh euh des opinions auprès de la
communauté musulmane ou des communautés
musulmanes. D'ailleurs, faut pas
l'essentialiser cette communauté
musulmane. Et euh il faut différencier
ça des frères musulmans structurés en
appareil politique
qui par ailleurs sont pas liés hein.
Enfin, c'est je je
le dernier rapport là qui est sorti sur
les frères musulmans, ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'en fait
un rapport de qui ?
De je sais plus quel de du ministère de
l'intérieur mais je les différents
chercheurs qui ont travaillé dessus.
Alors il y a cette femme là dont
j'oublie tout le temps le nom. Euh
cheveux court quel cheveux court mais je
sais pas si tu peux me retrouver le nom.
qui cheveux courts, blonde qui est une
sociologue qui est spécialiste sur ces
questions qui intervient souvent sur les
plateaux télé pour toujours présenter la
question de frères musulmans comme la
menace numéro 1 en France. Bon euh
concrètement ce rapport il dit qu'il y a
pas il y a pas de menace imminente et
par ailleurs, il y a pas de de lien
structurel euh entre entre des des
dérives qui peut y avoir dans la
pratique religieuse et euh
et l'historicité du des frères musulmans
en tant que parti, en tant que mouvement
dans certains pays. Donc juste pour moi,
il faut il faut faire cette cette
séparation-là. Et je veux juste finir
mon propos sur le fait que la cause
palestinienneement
c'est une cause donc nationale qui
décolonial qui l' toujours qui est une
cause
pour une indépendance
qui a appris aussi à concilier avec les
Israéliens puisque Arafat finit aussi
par signer les accords de slow. Les
accords de SL sont pas imposés aux
Palestiniens. Les Palestiniens acceptent
euh de renoncer à la lutte armée pour
euh les accords d'Olo. Et le Hamas en
2017, ce que peu de gens disent, en
2017, le Hamas revoit euh son agenda
politique et il
dit que il s'inscrit en fait dans la
dans dans les frontières de 67,
c'est-à-dire les accords d'Ol. Ça c'est
en 2017.
En 2019,
qui tient un discours de soutien au
Hamas, y compris sur l'aspect financier
? Benjamin Nathanahu.
Benjamin Nathanahu. 2 ans après que le
Hammas revoit ces documents en disant
"On est prêt en fait à se à se contenter
des frontières de 67 là où
historiquement effectivement le Hamas
était sur Israël, c'est une puissance
coloniale sur nos terre historique et
elle n'a pas vocation à exister."
Donc il s'est plié finalement c'est qui
a dit ça ? J'ai pas entendu le début.
Euh le Hamas, c'est la position du Hamas
historiquement, c'est de dire Israël n'a
pas vocation à exister en fait parce que
c'est un état qui a pillé nos terres et
qui vit sur cet aspect-là. Il a raison.
Je veux dire, moi vous prenez jusqu mon
parcours personnel, bah les terres de ma
famille qui étaient au village de
Alberoué qui est devenu un territoire
israélien. La maison de ma famille, elle
a été récupérée, elle a été annexée avec
cette loi que je vous ai cité tout à
l'heure, la loi de 1951 qui s'appelle
euh la loi des absents. tout palestinien
absent sur le territoire sur cette
période là où entre l'ANCBA et
l'adoption de cette loi,
les les c'est c'est les biens récupérés
sur ces terres des de ces absents
reviennent aux autorités israes.
Je peux vous poser une question ? Ouais,
bien sûr.
Les Palestiniens, ils ont bien vu les
gamins qui étaient au concert en Israël
se faire massacrer par les gars qui
débarquaient en ULM et qui reparta avec
des otages, des gamines désossées au
fond des 44 qui pissaient le sang, qui
étaient piednus, ainsi de suite. Est-ce
qu'ils ont
dégagé les djihadistes ? Est-ce qu'ils
ont dit "Non, mais nous on veut pas de
ça, on se désolidarise".
Mais là, vous avez une lecture qui est
pas une lecture complète de ce qu'est le
haas. Le Hammas c'est
non là je vous parle est-ce qu'ils ont
bien juste
Non mais dire les djihades c'est pas une
lecture complète parce que ce que vous
devez comprendre c'est que bien que ça
soit un mouvement religieux
qui s'est allié avec des djihadistes
bien que ça soit bah les autres
djihadistes c'est aussi un mouvement
politique en fait c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre et c'est la mauvaise lecture
c'est la lecture qu'on a pas en Occident
et et je crois qu'on passe à côté de
quelque chose. En plus, on est hypocrite
parce que quand on dit juste c'est
terroriste et donc on en parle pas, bah
commencez peut-être par condamner ceux
qui ont permis Hamas de se développer si
c'est ça votre bataille. À savoir
euh Nathanahu euh qui permet dès 2019,
il a un discours dans un
contre Kar
l'autorité palestinienne et empêcher
effectivement la création d'un état
palestinien. Et donc ça on reviendra
aussi peut-être tout à l'heure. C'est la
réalité du peuple palestinien. S'il faut
retenir une chose pour comprendre la
réalité du peuple palestinien, c'est la
fragmentation. Fragmentation
territoriale, fragmentation juridique et
fragmentation politique. C'est
précisément parce que
religieuse
religieuse non parce que bah l'ironie du
sort, c'est que les chrétiens palestiens
soutiennent le Hamas. Enfin, pas
idéologiquement, mais
c'est quoi vos sources ? Bah là, les euh
les communautés chrétiennes qui se sont
exprimées en disant que la résistance
palestinienne devait euh pour se
poursuivre, les chrétiens à Gaza qui
refusent de partir, qui ont été aussi
ciblés et bombardés, euh je veux dire,
il ils se ils sont pas euh ils sont ils
sont en rupture peut-être idéologique,
ça c'est certain. Et il y a beaucoup de
Palestins qui sont en rupture
idéologique avec effectivement le Hamas.
Et la convocation, moi ce qui me dérange
surtout en fait, c'est la convocation du
prisme religieux. Pourquoi ? parce
qu'elle ne permet pas d'inclure toute la
diversité du peuple palestinien. Et moi,
je viens pas, je viens d'une famille
musulmane, mais j'ai réussi récemment à
remonter aux racines chrétiennes de ma
famille. Et les Palestiniens, en fait,
c'est aussi la grande richesse, c'est
qu'ils sont ils ont été traversés par
les différentes différentes religions
monothéistes et euh ils étaient juifs.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. C'est ça. Quand je
vous cite un linguiste euh palestinien
juif, je veux dire au moment où le
sionisme commence à émerger, c'est c'est
toute une communauté qu'on a oublié et
qui c'est une minorité qui est restée
juive. Mais c'est ça existe, je veux
dire les les juifs palestiniens, ça
existe les chrétiens palestiniens aussi
bien que une partie des chrétiens
palestiens sont partis sous l'empire
ottoman. Sous l'Empire ottoman. Et donc
il y a eu grosse vague de migration
notamment en Amérique latine
de de juifs. Là si vous regardez par
exemple en dehors du de du pays arabe,
la plus grande communauté palestinienne,
elle se trouve où ? Au Chili.
Ouais. Donc le chiffre exact, je sais
pas mais c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliers, je sais plus 300000 ou quelque
chose comme ça.
Au nord, au sud
je sais pas exactement, je sais pas mais
c'est ils sont là depuis plusieurs
générations quoi. C'est vraiment il
parle plus l'arabe. Enfin, je veux dire,
ils sont vraiment mais ils se
revendiquent palestiniens et ils ont ils
ont aussi leur leur ancrage et avec ses
doubles identité. Donc le chiffre exact,
je sais pas
400000. Voilà. C'est même plus que ce
que je peux dire relation entre le Chili
et la Palestine.
C'est même plus que que ce que je
pensais mais voilà, on a une grande
diaspora quand même palestinienne mais
qui fait suite à des vagues de migration
notamment de la communauté chrétienne
sous l'Empire ottoman déjà et pendant le
mandat britannique. Donc effectivement,
moi ce qui me dérange disons
c'est le le prisme religieux qui permet
pas d'inclure pour moi la cause
palestinienne en tout cas c'est
l'héritage que j'ai une cause nationale
pas une cause religieuse c'est une cause
nationale. Et on a un problème à chaque
fois qu'on est enfermé dans le prisme
religieux, que ça soit dans le monde
arabe, que ça soit en diaspora où les
Palestins sont fantasmés comme
les musulmans martyrion,
alors qu'on a eu historiquement des
grandes figures chrétiennes. Tirina Boé,
la journaliste assassinée par des
snipers israéliens alors qu'elle a dédié
toute sa vie à documenter l'occupation,
la colonisation, elle vient d'une
famille chrétienne et il y a plein plein
de figures. Édouard Saïd euh qui est le
pionnier sur les études post-coloniales
euh qui à l'origine de tout le mouvement
de réflexion de recherche sur les
l'appeler l'orientalisme euh qui va être
sa principale œuvre mais qui va aussi
écrire sur la question politique
palestinienne, qui va aussi beaucoup
écrire sur l'exil palestinien euh et le
déracinement. Euh il est chrétien.
Il est chrétien. C'est une des plus un
des plus grands intellectuels
palestiniens cité par nombreux
Palestiniens et cité par de nombreux
aujourd'hui chercheurs parce que ça a
été un des plus grands chercheurs sur
les études post-coloniales.
Il reste des otages là ?
Oui, il en reste je crois une
cinquantaine mais ils ne sont pas tous
vivants. J'ai pas le détail mais ils
sont pas tous vous a donné le détail.
Justement, je n'ai pas le détail. On
sait le nombre de d'otages
encore demandé par les autorités
israéliennes,
mais on ne sait pas dans le détail qui
on sait qu'ils ne sont pas tous vivants.
Ça a été même redit par l'ambassadeur
d'Israël qui s'exprime de temps en temps
dans les médias. Est-ce que vous avez vu
la vidéo de l'otage israélien dans un
tunnel en train de creuser sa tombe ?
Oui oui oui.
Décharné. Alors
oui, mais je ça je je veux vraiment
juste insister sur le un un élément moi
qui me qui me dérange, c'est
qu'on ait de l'empathie pour les
Israéliens
et pour les Palestiniens.
Alors justement, je trouve qu'on en a
pas du tout pour les Palestiniens.
C'est qui on
bon l'opinion là par exemple, vous
m'avez cité à plusieurs reprises le fait
que vous avez été marqué par les images
du 7 octobre.
On a été aussi marqué par les images
d'après du 7 octobre.
Non, moi je vous demande avant.
Avant quoi ?
Citez-moi des images qui vous ont marqué
avant le 7 octobre.
Sachant que le peuple palestinien vit
des gares à répétition à la de Gaza des
assassins.
Avant avant je vais répondre à la
question. D'habitude je réponds pas aux
questions parce que ici c'est moi qui
pose les questions.
D'accord. Mais je veux bien savoir
pourquoi
les gamins les gamins palestiniens qui
se prennent des tartasses.
C'est pas des tartasses
des des on a vu ce type de vidéo par des
soldats. Manque de respect sur les
grands-mères, manque de respect. Il y a
aussi des assassins, il y a aussi de la
torture, il y a aussi des
prison israélienne
bien sûr, il y a aussi des enfants. Euh
là, vous pouvez vous référer au rapport
d'amnisté sur ce sujet. Vous avez des
enfants, le chiffre exact, je l'ai pas
en tête. Euh
vous avez enfin Israël a régulièrement
recours à l'emprisonnement d'enfants.
Vous avez des assassinats.
Est-ce qu'il y a des enfants qui sont
militaires ? Je veux juste terminer sur
ça. Par exemple, la France et les États
européens occidentaux ont des décennies
durant aider Israël à assassiner des
figures palestiniennes, y compris qu'il
se trouvait bah oui, je veux dire
c'est des grandes figures palestiniennes
qui ont été assassinées.
Alors, on va les accuser tantôt d'être
le bras droit de Arafat à l'époque était
lui aussi hein considéré étiqueté comme
terroriste. er rechercher avec lui et
tous ces
Arafat, il a été hospitalisé à Percy
avec une protection sur l'observatoire
deat, je pense qu'il a été empoisonné et
je c'est sa fille qui a énormément
travaillé sur ce sujet euh au moment où
les autorités israéliennes avaient
vraiment
encerclé le bâtiment dans lequel il se
il se trouvait, il n'it plus rien qui
pouvait rentrer sans contrôle les
Israéliens. Et donc sa fille est
persuadée qu'il a été euh je vous en
supplie, retrouvez-moi le le le
l'empoisonnement enfin le le produit qui
a été utilisé Polonium, pardon Polonium.
Et la thèse qui a été avancée, c'est euh
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il y a eu
ensuite des recherches, euh on a refait
des prélèvements et et on s'est rendu
compte que le polonium qui était présent
était massivement concentré autour de
son estomac donc et non pas dans la
terre. Donc on a retrouvé des traces de
polonium dans la terre où il a été
enterré. Toute la question qui se posait
c'est de savoir est-ce que c'était des
résidus naturels qui se trouvaient ou
est-ce que il a été empoisonné. Et dans
la mesure où la concentration la plus
forte a été trouvée autour de euh de de
ces organes digestifs, euh on en a très
vite enfin plusieurs experts ont conclu
qu'il a été effectivement empoisonné. Et
donc la thèse, moi dont j'ai le plus
entendu parler, c'était le dentifrice,
une goutte qui aurait suffi dans son
dentifrice pour que pour qu'il soit euh
à ce point atteint. Et voilà. Donc euh
j'ai j'ai perdu le film, mais ça pour
dire que les Palestiniens ont toujours
été catégorisés de terroristes et les
occidentaux ont souvent aider les
Israéliens à procéder à des assassinats
ciblés euh quand les Païens se
trouvaient en exil pour leurs activités
politiques, pour les discussions qu'ils
pouvaient mener et cetera et cetera. le
Mossade. Bah, il y a un très beau
documentaire sur YouTube que vous pouvez
retrouver sur les activités du Mossade.
Et vous avez non mais vous avez vraiment
du coup un travail d'archive qui est
fait avec des témoignages des agents du
Mossad qui ont travaillé sur les
différents dossiers. Donc c'est pas
c'est basé vraiment sur cas par cas et
des témoignages des agents en Israël qui
vous disent bah j'ai travaillé sur ce
cas-là, j'ai travaillé sur ce cas-là. Là
c'était une mission réussie, là c'était
une mission qui a échoué et cetera. et
on a littéralement normalisé euh ce
droit vraiment d'abattre et d'assassiner
des Palestiniens dès lors qu'ils avaient
des activités politiques. Et donc moi,
je reviens à cette question. Quelles
sont les images qui vont marquer de
l'injustice du peuple palisien ? Parce
que là, vous m'avez cité le 7 octobre.
Très bien, on est d'accord sur le fait
que les images ont été terribles et
cetera. Euh mais sur une histoire de 75
ans de persécution d'un peuple
palestinien, moi je suis assez étonnée
qu'il y ait très très peu de gens
capables de nous citer euh des choses
qu'auraient vécu le peuple palestinien
pour comprendre dans quoi s'inscrit en
réalité cette dans quel désespoir dans
quel abandon s'est retrouvé le peuple
palestinien. Et Oslo, les accords de
paix, c'est 93.
93.
Est-ce que ça justifie d'être plus
bourreaux que le bourreau ? Mais alors
moi je vous demande de vous mettre à la
place du peuple palestinien, d'accord ?
Vous êtes en France ? Oui, vous êtes en
France.
La France se retrouve découpée
en 47
parce que voilà, vous avez une
communauté persécutée certes, mais pas
que pas persécutée en en France, elle
est persécutée ailleurs. Parce que là,
l'histoire de l'antisémitisme européen,
faudra aussi y revenir. Et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on demande aux Palestiniens de
payer les cet antisémitisme européen ?
Est-ce que dit très bien Ilan Papé, je
suis tout une parenthèse. Ilan Papé,
l'historien israélien dont je vous parle
depuis tout à l'heure, il dit "C'est
assez fou parce que après la choa, il
n'y a pas un seul dirigeant européen qui
dit aux juifs
euh "Restez, c'est avec vous qu'on va
reconstruire une Europe et des nations
européennes qui vont définitivement se
défaire de l'antisémitisme." Il y en a
pas un seul. Il tous ces dirigeants
disent
à ces communautés, à son mouvement
sioniste, "Oui, oui, on va vous aider,
allez tous en Palestine puis c'est
là-bas que vous allez être en sécurité."
Donc enfin, je veux dire, l'héritage de
l'antisémitisme européen, je trouve ça
assez culotté quoi, la manière dont les
Européens l'ont balayé et puis
aujourd'hui la posture qu'ils ont avec
les Palestiens visant à leur faire la
morale et à leur dire "Vous êtes des
antisémites par essence parce que vous
ne voulez pas de l'État d'Israël." Non,
c'est une question politique et ce que
dit Henry Laoren sur ce sujet, c'est
qu'il dit "Les Parisiens sont pas
antisémites par essence. Il y a
forcément des antisémites un peu
partout. Il y en a partout, y compris
dans le monde arabe." Et le nationalisme
arabe a peut-être aussi exacerbé
certaines questions de ce point de
vue-là. Mais il dit en fait, ils sont
pas antisémit par essence, ils sont
antioccupation.
Si des esquimaux avaient occupé la
Palestine, ils seraient anti-esquimo.
C'est ça qu'il faut comprendre du peuple
palestinien. Donc là, je vous mets dans
une un exercice de de pensée,
c'est-à-dire faites l'exercice qui
consiste à imaginer la France qui est
découpée en deux en 1947 euh avec une
population qui a euh des milices
terroristes et je vais prendre le temps
de vous lire un petit extrait pour que
je pense que vous compreniez que des 7
octobre les Palestiens en avent vécu
plein. des milistes terroristes
israéliennes, nationnistes, il gourne,
stern
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de
comprendre que Tal, l'armée israélienne
actuelle est composée en fait de la une
sorte de coalition de toutes ces de tous
ces militionnistes qui ont jamais fait
le bilan de de leur mode opératoire, de
leurs exactions. Donc faut pas être très
étonné de ce que fait aujourd'hui de sal
quand on voit l'héritage quoi de en
terme de chaîne de commandement de
d'expérience qui a été transmise. Vous
rendez compte que de l'autre côté ils
ont le même point de vue hein.
Mais quel point de vue ? Je veux dire,
je
la Palestine n'a pas d'armée. Je veux
dire, s'il y a ses modes d'opératoire,
si il y a ces ces modes opératoire
complètement chaotique qui échappe
justement et y compris au contrôle de la
population que une population qui
pourrait avoir un contrôle dans un état
démocratique, voilà, souverain et
cetera. C'est précisément parce qu'il y
a pas d'état. C'est précisément parce
qu'il y a pas d'armée. Je dire Israël à
l'inverse, on nous le présente comme un
état démocratique, un état qui a une
armée la plus morale du monde. Et pire
encore. Pire encore. La différence en
fait c'est que la France alarme pas le
Hamas.
D'accord. La France alarme Tsal, elle
donne des munitions à Israël. l'Union
européenne à vent bien sûr euh vos
confrères de disclause ont parfaitement
documenté euh tout le tout le toutes les
tout le matériel militaire que la France
livrait notamment pour les mitrailleuses
israéliennes qui sont utilisées. On en a
la preuve dans ces documents de
disclailleuses défensives. Non, on non
en non. La preuve que ces mitrailleuses
ont été utilisées dans notamment dans le
massacre qui a été massacre appelé le
massacre de la farine où voilà plusieurs
centaines de Palestiniens ont été tués
avec ses mitrailleuses. Donc tout ça
pour dire que on a quand même une
différence notable, c'est que moi je
veux bien qu'on dise que ce qu'a fait le
Hamas le 7 octobre c'est c'est
condamnable et cetera.
Le Hamas et ses petits copains.
Mais le Hamas n'est pas financé par
l'Union européenne à ce que je sache.
Financé par qui ? Bah, il a ses appuis
diplomatiques, financiers euh, on va
dire euh auprès du Qatar, la Turquie,
l'Iran pour euh faire euh
pour schématiser quoi. Mais c'est euh on
va dire c'est essentiellement le Qatar
qui euh finançait mais il ne pouvait pas
faire passer cet argent sans l'accord
des Israéliens. C'est ça qu'il faut
savoir. Donc c'est c'est pour ça que
quand
quoi vos sources
bah les déclarations de Netaniaahu
lui-même qui dès 2019 dans un réunion de
conseil qui dit ça a été repris par Aret
y compris par le monde y compris par
différentes sources où il dit
il dit que voilà ça fait pleinement
partie de sa stratégie en fait de de
soutenir le développement du Hamas pour
défaire l'autorité palestinienne et
arriver à ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure, c'est-à-dire passer d'une
fragmentation territoriale
Israël avait tout intérêt à ce que le
peuple palestien soit fragmenté
territorialement. C'est-à-dire qu'on est
quelques millions de Palestiniens dans
les camps exilés, quelques millions de
Palestiniens si Jordanie, 2 millions à
Gaza. La fragmentation territoriale,
elle donne lieu à une fragmentation
politique. Demain, si vous fragmentez le
peuple le peuple français sur territoire
de la France en disant on va avoir je
sais pas dans le sud 2 millions de
Français et puis on va être séparé par
un autre peuple qui se constitue en État
et puis au nord on va avoir d'autres
millions de français. Au bout de au bout
de 50 ans, vous avez une fragmentation
politique. C'est indéniable. vous pouvez
avoir une fragmentation politique.
Peut-être le sud qui sera beaucoup plus
radicalisé que le nord qui a voulu
passer des accords de paix et qu'il a
échoué par ailleurs. Il faut bien
resituer que le fait que le Hamas, c'est
pas en 93 qu'il dit euh on va commettre
des attentats. Euh voilà, il il
considère qu'il y a une une dimension de
trahison parce que effectivement les
accords d'Ol sont euh
il y avait pas des attentats dans des
bus avec des cocottes minutes, avec des
des conneries comme ça ?
avec des boulons qui éclataient de
partout.
Mais je je pense que beaucoup de
Palestiniens, c'est pas que le Hamas,
beaucoup de Palestiniens ont veut aussi
dans Oslo euh un renoncement.
Et donc pourquoi ? Parce que quand on
regarde la carte, je veux dire le
découpage Oselo, c'est le découpage en
trois zones de de la si Jordanie, trois
zones A, B C. A c'est autonomie
palestinienne. C'est pour être vraiment
très exact, je dire 20 % exact, c'est 18
% la zone A, la zone B. Donc ça c'est
administration palestinienne pleine
autonomie. La zone B c'est coopération
israélo-palestinienne notamment d'un
point de vue militaire et cetera. Là
c'est 21 %.
Israël a déjà une des implantations de
colonies, une main mise sur ces
territoires qui est très conséquente.
Donc et on a la zone C, c'est 60 % de la
Sjordanie qui est exclusivement sous
contrôle israélien. Donc en fait ce qui
revient au peuple palestien dans Oslo en
pleine autonomie aujourd'hui et même dès
le début mais au début si vous voulez il
y avait les 5 ans parce qu'en fait ce
que prévoyent les accords d'Ol c'est
israélien vous avez 5 ans pour vous
retirer des territoires et en fait c'est
tout l'inverse qui s'est passé
j'ouvre une parenthèse. C'est tout
l'inverse qui s'est passé, c'est qu'on a
multiplié, on a saisi cette perche là
des des Oselo, des accords d'Olo pour en
fait multiplier les colonies. Et puis je
pense que la l'assassinat de Itagrabin
effectivement a aussi euh euh
malheureusement accéléré les choses.
Un fondamentaliste religieux euh
juif dont j'ai oublié le nom, pardon, je
mais qui est un adepte par ailleurs des
discours de Netaniaahu à l'époque, faut
le dire hein. S'il y a une personnalité
politique, c'est un fou fur qui soit
adepte. Non mais je veux dire ce que
Sylvain Sipel par exemple et d'autres
historiens ressent très bien, c'est
qu'ils disent que quand même à cette
époque-là, on a des discours de
Nathanahu qui présentent Rabin comme un
ennemi de l'intérieur qu'il faudrait euh
fait comprendre, faudrait faudrait
l'éliminer quoi. C'est un ennemi euh
c'est un ennemi d'Israël, c'est un
ennemi des intérêts du peuple juif. Et
et il y a des vous pouvez retrouver dans
les archives, dans les manifestations de
l'époque euh des portraits de rabine
avec une cible quoi sur sa tête. Donc
c'est pas un odin et ces manifestations
là la voix qui pesait le plus c'était
celle de Nathanahu qui galvanisait les
foules contre contre Itakraabin. Donc il
y a une responsabilité
énorme dans le discours qui a été porté
par Nathanahu et qui est aujourd'hui en
parfaite lignée avec la politique qu'il
met en place. Et je veux juste citer
aussi dans le gouvernement de Nathania,
vous avez Smotrich.
Smutrich qui est le ministre de la
défense
et lui alors non mais sur le Hamas sur
le Hamas il dit ça c'est sur un plateau
télé israélien. Il dit le Hamas est un
allié un atout un atout et l'autorité
palestienne est un fardeau. Et il dit ça
mais vraiment tranquillement sur un
plateau télé. Il dit parce que le Hamas,
comme tout le monde le voit comme un
groupe terroriste en fait, via son mode
opératoire, via son lexique et cetera,
et bien euh
on va toujours pouvoir l'utiliser quoi
d'une certaine manière et on va toujours
pouvoir avoir le soutien de la
communauté internationale. Mais
l'autorité palestienne, c'est plus
compliqué parce que l'autorité
palisienne, bah elle a renoncé à la
lutte armée et elle a embrassé la voie
diplomatique de la reconnaissance de
l'État palestinien, de la sisine des des
juridictions internationales, de la
convocation du droit international et là
bah c'est plus compliqué quoi à défaire
l'autorité palestinienne. Donc il dit
vraiment l'autorité palestinienne pour
nous c'est un fardeau parce qu'on a plus
de mal en fait à combattre l'agenda
palestinien quand il est dans cette
dynamique là. Et alors que bah si on a
encore des des Palestiniens qui veulent
faire quelques attentats en gros grosso
modo de temps en temps et bien nous on
s'assurera qu'on du soutien de la
communauté internationale parce qu'on
pourra les réduire à des terroristes
complètement fous et puis à qui on
pourra
les Palestiniens, ils ont pas compris
ça.
Les Palestiniens euh premièrement je
crois que ils ne font pas toujours en
fonction. Je crois qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre la situation euh des
Palestiniens. Il faut vraiment
comprendre la souffrance et le désespoir
dans lequel ils sont. Euh ça justifie
pas encore hein, mais euh quand euh ces
attaques sont commanditées, on est un
moment historique très important qui est
celui de la normalisation avec les
accords d'Abraham porté notamment par
les États-Unis et qui fait la tournée
des pays arabes pour dire "Allez,
maintenant, il faut normaliser avec
Israël."
En gros, les Palestiniens ont disparu.
C'est pas grave, ça sera les grands
sacrifiés de cette région. Vous avez
tout intérêt à coopérer avec Israël,
point de vue militaire, industriel,
pourquoi pas à terme sur plan
touristique, j'en sais rien. Enfin, je
veux dire, il y a vraiment euh ce plan
de normalisation qui est porté.
et il prend il prend au Maroc, il prend
au Soudan, euh il prend dans les
Émirats, il prend et là arrive la
question de l'Arabie Saoudite et
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est pertinemment MBS
c'est pertinemment. Je pense que lui
fondamentalement et personnellement, il
s'en fout des Palestiniens.
Je crois même que ça a dû fuiter dans la
presse. Il dit simplement "Je peux pas
parce que si j'abandonne la cause
palestinienne,
le pays se enfin je je perds le contrôle
du pays, quoi." Et ça c'est le problème
du divorce qu'il y a aussi entre
l'opinion dans les opinions arabes et
les pouvoirs qu'il y a en place. Les
Palestiniens sont dans un moment où on
leur promet un état depuis 47 parce que
Oslo c'est ça arrive déjà tardivement
mais la promesse d'un état palestinien
c'est en 47.
Il se retrouve avec Oslo où la
colonisation et l'occupation et la
partide s'encrent chaque jour un peu
plus gauche comme de droite hein. Moi
les personnes qui me disent c'est que
Natthania et cetera comme j'ai pu
l'entendre par ailleurs sur ce fauteuil
cher certains de vos invités
moi y compris des gens de comme Caron je
veux dire d'autres enfin je veux dire il
y a des gens qui réduisent vraiment la
question palestinienne parfois la
lecture de c'est Nathaniaou c'est le
diable quand il sera parti ça ira mieux
non quand on regarde l'histoire de la
colonisation israélienne vous avez
Perez vous Avez
Goldamir qui est une femme de gauche. Ce
sont des figures de gauche. Goldamir,
elle a empoisonné les terres
palestiniennes en territoire occupé.
C'est quoi vos sources ?
Oh bah les historiens que vous pouvez
lire, Ilan Papé, Henry Laurence, mais
vous suivez taper empoisonnement des
terres palestiniennes Goldamir et vous
pouvez retrouver plusieurs articles
sourcés sur ce sujet. Euh Goldamir,
c'est celle qui dit euh quand on lui
pose la question, alors il a une
interview assez culte d'elle où elle dit
une journée lui dit "Mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire des territoires occupés
?" Et elle elle dit "Mais il y a rien à
faire, on va on va pas les rendre aux
Palestiniens puisque les palissiens
n'existent pas."
C'est exactement le discours que tient
ce motriche aujourd'hui qui est présenté
à juste titre comme la droite
complètement
voilà radical et cetera. Mais je veux
dire Goldamir, figure de la gauche
israélienne, elle est pas très loin. Ce
qu'on observe sur les les rapports qui
documente la colonisation et le nombre
de colonies implantées euh qui sont
documentés par Aret par exemple ou c'est
repris par plusieurs organisations,
c'est que la colonisation ne baisse pas
quand la gauche est au pouvoir. Enfin,
elle est elle est elle baisse un peu
mais elle est elle baisse, pardon, elle
baisse pas mais elle elle baisse mais
elle ne s'arrête pas.
Elle ne s'arrête pas la colonisation
quand la quand la gauche israélienne est
au pouvoir, la colonisation des
territoires palestiens, elle ne s'arrête
pas. Elle baisse. Elle est beaucoup plus
importante bien sûr quand c'est la
droite mais elle ne s'arrête pas. Donc
ça c'est important de le comprendre et
ça rejoint ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure à savoir que Israël est un état
colonial. Gauche comme de droite comme
la France a été un état colonial. la
gauche comme la droite fut fut un moment
fut un moment
présentait tous les bienfaits de la
colonisation et cetera et c'était aussi
très porté à gauche. Donc on est
vraiment dans cette temporalité-là pour
la société israélienne. Et c'est pas un
odin quand on voit les sondages qui sont
repris par la presse israélienne à Ret
notamment sur 70 % des Israéliens qui
sont pour un nettoyage ethnique des des
des Palestiens, c'est-à-dire les
expulsions s'en débarrasser quoi.
Totalement, définitivement.
Ils disent pas s débarrassé où ?
Bah soit les expulsions, soit les
déportations. Donc je sais qu'il y avait
le plan pour la Libye, pour sinon penser
l'Égypte, mais l'Égypte a très vite dit
c'est pas possible. Et puis les
Palestiniens eux-mêmes ne veulent pas,
enfin je veux dire, les Palestiniens
eux-mêmes, ils se sont déjà fait avoir
en 1948. Ceux qui sont partis, qui ont
cru à cette fable de partez quelques
semaines et puis vous allez pouvoir
revenir. Moi ma famille est partie avec
comme beaucoup de Palestiniens avec leur
clés de maison avec leur clé de maison
avec deux trois de tron lit sur votre
fich j'ouvre je prends ma parenthèse qui
sera en trois parties.
Sur votre fiche Wikipédia votre maman
elle était très riche
et ensuite elle s'est mariée avec un
réfugié le réfugi c'est ma grand-mère.
Oui. Alors ma grand-mère
voilà. Pardon ? Et votre papa il était
il travaillait pour Bachar et Hassan ?
Il était pas du tout pas du tout. Mais
c'est une moquenaissance de de la
situation.
Pourquoi c'est sur fiche Wikipédia ?
Je sais pas. Non, c'est pas sur ma fiche
Wikipédia hein. Bon,
d'accord.
Ah, je sais pas. En tout cas, c'est pas
moi qui gère ma Pardon. C'est pas moi
qui gère ma fiche Wikipédia.
Donc au moins vous le savez. Question
les otages israéliens.
Oui. Alors, attendez juste, je réponds
sur ces ces accusations. Alors,
effectivement, moi, j'ai trois
grands-parents palestiniens descendant
de l'Aanacoba. C'estàd qu'ils ont vécu
donc du côté de mon père.
Il s'appelait comment ?
Euh du côté de mon père donc Hosni euh
qui a
bar
non euh du côté de mon père c'est
Hassan. Du coup Barak c'est le nom de de
de ma famille de ma famille maternelle.
Donc la famille de mon père vient du
village d'Alberou qui est un village au
nord qui est le même village que Mahmoud
Darwich.
Et Mahmoud Darwi, je pense que vous le
savez mais il a écrit toute son œuvre
quasiment sur la question de l'exil du
déracinement et cetera. Donc il a
vraiment sa famille a aussi vécu le
traumatisme de 1948. Il venait vraiment
du même village. La famille de ma mère,
j'ai que mon grand-père Jamil Mobarak
qui lui vient
de Salfit.
qui était un territoire près de
Naplouse, mais il était dans le nord
avec sa famille au moment de l'intrusion
des milices israéliennes et il se
retrouve en fait sur la même route
migratoire et le même le même
trajectoire migratoire que ceux qui sont
partis. C'est comme ça que ma famille
maternelle et maternelle se retrouvent
dans le même camp finalement alors
qu'ils viennent pas historiquement des
mêmes villages. Et effectivement, mon
grand-père Jamil Mobarak, il a une
histoire assez belle en réalité, c'est
que il va être accueilli par une
là, il y avait une grande famille. La
Syrie était à l'époque découpée vraiment
en 4 c territoires
et c'était des grandes familles qui
administraient, qui gérait ces
territoires et donc la famille Hanano et
le leader de l'indépendance syrienne
c'est Ibrahim Hanano qui est l'oncle de
ma grand-mère.
Ma grand-mère Malak Hanano vient
effectivement d'une famille très
fortunée pour
c'est quoi très
je sais pas parce que je vais vous dire
comment ça se termine parce que j'ai on
a jamais eu accès à ces à ces privilèges
là je veux dire et tant mieux tant mieux
ma grand-mère en fait donc cette famille
Hanano va mobiliser un foyer d'accueil
pour les réfugiés palestiniens le temps
que les camps des Nations- Unies se
mettent en place il se trouve que mon
grand-père qui est initialement un
paysan mon grand-père travailler la
terre en Palestine va en fait commencer
à donner des petits coups de main à la
famille Hanano réparer quelque chose
par-ci par là et travailler de ses main
quoi. Il va finir donc par être
accueilli par cette famille dans ce
foyer et il tomberait dingue de Malak
Hanano qu'il voit passer vraiment comme
une princesse. Voilà, elle entend parler
de lui, il lui est interdit de lui
adresser la parole. sa famille lui dit
clairement, "Tu es de ce rang-là et il
n'est pas question que tu te rapproches
d'un réfugié palestinien. Enfin, je veux
dire qu'il n'a rien, qui a même pas de
quoi se chausser.
Grossière erreur
et qui par ailleurs est un communiste.
Donc elle voilà bourgeoise, voilà. Et
finalement, elle persiste lui aussi et
il faudra attendre des années pour que
les autorités syrienne veille bien
enregistrer leur mariage. Elle elle sera
bien naturellement reniée par sa famille
et elle va vivre dans le camp avec nous.
Et elle a été enterrée dans ce camp.
Alors, il y a ses titres noblesses là
sur les sur son sur sa tombe parce que
c'est voilà, c'était c'était vraiment
comme une princesse quoi, je veux dire
sur le système à l'époque, c'était une
famille et donc elle a été totalement
déshéritée. Elle avait plusieurs
villages et cetera qui étaient au nom de
sa famille près d'Alep et elle a
totalement été déshéritée et elle est
partie vivre avec mon grand-père et ils
se sont jamais quittés. Ils ont fait
toute leur vie dans le camp dans une vie
euh très modeste, très très modeste. Et
ma grand-mère, c'était des seules en
plus qui était pas palestinienne pour à
l'époque. Donc on l'a surnommé la Lpine,
quoi. Enfin, pas elle était pas intégrée
euh comme les autres femmes de
palestiniennes. Et voilà, elle avait
C'est très drôle parce que moi je
raconte une anecdote qui me fait
toujours rire, c'est que ma grand-mère
elle avait plus les moyens de de elle
était plus une bourgeoisecve
ses moyens, mais elle avait gardé des
petits codes, des petites choses. Par
exemple, elle nous interdisait de en
tout cas, elle aimait pas qu'on mâche du
chewing-gum. Elle trouvait ça très
vulgaire. Donc, elle avait gardé des
petites des petites choses de son
éducation mais ça détonnait tellement
dans le contexte et le bordel du corps
dans lequel on était. Euh donc elle a
une histoire en réalité très belle et
nous on n' pas du tout gardé de lien
avec cette famille euh Hanano.
L'héritage qu'on a c'est plutôt
l'héritage politique qui est que
effectivement son grand oncle arrière
notre arrière grand oncle le leader de
l'indépendance syrienne et donc contre
les Français. Voilà donc et France la
France qui a aussi réprimé dans le sang
ces mobilisations dirigées par Ibrahim
Hanano et d'autres. Donc, on n'a pas
hérité d'argent de cette famille-là. Et
ma grand-mère, comme c'est une femme
dans les pays arabes, ça c'est un
héritage de l'Empire ottoman, ne peuvent
pas transmettre la nationalité. Donc ma
grand-mère n'a pas pu transmettre la
nationalité syrienne à ses enfants.
C'est ce qui fait que ma mère, mes
oncles, mes tantes et moi-même, on a
été enregistré sous le statut de réfugié
apatri de l'un roi. Donc plein de gens
me qualifient encore de syrienne.
Aujourd'hui, je n'ai jamais eu la
nationalité syrienne. Parce que les
femmes ne peuvent pas transmettre la
citoyenneté
dans ce pays comme dans d'autres. C'est
un héritage malheureux de l'Empire
ottoman.
Il y a des il y a des pays euh qui ont
essayé de vous tamponner ?
Non,
les Iraniens, les Syriens.
Mais je n'ai aucun contact avec les
Iraniens. Je suis même jamais allé en
Iran. Je rent même de mon entrée en
politique, hein. Il y a aucune trace de
moi. Euh
votre entourage ? Non non, il y a
personne. Je dire c'est vraiment des
mythes quoi qui sont construits autour
de parce qu'on part du principe que euh
comme j'ai essayé de à mon échelle de
dire "Attendez, le débat sur le Hamas,
c'est un peu plus complexe que ce qu'on
veut nous faire croire et par ailleurs,
l'hypocrisie euh des occidentaux qui
consiste à dire le Hamas c'est le mal
absolu mais en même temps, on soutient
Nathanahu qui a permis le développement
du Hamas. À un moment donné, il faut
être cohérent. Je veux dire, il faut
aller au bout de la logique.
C'est un peu comme les États-Unis qui
ont financé Ben Laden.
Ouais, je pense que il y a un moment
donné euh
je pense que les Israéliens sont laissés
dépasser en fait par le par le Hamas,
mais par contre, ils étaient très très
conscients de ce qu'était le Hamas. Je
veux dire euh Hamas euh savait
pertinemment qu' il savait pertinemment
qu'il développait une branche armée. Il
savait pertinemment que il avait
vocation à défendre euh la cause
palestinienne euh à travers la lutte
armée. Et je considère que la lutte
armée, pas celle du Hamas exclusivement
ou je considère que la lutte armée est
légitime en se basant notamment sur les
résolutions des Nations Unies que je
vous citais tout à l'heure 3070 qui
précise que dans un contexte
d'occupation et de colonisation un
peuple qui est en lutte pour son
indépendance euh il a le droit de
est-ce que dans ces textes on dit "OK la
lutte armée mais ils sont copains avec
les terroristes ils envoient des
terroristes en ULM." Mais justement, la
question même de la qualification du
terrorisme, je prendre 2 minutes non, je
prendre juste 2 minutes. Non non s'il
vous plaît, s'il vous plaît, je prends
juste 2 minutes et vous allez me dire
vous allez me dire si ça c'est du
terrorisme ou pas. D'accord ?
Des mecs en ULM qui je vais vous lire 10
lignes, vous allez
qui prennent des otages.
Je vais vous lire 10 lignes. Vous allez
me dire si ça
parce que les otages c'est un crime de
guerre.
Moi, je suis d'accord pour qu'on parte
sur la la qualification du terrorisme à
condition qu'elle soit honnête et
exhaustive,
pas qu'elle soit utilisée pour
diaboliser un camp plutôt qu'un autre.
Donc là, je vais vous lire D. Vous allez
me dire si si c'était du terrorisme ou
pas.
Je vous autorise.
Merci. Les témoignages des soldats
israéliens présents sur les lieux des
atrocité et qui avait participé à
l'assaude au sein du 89e bataillon
commandité par Méday sont unanimes.
Témoignage israélien. Les troupes de
l'armée israélienne envahirent le
village, entreprirent de liquider les
civils. Jetant leurs victimes dans des
fosses. Ils tuèrent les enfants à coup
de bâton sur la tête. Pas une maison ne
fut épargnée. Les survivants furent
alors enfermés dans des maisons sans eau
ni nourriture alors que le village était
rasé. Un commandant un commandant
ordonna à un sapeur de mettre deux
vieilles femmes dans une des maisons et
fit sauter la maison avec les deux
femmes. Un autre soldat se ventant
d'avoir violé une femme puis de l'avoir
tué. Une femme avec son nouveau nez dans
les bras fut prise pour nettoyer la cour
où les soldats mangeaient. Elle
travailla un jour ou deux puis la
tuèrent avec son bébé. Plusieurs
documents attestent que ses atrocités
furent commises dans le village et aux
alentours, y compris dans la mosquée
dans une grotte voisine, qu'on avait
fait sauter des maisons dans lesquelles
des vieillards avaient été enfermés et
qu'il y avait eu plusieurs cas de viol
suivi d'assassinats. Ça c'est 1948,
c'est la NACBA.
Et donc parce que eux ils font du
terrorisme côté du terrorisme. C'est
pour dire que
on
n pas sorti de l'auberge avec c'est pour
dire que on ne peut pas
d'un côté pour 1200 morts. Sachant que
près de la moitié de des 1200 morts sont
des cibles militaires ou des policiers.
Dans un contexte d'occupation, c'est
légitime ça. Ça c'est le droit
internation.
Non, je vous le dis, je vous le dis.
civil civil euh c'est inexcusable, c'est
injustifiable mais dans un contexte
d'occupation, quand la France était sous
occupation cibler des militaires et des
policiers, c'était euh son droit. Elle
devait même le faire. Elle devait le
faire. Et bien euh Stéphan Essel qui est
euh l'auteur de Indignez-vous qui est
qui est lui-même de confession juive,
qui était un résistant français allemand
franco franco-allemand et qui a beaucoup
participé à la réconciliation justement
et qui était un résistant. Il dit
parfaitement l'occupation que vit les
Palestiniens est pas très éloigné de
l'occupation que les Français ont vécu.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ont un devoir de
résistance qui passe aussi par la lutte
armée. Et donc dans cette résistance et
bien la les cibles sont effectivement
prioritairement militaires. Donc ça ne
justifie pas effectivement les le cible
qui a été fait des civils. Mais
il y a pas de mai.
Je termine mon propos. Si vous voulez
aller sur la qualification terro pour
dire que ce qui l'attaque des civils,
c'est ça en fait finalement parce que
c'est une définition molle en droit
international. Le terrorisme c'est pas
défini, c'est pas une on c'est pas une
il y a pas de définition, il y a pas de
consensus sur la définition. Vous pouvez
demain dire d'ailleurs, on l'a vu les
dérives autour de ce la convocation de
ce terme d'Armanin qui dit
l'écoterrorisme. Donc les militants
écologiques écologistes, on va
maintenant s'ils sont un peu radicaux,
c'est des terroristes. Donc faut faire
très attention.
Le radicaux, ils cartonnent des des CRS
à coup de bomb. Non, mais on va on va
partir on va partir du principe
consensuel du diable.
On va partir du principe consensuel.
Oui. Bon, en même temps, je veux dire,
quand il est question de la survie du
vivant et de la terre euh
ou même d'un écosystème, d'un village,
d'un fonctionnement, je je je pense
qu'il y a une radicalité qui se
comprend. Une radicalité qui se
comprend. Moi, je viens, je l'ai dit,
mon grand-père c'est un paysan. Je viens
d'un uneune famille qui avait aussi ce
rapport à la terre qui malheureusement
elle a perdu parce que finir dans les
camps de réfugiés que dans du bitume
entre les tentes et les bitum. Enfin, je
veux dire il y a un moment où on est
très déconnecté et éloigné justement de
ce rapport là et c'est une vraie
souffrance pour les palestiniens. Mais
moi, je peux comprendre cette
radicalité-là, je la comprends. Je la
justifie pas toujours, mais je la
comprends.
Vous l'acceptez ou pas
la la cette radicalité là ? Je pense
même qu'elle est nécessaire.
Est-ce que vous l'acceptez ?
Je mieux que ça, je pense qu'elle est
nécessaire.
Non,
j'ai dans dans je pense que dans
certaines circonstances,
il y a aucune circonstance qui justifie
d'aller taper des mots et d'aller
kidnapper des mots.
Ah non, mais je vous parlais de la
radicalité des des écologistes.
On était sur ça. Donc je reviens juste,
je termine mon propos. Je veux bien moi
qu'on convoque la question du
terrorisme, même si encore une fois elle
fait c'est elle fait pas consensus sur
en matière de définition de droit
international.
Donc si on nous qualifie les
Palestiniens de terroristes pour avoir
tué
quelques centaines de civils, pourquoi
on qualifie pas Israël d'état terroriste
quand on est à plus de 60000 morts ?
Donc là, on peut se référer à au remède.
Combien de pourcentage de civil ? 83.
C'est quoi la source ?
La source récemment qui ben c'était les
Nations Unies, il me semble. Je Non,
c'était pas les Nations Unies. basé sur
des sur les données israéliennes ou The
Guardian qui avait aussi fait un article
mais je sais pas si les Nations Unies
avait également mais en tout cas pour
vous pouvez vous référer à The Guardian
avec qui précise bien qu'ils se sont
référés aux données israenes ellesmême
c'estàd qui considage de de militants du
Hamas au sein de la population palestin
Jean-Pierre Fulen%
c'est ça
il dit que il y a on estime qu'il y a
environ 30000 combattants
pour le Hamas et que on en aurait tué.
Bah
alors justement, on est entre euh là
entre ceux qui ont été tués voilà donc
c'est 40000 mais justement ils estiment
que le nombre de pertes pour le Hamas
c'est autour de 10000
autour de 10000 combattants. Donc on
aurait actuellement autour de 30000
combattants encore mobilisable ou
mobilisés.
Ça fait combien de pourcentage de la
population ? Alors en math, du coup, on
est sur 2 millions quasiment. Sachant
que le nombre de morts est très
incertain si on se réfère à l'étude de
l'anc
et d'autres études qui ont dit que voilà
qu' on resitué les morts directes et
indirectes euh et qui sont un chiffre
bien au-delà de celui qui est qui est
acté actuellement et qui n'inclu que les
personnes qu'on a réussi à identifier,
le corps, le nom, le prénom. Il y a
s'il a pas été retiré d'hélic par les
uns et par les autres.
Il y a énormément de de Palestiniens
dont on qu'on ne retrouve pas qui sont
sous les décombes qui
dont on a qu'une partie du corps. Ça
c'est une réalité qu'il faut aussi dire.
C'està-dire qu'on a eu des scènes
terribles. On a vu des Palestiniens
ramasser des bouts de corps dans des
sacs et que ça soit pour les enfants ou
les adultes. Donc il y a aussi des
corps, je veux dire qu'on arrive pas à
identifier. Donc on est à mon sens si on
suit un peu les les
conclusions de l'an fait déjà il y a
bientôt près d'un an
euh on est sur au moins 200000 morts.
Au moins 200000 morts parce qu'à
l'époque ils étaient sur 180.
Donc euh on est au moins, je veux dire
euh et c'était des estimations quoi qui
étaient faites. Mais on est voilà. Moi
ma grosse crainte, c'est qu'on on taise
en fait les les analyses qui tendent à
nous dire qu'on est sur des chiffres
beaucoup plus vertigineux que 60000
morts pour justement éviter que la
population, les opinions se mobilisent.
Euh parce que on si on en croit un peu
la propagande israélienne, c'est c'est
de dire "Ah ben 2 ans de génocide, 60000
morts, c'est pas beaucoup." Enfin, on
pourrait se dire si on veut vraiment euh
voilà euh
éradiquer cette population
palestinienne, il y a 2 millions
personnes, si on veut, on peut très vite
monter quoi en terme de nombre de
victimes. Je pense qu'en réalité le
nombre est beaucoup plus important et on
le voit de toute façon à l'ampleur de
les destructions civiles, des
infrastructures civiles. Euh, on parle
même d'écocide. Il a plusieurs
organisations qui convoquent de plus en
plus le terme d'écocide parce que il
reste très très peu de terres sur
lesquelles les Palestiniens ne peuvent
ne serait-ce que cultiver. Il y a
une explosion aussi des maladies qui
sont liées au taux de
enfin d'exposition au résidus des des
bombes des des et des
produits chimiques en fait, je veux dire
qui émanent de de ces bombes là. Et euh
les chiffres qu'on a, c'est 100000
tonnes à peu près de bombes qui ont été
larguées sur la bande de Gaza depuis
l'offensive. Donc juste pour dire
comment se fait-il ? C'est pour dire que
à quel point en fait la question de la
convocation du terme terroriste est à
mon sens aussi convoquée sur un agenda
colonialiste et impérialiste.
euh
les États-Unis qui tuent qui torturent
dans les prisons d'Abouïb les Irakien
qui leur pissent dessus euh qui
mobilisent les chiens euh qui ont
recours à du viol euh qui
font la guerre à une population avec
quasiment 1 million de morts.
Qu'est-ce qui appauvri ? Qu'est-ce qui
nous empêche de les qualifier de
terroristes
si ce n'est la colonalité du monde, si
ce n'est les rapports de force dont on
hérite dans le monde et qui nous font
dire que bon en fait euh un arabe barbu
de du Hamas, même s'il tue 100 fois
moins qu'un Israélien,
il méritera cette étiquette de
terroriste. Par contre, un Israélien
peut assassiner 10 fois plus de
Palestiniens
avec des atrocités
terrible, je veux dire, qu'on peut voir.
Et bien, ça fera même pas débat. La
question ne se posera même pas. La
question ne se posera même pas de savoir
si on a recours à du terrorisme.
Est-ce qu'il y a du On parle de la
propagande israélienne selon vous ? Ah
oui, mais il y a une y a un financement
de 5 millions d'euros euh par Israël, ne
serait-ce qu'en France, d'ailleurs, sur
les chaînes YouTube et cetera.
Quelle chaîne YouTube ?
Ah mais sur les sur les la plateforme de
YouTube. Ah,
pour faire de la pub ?
Ouais, vous pouvez ouvrir un article de
Libération là-dessus qui a fait un check
justement sur cette information et c'est
pour être exact 4,8 millions de dollars
euh éjectés vraiment les premiers mois
euh pour la propagande israine.
Est-ce qu'il y a de la propagande côté
Hmas ? avec des faux morts, des faux des
machins, des des fausses ou non mais
bien sûr qu'il y a des éléments de
propagande de toute façon quel que soit
le parti au conflit dire moi je j'ai mes
engagements et tout mais je je suis
quand même lucide, je suis pas
bien sûr qu'il y a de la propagande du
côté Hamas, c'est une propagande
guerrière de résistance et cetera et
cetera
mais je veux quand même dire
le coloniser
aura toujours plus d'excuses que le
colonisateur de par la souffrance qui
l'endure. Aujourd'hui, avec le recul
qu'on a, même si ça reste un sujet très
sensible, on arrive à comprendre
pourquoi le FLN a fini par faire
exploser des des cafés, des restaurants
ou des familles françaises. Enfin, on
arrive à comprendre dans le sens où vous
avez des émissions
qui arrive à comprendre,
vous avez des émissions France Culture
là-dessus sur le FLN, sur Je veux dire,
c'est ça fait partie des débats de
on arrive à expliquer, c'est pas c'est
pas justifié mais on arrive à expliquer.
On le restitue comme un épisode
historique de voilà la mise en mouvement
de du FLN qui a recoure opératoire
terroriste mais qui a pas d'autre issu
en réalité qui voit la seule qui voit ça
comme étant la seule issue.
Et bien les Palestiniens, je pense
qu'ils sont dans cette temporalité,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont bien sûr
fortement condamnés pour un recours à un
mode opératoire terroriste,
mais ils sont dans cette temporalité du
désespoir du colonisé. Du désespoir du
colonisé qui ne sait plus quoi faire
pour être entendu. Et c'est pour ça que
je parle aussi de l'hypocrisie des
occidentaux. Là, on nous présente la
conférence qui arrive le 22 à New York
comme étant la conférence de
Tout le monde a eu ses visas
du grand progrès pour euh les grandes
avancées pour la cause palestinienne.
Tout le monde a eu ses visas.
C'est c'est la conférence aux
États-Unis. Non, c'est pas celle-là.
Oui, c'est ça. aux États-Unis euh pour
la reconnaissance de l'État palestinien
et qui est la seule initiative portée
par Emmanuel Macron. Et ce que je trouve
insupportable, c'est qu'on nous la
présente vraiment comme une
une carte Yu-Gi-Oh
et on la présente vraiment comme quelque
chose de de très euh comme une grande
avancée alors qu'on a à l'heure où on se
parle là, on a 75 % de la communauté
internationale qui reconnaît d'ors et
déjà l'état palestinien.
Alors avant de partir à l'international
euh je vous rappelle et je l' fini. Non
mais vous avez juste dit
non mais sur l'hypocrisie des
occidentaux c'est que qui a abandonné
les Palestiniens ? Je termine juste sur
ça.
Khaas
qui oui Khaas après qui a perdu
parce que après c'est Mchi.
Non non qui a abandonné les Palestiniens
? Moi je veux bien qu'on cond les
Palestiniens quand ils pètent les
plombs.
Il ils deviennent fous, ils font
n'importe quoi. OK
abandonné les Palestiniens depuis les
accords de Sou. Je remonte même pas à
48. Accord de SL à la commité
internationale était unanime sur deux
états. Il faut arrêter la colonisation,
il faut arrêter l'occupation. Et ben
entre-temps, on a des entreprises
françaises qui sont allé s'implanter
dans les territoires occupés et on a la
les autorités françaises qui sont
parfaitement au courant et qui n'ont
prononcé aucune sanction. Là, à l'heure
où on se parle, l'Union européenne est
toujours le premier partenaire
commercial d'Israël. Combien de
milliards ?
Oh, je sais pas. Tout compris avec le
programme Horizon, mais ça se compte en
plusieurs dizaines de milliards.
Donc, on va passer à la question
internationale. L'Espagne, la flottie et
tout la toin,
les otages israéliens. Hm hm.
Et vous avez euh des contacts en
Palestine pour dire "Bon les gars, vous
ça déconne là, il faut les lâcher. Euh
ah non, voilà, vous vous vous non
surestimez
mon mon réseau ou je sais pas, vous
l'amplifiez. Mais
vous avez essayé ?
Ah non, c'est pas mon rôle. C'est pas
mon rôle. Mon rôle
c'est d'être députée européenne
d'origine palestinienne. Et ça, je crois
que j'ai le droit de le convoquer parce
que je crois qu'on arrive en politique
aussi avec ce qu'on est, ce qu'on a dans
les tripes et l'histoire de la France a
Giselle Limi, Giselle Limi, c'est une
française d'origine tunisienne et ce qui
fait qu'elle comprend le FLN, c'est ses
origines arabes aussi
avec ce que vous avez vécu, ce que votre
famille a vécu, ce que vous avez pu
lire, ce que l'histoire a pu vous
transmettre.
l'empathie envers les les familles des
Israéliens qui ont des otages dans des
tunnels
mais abandonnés par Nathanahou.
Non mais OK,
je parle de vous.
Ouais.
Votre empathie de femme de de femmes
cultiv
Bien sûr qu'elle est là. Bien sûr
qu'elle est Mais attendez là, si on veut
être honnête dans le déroulé de
l'interview, c'est qu'il faut bien que
vous êtes honnête.
Non, à vous aussi de l'être.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut revoir les
premières interviews que j'ai donné.
Alors moi, je vais passer 2 ans à moment
où le peuple palicien est génocidé à
convoquer en permanence cette question
de l'empathie. C'est une question que
j'ai traité dès le début. Je me souviens
avoir fait une interview,
je sais plus cit Media Part ou
l'humanité où j'avais dit que on nous a
on a été empêché d'avoir un espace
d'empathie un peu commune euh dès le
début. C'est-à-dire que dès le début, et
ça c'est le reproche que j'ai à faire au
soutien d'Israël qui sont nombreux en
France hein. Le le lobby proélien est
très puissant en France. Je dirais juste
après les États-Unis, c'est un des pays
les où c'est le plus dur de porter la
question palestinienne. Euh
Allemagne, c'est pas mal quand même, non
?
Oui, mais en France, c'est plus ancré
historiquement. Et donc euh on a tout de
suite associé soutien à la famille
à la question des otages et cetera, à la
condamnation en fait aussi de du mode
opératoire du 7 octobre
ce qui est logique
un soutien inconditionnel à Israël.
Je suis désolé mais ça vous le retrouvez
dans tous les discours politiques, la
grande majorité des discours politiques.
C'est ce qui s'est passé, c'est
terrible. Soutien inconditionnel
indéfectible à Israël. Non non.
7 octobre, c'est quelque chose qui doit
être euh
puni. Puni, oui, dans la Oui, mais
recontextualisé avant d'être puni parce
que c'est un peu facile de venir dire à
un peuple qui finit à ce niveau-là de
désespoir.
Mais les mecs qui ont débarqué en ULM
faut il faut le il faut le comprend il
faut le comprendre à un moment donné
aussi comme le désespoir. Il faut
Attendez là avec le recul quand on vous
présente le casen quand on vous présente
la NC Mandela c'était quoi son projet à
Mandela ? C'est un coup d'état dans
l'apartide.
C'est un coup d'état. il est pas venu
offrir des fleurs aux dirigeants euh euh
Gandy.
Mais Gandy, alors c'est marrant que vous
convoquez la figure de Gandhi parce
qu'il faut la déconstruire la figure de
Gandy. Gandy il était raciste. Euh
Gandy, il a quand même il avait un
rapport aux femmes un peu plus
problématique. Et par ailleurs, c'est la
convocation, l'utilisation,
l'instrumentalisation généralement par
l'Occident de figur présenté comme
pacifique
des hommes et des femmes de paix. Et ça,
je crois que ça permet surtout d'exclure
ou d'éliminer dans notre réflexion
commune
la question de la radicalité et de la
violence. Attendez, parce que la
violence Non mais attendez, ça c'est
très
Vous connaissez Krishna Murti ? Non, je
ne me dis rien.
Sa déclaration, son discours en 1985 à
l'ONU, je vous le recommande vivement.
D'accord. Je regarderai. Mais c'est
c'est juste pour finir sur ces questions
de la violence légitime. C'est très
intéressant parce que vous avez en fait
euh
le titre c'est pourquoi l'homme ne peut
pas vivre en paix sur cette terre ?
D'accord. Bon ben je je me noterai la
référence en partant.
Mais pour moi en fait cette convocation
des figures très lisses par exemple
préféré systématiquement Martin Luther
King à Malcomic euh pour moi c'est pas
neutre. C'est pas neutre parce que ça ça
tend aussi à exclure toutes les figures
qui ont été radicales dont les modes de
mobilisation peuvent être parfois
incontestables.
Malcomic c'est œil pour œil, dents pour
dents. C'est il est dans vous vous
voulez casser la gueule des noirs, on va
casser la gueule des blancs.
On peut se dire que c'est contestable.
Ah, il appelle pas la paix, il tend pas
la joue. D'accord. Mais euh
leur simple existence à ces discours et
à ces moyens de mobilisation
disent quelque chose. disent quelque
chose soit du désespoir euh soit de la
rentrer. Pourquoi on rentre à un moment
donné dans un niveau de radicalité tel
qu'on peut l'observer ? Et donc la
radicalité euh condamnable à certains
égards du Hamas ne doit pas être exclu
de notre champ d'analyse et de
réflexion. Il faut la comprendre. et
François Burga qui a été
qui a été poursuivi pour apologer et
enfin en tout cas qui a été qu'on a
tenté de poursuivre pour appog
terrorisme, il a été finalement relaxé.
Vous avez combien de plaintes ?
Moi je pense que je suis sur euh faut
que je demande à mon avocat mais je
pense que on est sur 18.
Pourquoi
vous êtes qu'est-ce qui vous est
reproché ?
Alors apologie terrorisme beaucoup je
crois.
Pourquoi ? pour euh
pour euh avoir dit que la le Hamas mène
une action légitime. Mais en fait, on
est incapable de comprendre euh la
réflexion aussi en droit international
là-dessus. C'est-à-dire que dire qu'il y
a un cadre de résolution des Nations-
Unies et un droit.
Vous pouvez comprendre aussi de l'autre
point de vue pourquoi il vous attaque.
Non, on est dans un combat politique. Je
ne
légitime pas tout. Mais encore une fois,
je veux dire, ça c'est l'interprétion
que vous faites. Si moi je dis le Hamas
a euh la lutte armée est légitime, le
Hamas, ce n'est pas qu'une branche armée
qu'un mode opérateur terroriste. C'est
un d'abord un parti politique qui a
gagné les élections en 2006 dans la
bande de Gaza.
Diaddiste.
Mais c'est qui les djihadistes ?
Bah les mecs ont marquis le djihad
islamique. Et le dijihad islamique c'est
aussi une composant politique. Qu'on le
veuille ou pas. Je veux dire, si en fait
moi ce ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il
faut il faut vraiment faire attention au
moment où on nous demande d'arrêter de
réfléchir.
C'est très dangereux moi je pense quand
on nous demande d'arrêter de réfléchir.
Pourquoi d'autre ?
Donc 18 plaines apogéorisme.
Alors ça il y a des plaintes très
drôles. Il y en a une
à mon avis c'est pas drôle.
Ah si il y en a une j'ai une plainte
pour avoir utilisé le mot soulèvement.
C'est le quand j'ai fait un tweet en
disant l'heure est au soulèvement dans
le mouvement étudiant au moment où les
mouvements étudiants prenaient beaucoup
d'ampleur et j'ai retravaillé dessus
d'ailleurs avec la rapporteur spéciale
des Nations- Unies Gina Romero qui a
travaillé sur les libertés d'expression
et de mobilisation sur les campus des
étudiants pour la Palestine et qu'on a
invité au Parlement. Elle a fait un
rapport très intéressant sur ce sujet où
elle documente les violations faites par
les autorités en matière d'accès, en
liberté d'expression et de mobilisation
et de et de de réunion pour les
étudiants dans le cadre de leur
mobilisation pour la Palestine. Donc je
vous invite à regarder son rapport mais
euh et j'utilise ce terme dans
un tweet et puis bah on porte plainte
contre moi en disant j'appelle à
l'insurrection
je suis en danger.
Ça pas être compris comme ça. Non
non mais attendez, vous plaisantez ou
quoi ? Je franchement on en est où
maintenant ? On fait la police des des
démos. Je veux dire on va
vous avez vous avez été chercher des
crosses à Chaloui.
Chaloui ? Ah bah
vous l'avez déjà rencontré ?
Non et je n'ai pas très envie de le
rencontrer.
Pourquoi donc ?
Chalomi euh
il est très grand. Je vous invite à
regarder parce que là ça effectivement
dès que dès que dès que je me défends,
ça fait énormément de de de de bruit.
Mais j'observe que quand je suis
attaquée,
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait avec
Chaloui ? Pourquoi ?
Non, personnellement, je n'ai rien fait,
mais Chaloui a fait plusieurs interviews
avant même que
Vous avez pas fait un tweet
récemment ? récemment, mais Maombri a
fait le même pour dire Bairou Barnier,
on l'a pas accusé de menacer de mort
Bairou avec l'horloge. Elle a fait le
même tweet, il y en a plein qu' on qui
on fait ce tweet là. Donc il y a aussi
ce billet raciste. Je moi ce qu'on a dit
de moi c'est rima lance une fatoie.
savoir ce qui est une fatoie quand même.
Je n'ai pas autorité pour lancer une fat
et je suis pas sûre qu'on lance une fato
avec l'icône de l'horloge. Enfin, je
veux dire c'est quand même
voulait pas de mal à Chaloui.
Non, Chalgoui, je je c'était pour dire
bientôt il sera démasqué en fait. et
démasquer dans parce que c'est une
imposture. Bah Chalomi, je veux dire, il
y a eu le sketch de Malic Bentala qui a
fait rire beaucoup de gens, qui a fait
des millions de vues sur YouTube. Je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu cette mise en
scène de Malik Bentala où il limite en
fait Chalomi et ça a vraiment fait je
sais pas combien de millions de vues sur
en ligne tant
c'est pas parce que ça fait des millions
de vues, c'est vrai.
Non non parce que justement ça a même
été repris dans des médias mainstream en
disant que c'est repris dans les médias
mainstream non plus. Non, mais je veux
dire médiia mainstream qui sont plutôt
du bord de Chalomi, j'ai envie de dire
sur le narratif sur les musulmans. Et
là, il y a eu vraiment quelque chose de
bon c'est vrai que les musulmans sont
représentés par quelqu'un qui passe leur
temps qui passe son temps à leur cracher
dessus, à les ridiculiser. En
l'occurrence Chalomi. Chalomi quand on
regarde son avocat, il fait ça, il fait
pas ça.
Chalomi.
Oui.
Attends, présenter quoi ? Chalomi, il a
été mis en place, il a aucun soutien et
il est présenté comme maire de Drancy.
Il n'est ni maire à Drancy, il ne
mobilise personne à Drancy.
Présenté comme imam à
imam, j'ai dit maire, pardon. Euh non,
fort heureusement, il a pas ce cap imam
à Daniy. Alors, il n'est pas il n'est
pas imam à Drany. Il n'a pas d'activité
dans la mosquée de Drancy. Il n'a aucune
communauté
les gens qui sont à Drancy, les élus qui
sont à Drani et qui que vous pouvez
contacter si besoin qui peuvent vous
dire mais en fait vous allez à la
mosquée ? il est pas là, il ne fait
aucune activité dans cette mosquée et
puis euh et par ailleurs, il est euh il
est vraiment euh les la communauté
musulmane, les communautés musulmanes,
ce que je ne veux pas l'essentialiser en
une seule, c'est fortement désolidarisé
de lui. Et je pense que ce qui est fait
en fait à la communauté musulmane et ce
qui est très dangereux, c'est que on
crée du ressentiment
en validant une personnalité qui tend à
les représenter mais qui les insulte de
par sa posture, qui les humilie. C'est
votre interprétation ?
Ah non, pardon, c'est pas que mon
interprétation, c'est le ressenti. Et ce
ressenti-là de la communauté musulmane,
il est justement nié par les pouvoirs
qu'il a insulté quelqu'un.
Mais si vous voulez, quand il passe son
temps à dire que oui, en fait
interprétation,
non, c'est pas mon interprétation. Vous
pouvez vous pouvez vous documenter quand
il fait un déplacement. Il est il y a
pas un seul déplacement où il est
accueilli par des communautés la
communauté musulmane dans une ville.
Jamais. Donc si musulmans qui va
entendre ça et qui il mettent des photos
où il est accueilli.
Je crois que les musulmans dans le
contexte dans lequon est dans lequel on
est en train de vivre un moment
pas simple du tout.
A le voile, les lois séparatistes,
les musulmans disent à le voile.
Non, ce qu'ils sont en train de vivre
politiquement. En fait, ce qu'il faut
comprendre, c'est que l'islamophobie
parce que effectivement, il y a de
l'antisémitisme, effectivement, il y a
tout type de racisme.
Oui, il y a eu plus de de d'actes
antisémites. Après, très honnêtement,
moi je vous le dis et je l'assume, je ne
fais pas du tout confiance au chiffres
du CRIF. Le CRIF est présenté, y compris
par des chercheurs ou des historiens
comme Sylvain Sipel, comme euh
l'équivalent de l'IPAC euh en France euh
enfin aux États-Unis. L'IPAC est le
lobby euh proisraélien aux États-Unis
qui va jusqu'à financer et cetera. Alors
en France, on a son
quand même au fait de ce qui se passe.
En France, on est quand même plus
réglementé et cetera, mais par exemple
le CRIF a financé des voyages en Israël
à certains élus. Le le comment s'appelle
cette chaîne YouTube ?
euh canard de toute façon qui se base on
s même citer le le type qui a fait ce
parce que je voulais juste citer son
travail parce que c'est c'est grâce à
lui que j'ai j'ai eu accès à ces
informations mais lui-même se base sur
la déclaration des voyages des députés
et donc vous avez euh
un peu plus de entre 20 ou 30 députés
qui ont été dont les voyages ont été
financés par le CRIF.
Donc les musulmans
votre responsabilité, votre visibilité,
faire des tweets avec des petites
horloges et ainsi de suite, c'est pas
immature, c'est pas puiril, c'est pas
remettre de l'huile sur le feu. Est-ce
que
Non, je pense que
premièrement,
je suis une femme politique certes, mais
je suis aussi normale. C'est-à-dire que
des fois j'aime bien prendre un peu à la
dérision certaines choses. Il y a des
moments où j'aime bien enfin j'aime bien
c'est pas que j'aime bien c'est que de
toute façon
la période est si tendue.
Mais la période est si tendue autour de
quoi ? Je veux dire Chalomi, c'est un
clown pour la communauté. Bah je suis
désolé si enfin je veux dire à un moment
donné respecter la communauté musulmane
de France
c'est dire que
ça vous engage que vous. Je le dis, je
le dis et je je le dis en une phrase.
Chaloui est placé,
soutenu
euh par tout un appareil politique et
cetera. Mais attendez, on le voit dans
les soutiens qu'il a. Il bénéficie des
soutiens euh symboliques aux politiques
de ministre de de
parce que peut-être il apa l'apaisement,
il a désolé. Non, attendez de tendre la
main.
Non non non. Je pense surtout qu'il a
une Je pense surtout qu'il a embrassé un
agenda qui consiste
C'est votre interprétation ?
C'est mon interprétation, je le dis.
Moi, je pense que Charles Gomi est placé
pour euh et c'est très dangereux, il est
placé alors que les musulmans qu'il est
placé.
Je pense qu'il est placé et qu'il est on
sait pas par qui il est financé
d'ailleurs. On sait pas par qui il est
financé. On sait pas par qui il est payé
parce qu'il n'a pas d'activité.
Vous ne savez pas ? Je ne sais pas mais
je veux dire j'ai j'ai cherché euh on
est il y a quelques artic
il y a quelques articles qui remontent à
un dignitaire syrien euh qui serait euh
proche euh qui était proche du régime
qui aurait euh euh Mais d'accord mais
qui a écrit ça ?
Mais justement je vous dis qu'on a pas
assez de sources sur savoir qui le
finance, qui lui donne de quoi vivre et
cetera.
C'est lui jeté c'est lui jeté.
J'observe que son avocat est membre
du comité exécutif du CRIF. Et alors,
pardon mais quand on est membre d'un
comité exécutif d'un lobby,
il reste avocat.
Il est avocat, il a le droit de défendre
qui veut.
Exactement.
Mais un avocat qui est membre, moi je
suis, imaginons demain, je suis membre,
je suis avocate et je suis membre d'un
comité exécutif d'un lobby. Je je suis
désolé, ça dit un bord. Veut pas me dire
c'est neutre. C'est pas possible de dire
que c'est neutre. Ça ça c'est une
étiquette quand même. C'est pas un odin.
Vous pensez que c'est une étiquette ? Je
pense bien sûr que c'est une étiquette
quand on fait partie d'un moment exictif
d'un lobby qui est présenté par Sylvain
Sipel. Là c'est par Rima Hassan.
principal qui est un historien
euh voilà reconnu pour ses travaux,
régulièrement invité, qui participe à de
nombreux ouvrages et bien Sylvain Sipel
présente l'écrive comme un lobby et
lui-même qui est de confession juive et
qui fait une étude très fine de ce
qu'est le le lobby justement israélien
un peu partout en en Occident et et donc
quand on est
mais ça reste un avocat,
ça reste un avocat mais qui a un bord je
pense. Voilà. Et je pense que aussi le
le les liens de Chalomi avec certains
cercles qui sont des cercles de
lobbiste,
est-ce que c'est
c'est pas ça le dialogue interreligieux
? Mais oui, quand on est à ce point
les interprétation
quand on est à ce point proche du CRIF,
quand on est à ce point proche de ces
cercles justement qui travaillent avec
un agenda politique lobiste, c'est pas
ça le dialogue interreligieux. dialogue
interreligieux, c'est de synagogue à
mosquée, de communautés très concrètes,
locale française, de musulmans français,
de juifs français. Israël n'a rien à
voir dans dans dans l'agenda du dialogue
interreligieux en France. Et c'est tout
le reproche que je fais au CRIF et que
je leur ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
vos
en des termes respectueux, par des
tweets interposés avec des petites
horloges. Non, mais déjà, j'ai le droit
d'être en colère. Je pense qu'à un
moment donné aussi humaniser le
politique et moi je me refuse à me
lisser à devenir comme certains
politiques je veux dire qui ont on
l'impression juste que c'est des
machines quoi. On sait même plus
qu'est-ce qui parle en eux. Bien moi le
fait que de temps en temps j'ai encore
un peu de colère, un peu de larme
parfois ça m'est arrivé de pleurer, de
craquer dans une interview, ça m'est
arrivé de et ben de de colère et cetera,
de rage même de et ben je suis désolée
mais c'est ce qui fait aussi de moi
quelqu'un je l'espère d'entier. euh de
de qui n'est pas faux, qui ne cherche
pas à lisser son image, qui ne cherche
pas à façonner son discours. Donc ça
c'est important pour moi de le garder et
de dire aussi que je suis humaine. J'ai
le droit à l'erreur, j'ai le droit
parfois de dire des conneries, j'ai le
droit parfois de voilà et j'ai le droit
aussi de rire. Et Charles Gomi, c'est un
cas vraiment qui fait rire, je crois 99
% des musulmans de France.
Mais qui c'est quoi votre source ? Il y
a eu un sondage des gens sondés. Mais je
vous je vous recommande,
c'est
c'est tout le reproche que je peux
éventuellement faire aussi au pouvoir et
au ministère de l'intérieur, c'est de
pas son les musulmans pour choisir des
gens qui le représentent dignement dans
ce qu'ils sont en train de vivre
actuellement. le niveau de persécution
d'islamophobie,
l'assassinat récemment de Abou Bakar
Sissé en pleine prière dans une mosquée.
Euh le le le le matraquage qu'il y a
autour de la situation des femmes
voilées par exemple qui peuvent
maintenant Abou Bakar qui pris des coups
de couteau par un mec qui a débarqué
alors qui faisait une
qui voulait en plus apprendre à prier a
priori et cetera. Et je veux dire les
femmes voilées qu'on prétend émanciper
alors qu'on les alors qu'on les prive du
marché du travail, qu'on cherche à les
exclure des universités, qu'on cherche
également à les interdire des
compétitions sportives. Je veux dire si
une femme voilée est vraiment soumise et
qu'on lui a vraiment imposé le voile,
vous croyez que le meilleur moyen de
l'émanciper, c'est de l'enfermer encore
plus, de l'empêcher de travailler, c'est
de l'empêcher de de d'avoir accès à
l'éducation, de se faire un cercle
d'amis. Non, enfin je veux dire c'est
contreproductif et ça c'est l'héritage
colonial aussi de la France. Les
campagnes dévoilement c'était en
Algérie. En Algérie française, vous
aviez déjà des campagnes dévoilez-vous,
vous êtes tellement plus belle sans vos
voiles.
Et en France, on dit pas,
c'est une maladie franco-française,
hein. L'obsession du voile, c'est une
maladie franco-française, hein. C'est
aucun pays
on a ce ce niveau.
Question internet. Si je vous dis Jésus
sioniste, interrogation,
je mets un contexte. Oui.
Jésus est un rabin juif qui manifestait
son hostilité à l'occupation romaine de
son pays, la Judée.
Ouais. Il a il a été crucifié par un
Romain à Jérusalem en l'an 30
ou
pour avoir contesté le pouvoir en Judée.
Hm
hm.
Signification de les cryptaux porté sur
la croix par les Romains. I N R I.
Je vous préviens, c'est du latin.
Oui.
Jésus de Nazareth, trois des Juifs.
Ouais.
Est-ce que
Jésus est un sioniste ?
Non. parce que là, il y a une confusion
entre l'héritage religieux et l'héritage
du projet politique. Donc par ailleurs
pour les Palestiniens, le Jésus est
palestinien. Je veux dire, vous regardez
vous regardez l'œuvre de du peintre
Mansour, du palestinien
Sliman Mansour qui est un peintre
chrétien par ailleurs palestinien euh
qui a beaucoup peint sur
toute la tout ce qui a de symbolique
pour les Palestiniens. Et d'ailleurs, il
fait partie du mouvement des artistes
qui a commencé à peindre la pastèque à
un moment où l'occupation israélienne
pourquoi on pourquoi la pintec est
devenue un symbole de la cause
palestinienne ? Parce que l'occupation
israélienne
à partir de de 67 a commencé à interdire
le drapeau palestinien et donc les
palestiniens notamment les artistes ont
commencé à utiliser la pastèque parce
qu'il reprenait les couleurs. Donc Simon
Mansour fait partie aussi de ce
mouvement là. Simon Mansour, il a
plusieurs œuvres où il présente euh les
chrétiens palestiniens et notamment
Jésus. Et euh donc pour les
Palestiniens, l'héritage de Jésus, c'est
que c'est un Palestinien et il faut pas
faire la confusion entre l'héritage
religieux et l'héritage sioniste qui est
un qui est un projet politique colonial.
Question intérêt. D'où vient le nom
Palestine ?
Philistine des Philistins.
C'est le nom donné à la Judée par Adrien
empereur romain en 135 après
Jésus-Christ. Oui. Bon, ça ser
pour punir les juifs qui se battaient
contre la colonisation romaine de la
Judée Adrien renommé leur pays
la Judée en Palestine pour effacer
étymologiquement l'origine juive de
cette terre entre parenthèses comme les
Arabes ont renommé la Judée en 6
Jordanie en 48. Fermez la parole.
Oui. Donc ça c'est la rhtorique
coloniale qu'on entend très
régulièrement. Donc encore une fois il y
a une confusion entre la question de
l'héritage religieux. Les Palestiniens
eux-mêmes vous diront que ils ont été
traversés par les trois religions
monothéistes qui sont parfaitement en
paix avec le fait d'avoir des origines
juives et que effectivement il peut y
avoir une communauté juive importante,
même importante en Palestine. Mais ça ne
peut pas se faire avec ce procédé de
dépossession, de colonisation, de
nettoyage ethnique, d'appartil, des
maintenantes de génocides euh contre le
peuple palestinien. Donc il faut pas
confondre la présence et l'héritage
de la question du judaïsme en fait
sur ces terre trois fois sainte avec un
projet politique qui encore une fois a
été porté historiquement par des
noncroyants, des non religieux.
Historiquement les sionistes, il y a un
sionisme maintenant religieux qui est
porté notamment par le rabin Cook qui
lui inverse la prophétie. C'est-à-dire
que pour le Rabin Cook, c'est
tous les juifs qui doivent venir en
terre sainte, en Palestine et pour faire
venir le Messie. Alors que
historiquement, le récit c'est vous êtes
condamné à l'exil à être un peuple
diasporique et c'est qu'au retour du
Messie que vous pourrez revenir. Et
Rabin Cook, bah lui c'est le sionisme
justement religieux. C'est-à-dire que
lui, il inverse, il inverse cette
lecture là. Il dit que le Messie ne
reviendra que quand il y aura tous les
juifs en Palestine historique. Donc il
faut vraiment pas confondre
judaïsme et sionisme dans leur héritage.
Il nous met une autre question. Pourquoi
les Arabes ne veulent pas cohabiter sur
cette terre avec les Juifs au pouvoir ?
Bon déjà moi j'ai un problème avec le
terme arabe parce que c'est un terme
colonial parce qu'il efface l'identité
nationale palestinienne. Les Israéliens
adorent convoquer le terme arabe.
Pourquoi ? parce que ça permet de diluer
les Palestiniens dans une identité arabe
régionale.
Comme vous, on pourrait dire, vous êtes
pas français, vous êtes européen. Non,
vous êtes français et européen. Vous
avez une une identité régionale et vous
avez une identité nationale. Et bien
pour les Palestiniens, c'est pareil, ils
ont une identité nationale et régionale.
Donc il faut faire très attention à
rectifier. Donc pourquoi les Arabes, les
Palestiniens ne veulent pas cohabiter ?
Je crois que les Palestiniens euh ont
été très très cléments, très très
réceptif aux initiatives
visant à chercher une cohab
cohabitation. Mais Israël est quand même
un des rar pays au monde qui n'a
toujours pas défini ses frontières, qui
se targue encore aujourd'hui de vous
d'aller vers le grand Israël. Donc
c'est quoi le grand Israël ?
Bah ce motriche par exemple et d'autres
he ministres, on parle de ministres, on
parle pas de deux trois fou en Israël,
on parle de ministres donc ils ont
politique d'état.
Euh c'est le grand Israël qui a inclut
aussi la Jordanie, qui a incluinaï qui a
inclut voilà des bouts de territoire de
différents pays de la région. Et
Isutriche fait des discours avec au
pupitre cette carte-là. Donc mo je dire
les jardiniens, ils font quelle tête ?
Et bien diplomatiquement effectivement
ça crée ça crée des tensions. Mais
est-ce que vous vivez en Jordanie ?
Est-ce que j'ai vécu où je vis ?
Est-ce que vous avez vécu ? Est-ce que
vous vivez ? Non, là actuellement je vis
à Bruxelles pour mon travail euh enfin
entre Bruxelles et Paris. Donc c'est
à Bruxelles
euh à côté de du Parlement. J'ai j'ai
commencé près de la gare mais ça me
faisait trop de trajet tous les jours.
Euh ça faisait 30 40 minutes. Donc je me
suis rapproché du parlement pour pouvoir
que ça soit plus simple. Euh donc du
coup je
j'ai vécu en Jordanie. Je je suis partie
après 7 octobre. J'ai étouffé du cadre
du débat en France. Je sais pas si tout
le monde se rappelle mais l'affaire des
40 bébés décapités, les mensonges, la
propagande israélienne. En fait, on
était dans une période de consentement
au génocide. Et j'ai très vite compris
ça. Moi, la première interview que je
donne où je parle de risque de génocide,
c'est fin octobre. C'est
fin octobre à Mediapart où je resitue
l'élément le plus important dans la
caractérisation du génocide. C'est pas
tellement les cinq actes qui sont
décrits, c'est l'élément intentionnel.
Le plus important dans la convention sur
la prévention du génocide au-delà de
l'atrocité des actes, c'est l'élément
intentionnel. Et l'élément intentionnel,
on l'avait déjà. On l'avait déjà animaux
humains, des déclarations visant à dire
il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de de
différence entre le Hamas et les
Palestiniens. Ils sont tous coupables
d'une certaine manière. Et donc le
discours qui s'installait en France,
c'était vraiment un discours médiatique
et politique de consentement au
génocide. On était en train de nous
faire accepter collectivement les
atrocités qui allaient venir
dont on allait être témoin.
Il avait pas encore.
Ah si, 2 jours après. 2 jours après. Et
donc là, toute la propagande qui s'est
mis en place, les financements par
ailleurs d'Israël, près de 5 millions de
dollars sur des chaînes YouTube et
cetera avec des des des micro des clips
de propagande.
Tout ça c'était vraiment ça a été fait
pour qu'on puisse à un moment donné
rendre acceptable le génocide en fait.
sans le nommer et avec une interdiction
bien sûr de le nommer comme ça.
Qui est-ce qui dit qu'il y a un génocide
à au jour d'aujourd'hui ? Après
la vraie question c'est qui ne dit pas
aujourd'hui ? Malheureusement, enfin je
j'enri mais c'est nerveux parce que ça
fait quand même 2 ans que on est épuisé
à dire que il y a un génocide qu'il faut
vraiment se et par ailleurs si on s'est
autant épuisé à dire qu'il y avait un
génocide c'est précisant parce que les
engagements de la France c'est sur la
prévention du génocide c'est pas sur
quand Macron dit
Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron pardon dit de manière
assez irresponsable
notre président charismatique l'human
le fameux Jupiter le le quand il dit euh
je laisse ça aux historiens. On verra
après, on commentera après. Il dit "Bon,
je sais pas s'il y a un génocide, s'il y
en a un, on verra. C'est les historiens
qui nous le diront."
C'est extrêmement problématique parce
qu'il trahit les engagements de la
France. Les engagements de la France
auprès de cette convention, c'est tout
faire pour prévenir le génocide. Et je
me suis renseigné sur la question de la
complicité.
Où est-ce que vous êtes renseigné ? Bah,
la convention elle-même. L'article 3 de
la convention prévoit que on peut
caractériser la complicité avec deux
éléments.
L'aide logistique, militaire, tout point
de vue, même économique, hein, je veux
dire quand on soutient une armée et tout
enfin qui est en train de commettre ce
qu'elle est en train de commettre, c'est
c'est un élément qui peut être
caractérisé, retenu pour apprécier la
complicité. Le deuxè élément, c'est quoi
? le fait d'être au courant des
intentions génocidaires.
Et même si le génocide
la doctrine sur ce ce sujet et la
jurisprudence sur ce sujet précise que
même si le génocide n'aboutit pas, même
si on est sur quelques actes pas
même si on n'est pas sur une le simple
fait d'être tenu au courant d'une
intention génocidaire d'un état envers
un groupe et de ne pas intervenir, de ne
pas tout faire pour l'éviter, c'est
apprécié comme de la compensation.
Il fallait faire quoi ? Il fallait
envoyer le porteavion Charles Gain
la première chose à faire c'est
l'embargo sur les armes. C'est ce qu'on
a fait pour la l'appartenide en Afrique
du Sud. Un embargo qui a été décrété. La
France a continué
la France de Mitteran a continué à
livrer des armes pendant un moment. Mais
je dis en tout cas l'embargo
source.
Oh ben les sources que j'ai pu lire sur
ce sujet euh
c'était à l'époque où j'ai rédigé mon
mémoire sur la partide. Donc euh
vous retrouvez ça franchement vous tapez
Mitéran à la partide vous retrouvez des
articles. Là j'ai pas un auteur en
particulier. Ce que je veux dire c'est
que ça a mis du temps à se mettre en
place et on a eu faire on a eu aussi à
on a eu affaire à un même discours un
peu hypocrite de droit de l'homme mais
en même temps on donne des armes à à un
régime d'appartide quoi qui massacrait
aussi et cetera. Donc la première chose,
c'est l'embargo sur les armes. La
deuxième chose, c'est
les sanctions économiques. Euh
c'est-à-dire
a un exemple très parlant du deux poids
de mesure de l'Occident et qui par
ailleurs nous fait perdre énormément sur
le plan stratégique et sur le plan de
comment on avance nos pions. Mais bien
sûr,
bien sûr, c'est la Russie et l'Ukraine.
la Russie et l'Ukraine, on est au 18e
paquet de sanctions pour l'Ukraine pour
la Russie enfin pour l'Ukraine contre la
Russie. Il n'y a pas une seule sanction
qui a été prononcée contre Israël depuis
2 ans, quasiment 2 ans. En octobre, ça
fera 2 ans.
Alors que les chiffres qu'on a, le
niveau de destruction qu'on a, le nombre
de cibles de civil documenté, ressourcé,
là récemment, j'ai vu que 500 employés
du haut commissariat au droits de
l'homme, 500 employés donc des gens qui
sont en maîtrise de ce sujet demander à
ce au commissariat de reconnaître le de
qualifier le génocide.
Donc aujourd'hui, en vrai, la question
qu'il se pose, c'est pas de savoir qui
dit qu'il y a un génocide. cette
bataille là entre guillemets allit
gagner même si je considère que c'est un
échec moi j'en suis absolument pas
satisfaite
fait que maintenant tout le monde puisse
par dire oui oui oui un génocide moi
bataille celle que j'ai mené et qui m'a
coûté c'était de dire dès le début
attention il y a un consentement au
génocide qui est en train de s'installer
dans le discours politique et médiatique
et l'intention d'Israël de commettre un
nettoyage ethnique et un génocide parce
que nettoyage ethnique c'est pas
vraiment un terme juridique mais un
génocide parce que là on a une
convention là-dessus il est là Il a CJ
la Cour internationale de justice qu'en
janvier 2024 elle nous dit risque
plausible. Risque plausible ça suffit.
Risque plausible ça suffit puisque c'est
une convention sur la prévention
et elle elle impose des mesures
conservatoires à Israël en disant si
Israël ne met pas en place ces mesures
conservatoires, il va y avoir
effectivement un génocide. Et là plutôt
que d'avoir affaire à une France droit
de l'homme droit de l'homiste
universaliste
comme prétend l'être et l'Union
européenne également.
qui convoque tous ces outils de
sanction, de diplomatie,
de dissuasion pour empêcher ce génocide.
Et ben on affaire à une Europe complice.
On a affaire à une Europe qui moi ce qui
me blesse le plus au-delà de la
complicité par rapport aux Palestiniens,
ce qui m'enrage le plus, c'est quand je
vois des dirigeants européens qui sont
prêts à se retourner contre leurs
propres citoyens pour sauver des des
intérêts
pitoyables, je veux dire, avec un un
état qui est en train de commettre un
génocide, d'intérêt économique,
stratégique et cetera. Quand on voit les
images qu'on voit à Berlin, quand on
voit qu'il y a des prisonniers
maintenant politiques, bon ça fait plus
partie de l'Union européenne mais en
Grande-Bretagne, quand on voit que aux
États-Unis également, quand on voit
qu'on a affaire à des États et en France
aussi hein, je veux dire la répression,
la la directive la directive oui, la
directive euh de
la circulaire pardon euh de
du 10 octobre faite par le le garde des
saut.
euh qui demande une poursuite
systématique pour appeler terrorisme.
L'utilisation qui été faite contre des
syndicalistes, contre Guillaume Maurice
qui est un humoriste, contre des
citoyens ordinaires qui ont pu être
parfois maladroit mais qui euh avaient
des choses à dire sur le débat qui se
posait. Quand je vois que l'État a
préféré mettre des moyens de justice,
d'argent public et puis de traumatisme,
je veux dire quand on est père de
famille, quand on est un militant, moi
j'ai de la chance que j'ai une
visibilité, j'ai une tribune, je peux
m'exprimer là, je peux venir une
immunité.
Oui, j'ai une immunité mais pour le
moment je l'ai pas convoqué. Je suis
allée aux convocations 11h30
d'interrogatoire sur les premières
affaires.
J'ai pas on n pas fait toutes les
affaires, je dois encore être entendu.
On en a fait quelques-unes pendant ces
11 heures et bien par des policiers qui
traitent les plaintes et qui appliquent
ses consignes du garde de saut des
gardes des saut de qui était Moritier à
l'époque qui disait poursuite
qui était qui était adressé au parquet
et qui disait bah en fait poursuite
systématique aucune impunité risqué.
Alors moi je risque rien à ce stade. Ce
que je risque c'est que parce que là j'y
vais de mon propre chef à ces
convocations. Je peux parfaitement dire
j'ai une immunité, je ne viens pas. Donc
j'y suis allée pour m'expliquer.
Je vais y retourner. J'ai rien caché.
Par ailleurs, je l'ai dit que c'était
aussi un signe de solidarité avec toutes
celles et ceux, tous les citoyens
ordinaires qui ont qui sont poursuivis
et qui sont convoqués et qui eux n'ont
pas la chance d'avoir une immunité à
convoquer. Donc voilà, je je vais je
joue le jeu comme tout le monde.
Qui est-ce qui paye vos frais de justice
?
Ben moi. Je pense que l'harcèlement
judiciaire a aussi cette finalité là,
c'est-à-dire obtenir la levée de mon
immunité au parlement,
me faire condamner. Donc vous voyez, une
condamnation à un moment donné, ça
permet de de mettre une étiquette quoi,
de dire elle a été condamnée, voilà donc
de d'exclure un peu petit à petit les
tribunes que je peux avoir ou la
crédibilité de mon propos aussi. Je
pense vraiment, je crois que c'est ça la
finalité. Et puis l'harcèlement
judiciaire, c'est aussi un harcèlement
financier.
C'est aussi un harcèlement financier
parce que effectivement il faut couvrir
les frais d'avocat, il faut euh il faut
suivre les affaires et puis il faut on n
pas encore eu de procès mais je veux
dire il y a quand même des parties des
associations qui se constituent partie
civile.
Ça c'est quand même assez cocasse se
partie civile parce que Rima Hassan a
utilisé le le terme soulèvement. Enfin,
je veux dire, il faut quand même être
sacrément indécent et culoté.
Oui.
Pour venir poursuivre des militants qui
contre le génocide. Parce que au-delà
fait que je sois palestinienne, au-delà
du fait que je sois personnellement
touché, je suis française mais je suis
aussi palestinienne.
Euh mais au-delà du fait de la dimension
personnelle de mon parcours et de mes
origines,
je trouve ça particulièrement indéc
d'aller poursuivre des militants qui
luttent contre un génocide
en leur disant "Je veux en plus des je
veux en plus être indemnisé parce que
moi j'ai été offusquée par le terme
soulèvement." C'est quand même
incroyable. On vit quand même une époque
incroyable où on est plus offusqué par
le terme soulèvement pour une
mobilisation étudiante que contre un
génocide qui est en train de se passer
sous nos
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'étudiante
qui a qui a fait des tweets antisémites
euh et qui et qui euh bloque maintenant
lequel ?
C'était dans dans quelle université déjà
? Rafraîchissez-moi la mémoire.
Un étudiant qui a fait des tweets.
Ouais. Une étudiante palestinienne.
Ah oui, c'est l'étudiante qui avait
obtenu une protection à la CNDA et qui a
fait
CNDA pour ceux qui ne savent pas. la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile, donc
dans laquelle j'ai j'ai travaillé par
ailleurs quelques années 6 ans.
Donc la CNDA pour ceux qui savent pas,
quand un réfugié demande une protection
internationale, il passe par l'Office
français de protection des réfugiés des
apatrides. S'il est dégoûté de sa
demande, il fait une demande auprès de
la CNDA. Il fait un recours pardon
auprès de la demande de la CNDA. Donc la
CNDA a apprécié effectivement
euh une violence généralisée ou je sais
plus exactement les termes juridiques
qu'elle a retenu pour cette affaire.
Science Paulille.
Oui. Alors, elle était à Science
Paulile. Donc, on est parti fouiller,
on est parti fouiller ces tweet
après le 7 octobre et cetera.
Moi, j'aimerais savoir si on fait ça
avec des franco-israéliens.
un franco-israélien qui aurait mis, il y
en a qui aurait mis sur les réseaux des
vidéos, il participe au génocide ou qui
pourrait dire "Oui, il faut tous les
tuer, il y a pas de différence entre la
Hamas et cetera." Donc moi, je veux bien
encore une fois, c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure, euh il faut quand
même analyser cette colonialité dans
laquelle on est, qui fait que quand le
Hamas tue quelques centaines de civil
israéliens, ce sont des terroristes,
mais quand le Israël, l'armée d'Israël
tue plus de 60000 Palestiniens dont une
écrasante majorité sont des civils, le
débat s'oppose pas de savoir si c'est
une armée terroriste, c'est un état
terroriste. et avec les mêmes
répercussions parce que quand on dit est
terrorist c'est on veut bannir
sanctionner et cetera donc pourquoi on
ferait pas ça avec de la même manière si
vous avez une étudiante
qui est d'origine palestinienne et qui a
tenu des propos problématiques sur les
réseaux et cetera avec l'âge qu'elle a
avec l'époque qu'elle vit aussi parce
qu'il faut pas oublier qu' elle sort de
Gaza. Voilà on peut très bien les
condamner. Moi, je j'ai aucun problème
avec le fait qu'on les condamne. Mais
pourquoi on condamne pas les propos
tenus par les franco-israéliens qui sont
tout aussi problématiques ? Et ça,
il y en a pas qui sont il y en a pas qui
sont euh poursuivis. On a eu que deux
informations judiciaires qui ont été
ouvertes contre deux personnalités qui
ont bloqué l'aide humanitaire, qui
participent à des activité visant à
bloquer l'aide humanitaire à Gasin. Donc
là, on est vraiment sur quelque chose de
très caractérisé et qui dont elle se
revendique elle-même par ailleurs en
disant on a réussi à bloquer tant de
camions et cetera et cetera. Et donc moi
ce que je veux dire c'est que pour
conclure sur ça,
vous parlez vous parlez des camions.
Est-ce que le Hamas met la main sur les
camions en question ? Non, parce que vo
làà, je vous invite à regarder et lire
Jean-Pierre Filou justement qui c'est
historien qui revient de Gaza et qui dit
alors oui, il y a quelques milices qui
foutent un peu le bazar dans cette aide
humanitaire et en fait on observe
qu'elles sont financées et soutenu par
Israël.
C'est quoi ces sources ? Mais c'est un
historien qui documente sur place. Euh
je veux dire si vous commencez à
contester les sources de Jean-Pierre
Fulio sur le sujet, on enlève Henry
Lawrence, on en on enlève Ilan Papé, on
enlève des gens très sérieux quoi. Donc
là, il a fait
teste pas, je demande,
je crois qu'il a fait une interview
d'ailleurs à sujet, je sais plus, c'est
France Interre ou il me semble que c'est
France Interre
euh où il où on lui demande
explicitement euh d'expliquer cette
question de la de l'aide humanitaire. Et
il dit effectivement il y a quelques
bandits en fait c'est même pas des
milices structurées organisées
politiquement. Il dit c'est c'est on
dirait c'est des mercenaires en fait des
mercenaires des des des bandits en fait
qui vont
utiliser cette aide humanitaires
et qui sont armés mais en fait on se
rend compte qu'ils sont financés et
armés par Israël.
Et d'ailleurs récemment, on a eu
Netanyahu qui s'est justifié de financer
sûr de ça ?
Oui oui oui oui, je suis sûr de ça.
Et Jean-Pierre, il est sûr de ça ?
Bien sûr qu'il est sûr de ça et c'est
l'objet d'ailleurs de d'un livre. Non,
il est pas tout seul. Et récemment, je
vous invite à regarder les propos euh de
Nathanahu quand on il a été confronté
euh par des Israéliens euh puisqu'il a
été documenté qu'il finançait Daesh,
enfin la branche euh la branche euh de
l'État
islamique ou des des là pour le coup des
djihadistes qu' on aucune revendication
politique structurée sur la question
palestinienne à Gaza. Et il dit il dit
"Oui, j'ai pas de problème avec ça. Tant
que ça nous permet
d'affaiblir
d'affaiblir le Hamas. Je enfin,
j'aimerais comprendre la structure de
pensée de Nintentenahu qui fait le tour
du monde pour dire notre combat c'est
celui contre le terrorisme quand en fait
on est en train de d'armer et de
financer
à l'international
les Espagnols, les Belges, qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont dit récemment ?
Alors qu'il les Espagnols alors attendez
l'intermédiaire de qui ? Alors, les
Belges, ils sont dans une dynamique de
reconnaissance de l'État palestinien
pour la conférence du 22. Donc ça
rejoint en rejoignant notamment le
Canada, euh la Grande-Bretagne, enfin
l'Angleterre, euh la France euh à mon
sens, ce sont les États là qui et
l'Espagne a déjà reconnu, c'était
c'était il y a déjà plus d'un an,
l'Espagne,
la Norvège,
euh la Suède, enfin je dirais vous avez
déjà
il y a eu déjà une première vague de
reconnaissance de l'État palestinien car
maintenant près d'un an et Là, nous
sommes sur une deuxième étape, disons
qui est un peu plus portée par la France
et d'autres grands d'autres grandes
grands états qui vont qui pèsent quand
même, je veux dire, sur la
ça veut dire quoi ? Ils interdisent
notamment la Grand-Bretagne parce que
c'est l'ancienne empire colonial,
il coupent les ponts avec le commerce
avec Israël, ils mettent des sanctions.
Non, malheureusement Malheureusement on
en est pas là. Et là, on arrive à la
question la plus épineuse pourou. Il a
pas un mandat d'arrêt qui a été émis
pour quelqu'un ? Par qui déjà
? La CPI
qui est reconnu par ?
Bon, par tous les États quasiment, on a
très peu d'États qui coopèrent pas avec
la CPI. Bon, les États-Unis font partie
de ces états, mais après une différence
entre non coopération et ratification du
traité de de Rome. Donc, on peut parfois
ne pas ratifier un traité mais
coopérer. Donc la France en tout cas et
tous les États de l'Union européenne
sans exception ont non seulement
ratifier mais en plus coopère s'engage
réitère régulièrement leur engagement à
coopérer avec la CPI. Donc on l'a vu, le
dernier cas, ça a été le cas de Poutine
où il y a eu un consensus très clair. Et
là, nous avons eu Nathanahu qui a pu
survoler effectivement
l'espace aérien français à plusieurs
reprises et on a vu le ministère des
affaires étrangères convoquer une uneité
qui n'existe pas vraiment. Alors tous
les juristes et même des organisations
ont démenti
en refaisant la lecture des bah des
articles de des traités du traité de
Rome du statut de la CPI en disant
l'immunité pour les crimes les plus
graves n'existe pas en réalité. Et donc
la France a
aurait pu arrêter Nathanahu aurait pu
arrêter Nathanahu. Il l'a pas fait.
C'est ça la vérité. Qu'on doit aux
français pas qu'on qu'on doit aux
Palestiniens mais qu'on doit aussi au
français. Parce que moi ce qui me
dérange énormément dans cette complicité
crasse avec le régime de Natthaniau,
c'est aussi le sacrifice qui est fait
des de la population quoi, et la la
manipulation qui va avec. On a un
sondage qui date de plusieurs mois qui
démontrait, je sais pas si l'hop ou non,
peut-être pas l'ipope, pardon, euh je
suis désolée si vous arrivez à retrouver
la source, un sondage qui précisait que
76 % des Français étaient favorables à
des sanctions contre Israël.
Et euh pour moi, il y a vraiment une
trahison et une manipulation aussi de
l'opinion. Euh quand on convoque une
immunité qui n'en est pas, quand on dit
"Bénocide, c'est une affaire
d'historien" alors qu'en fait la France
a ratifé une convention sur la
prévention du génocide que tout ça ça
nous engage dans notre histoire commune.
Enfin, je veux dire Macron dans quelques
années et il ira dans sa maison de
campagne, il sera à la retraite avec
tous ses privilèges, je veux dire
avec Brigitte.
Voilà. Et nous euh le peuple aussi qui
est militant qui est sensible en tout
cas moi je pense que le français moyen
contrairement à ce qu'on est on veut on
veut faire croire et bien sans dis
français moyen c'est pas péjoratif mais
qui est pas trop politisé qui se qui se
tient informé mais qui qui est pas ni
pro palestinien ni proien je pense qu'il
est vraiment vraiment touché par ce qui
se passe. Je pense que vraiment la la
France profonde en fait c'est une France
qui n'accepte pas ce qui se passe. Et
c'est ça aussi qu'on veut empêcher faire
émerger dans le débat. Euh moi en me
diabolisant comme juste un ennemi de
l'intérieur
qui propagéit euh qui propage
l'antisémitisme,
qui euh cautionne le le les attentats
terroristes.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Oui. Alors que pas du
tout. Je veux dire, quand on prend le le
temps de de discuter, moi ce que je je
refuse qu'on me retire des éléments
complexes de réflexion. Je refuse qu'on
me dise de simplifier en fait cette
réflexion là. Et euh et je veux qu'
qu'on garde cet espace de débat et cet
espace de liberté en fait. Et ça
n'empêche pas de dire que oui, il y a eu
un mode opératoire. Oui, ce qui s'est
passé à l'endroit des civils est
condamnable. C'est le travail des
juridictions internationales, ça relève
des crimes de guerre, de crimes contre
l'humanité et cetera. Mais en même
temps, moi j'ai le droit de resituer que
il y a des résolutions des Nations-
Unies qui prévoient la lutte armée. Il y
a des résolutions des Nations- Unies euh
et une historicité qui resitue le peuple
palestinien d'abord comme un peuple
victime d'une colonisation de peuplement
qui se bat pour son indépendance, qui se
bat pour sa survie maintenant dans un
contexte de génocide et qui a été
abandonné. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du projet de
Trump
de délocalisation de euh 5000 5000
dollars en cash, de 4 ans
d'alimentation, 4 ans de loyer et euh 1
an de nourriture.
Et bien là euh
et des jetons des jetons euh pour des
jetons numériques pour si vous avez un
bien, vous pourrez revenir, vous serez
dans un appartement, dans une ville
connectée. Voilà.
Là, on a
l'élément le plus cynique, je crois,
dans le colonialisme.
C'est
un départ volontaire.
Il y a pas de départ volontaire, c'est
un départ contraint de par la
conjoncture de
du génocide. C'est-à-dire que quand on
détruit près de 80 Corastou à Gaza, euh
oui, peut-être que les familles vont
devoir se dire "On a plus le choix, faut
qu'on aille ailleurs." Mais je veux
dire, ça c'est l'histoire de la
migration forcée, hein. C'est pas un
départ volontaire. dans le monde, vous
avez euh si on se réfère aux données du
au commissariat de réfugiés des Nations
Unies, le HCR, on est à plus de 100000
100 millions de personnes déplacées.
C'est pas des gens qu' on envie de
partir. C'est des gens qui partent parce
que c'est la guerre, parce que il y a de
la famine, parce que voilà. Et donc pour
les Palestiniens, on n pas de visibilité
pour le moment pour savoir ce qui va
vraiment pouvoir se mettre en place. Ce
qui est sûr, c'est que les Palestiniens
n'en veulent pas. Ce qui est sûr, c'est
que les Palestiniens dans leur grande
majorité
préfèrent, je pense, mourir sur leur
terre que mourir en exil. Parce qu'ils
encore une fois, pourquoi je dis les
paliens sont déjà fait avoir en 1948 ?
La composition de la société
palestinienne à Gaza,
elle est composée en grande majorité de
réfugiés palestiniens de 1948.
C'est pour ça que des historiens comme
Ilan Papé et d'autres vous disent qu'en
fait Gaza c'est un c'est pas la bande de
Gaza, c'est un c'est un immense camp de
réfugi en fait. La majorité
certains disent quoi d'autre ?
Prison à ciel ouvert. Mais là c'est un
cimetière maintenant c'est un c'est plus
une prison je veux dire c'était une
prison à ciel ouvert.
Vous avez vu les images de la télé
turque ?
Non.
Qui survolait Gaza ? Ah euh j'en ai vu,
je sais pas si c'était cel de la de la
télévision turque, mais oui, tout est
euh Oui, totalement. Totalement. Donc
euh
moi, c'est pour ça que je je veux dire
que je ne crois pas à la solution à deux
États.
Alors, comment on fait pour réconcilier
tout ce petit monde qui qui ne rêve que
de s'écharper ? Je ne crois non je crois
pas que c'est le rêve et présenté comme
ça c'est trompeur. Je crois que les
Palestiniens sont en attente d'une
solution politique
politique. Ils sont pas en Ils sont pas
dans un
le Hamas.
C'est au palestinien de le décider.
C'est au palestinien de le décider. Je
suis ça aussi. Je suis désolée mais je
suis intransigente sur la la posture
coloniale qu'on a avec le reste du monde
qui consiste à dire personne n'est venu
dire au français comment il fallait
lutter contre les Allemands et
l'occupation allemande.
Les Français on n pas tué des bébés
allemands.
Non mais attendez euh les Palestiniens
le 7 octobre, ils ont pas tué des bébés
hein. Affaire des 40 bébés décapités
c'est un fake. Vous êtes au courant
maintenant j'espère. Voilà donc euh les
gamines
au concert là.
Oui. Non mais encore une fois, il y a eu
des civils, mais je veux dire resitués.
Je vous ai lu un extrait de des
exactions commises par l'armée
israélienne. À un moment, les
Palestiniens n'étaient même pas
structurés politiquement. Il y avait ni
Fata, ni OLP, ni Hamas. Donc il faut
resituer. Je veux dire ça ça s'inscrit
en réponse à quoi cette radicalité ?
C'est pour ça que je vous dis que c'est
très dangereux quand on et moi je trouve
ça très problématique pour un état qui
se dit démocratique d'arriver à un
moment où on cherche à retirer tous les
éléments complexes du débat. Que moi,
j'arrivais sur les plateaux disais
terroriste ou pas terroriste, vous
condamnez ou vous condamnez pas ? Alors
attendez, pardon, mais je j'ose espérer
que j'ai euh un peu plus d'espace pour
réfléchir les événements historiques de
ces templeurs et on nous l'a pas donné
cet espace là. Donc euh
vous pensez que tout ce qui est simple,
du moins vous qualifiez tout ce qui est
simple et court, c'est le passeport pour
le slogan idéologique pur.
Ouais, je pense que je pense que sur
tous les sujets,
il faut prendre le temps.
Il faut prendre le temps. Il faut avoir
de l'humilité, il faut avoir des doutes.
Faut se méfier des gens qui ont beaucoup
de certitude, peuvent avoir des
convictions.
Comment on dit ça en grec ?
Tout ce que je sais, c'est que je ne
sais rien. Voilà. Donc il faut il faut
se il faut enfin je veux dire il faut
qu'il y ait des gens faut qu'il y ait un
panel en fait de conviction qui se
croise qui se mélangent qui débattle.
On revient sur la question
internationale. Ça fait 2h47. J'ai
encore plus
Ah oui pardon on a débordé.
Non mais il y a rien à déborder parce
qu'ici on reste autant de temps qu'on
veut. D'ailleurs, on pas beaucoup parlé
de l'étabe. Merci à notre communauté de
nous soutenir sur Tipi parce que c'est
grâce à eux qu'on peut prendre le temps
de discuter qu'on soit d'accord pas
d'accord avec toutes les argum. Je pense
que je me rends pas compte parce que
j'ai très peu accès à ce type de format.
Donc je suis en train de partager
beaucoup de choses. Vous
pouvez remercier notre communauté.
Oui, tout à fait. Je vous remercie.
Grâce à eux, on est indépendant, on fait
ce qu'on veut, on soit qui on veut,
même s'il y a des gens qui vont pas être
contents qu'on vous ait reçu.
Oui, c'est
il y a des gens qui vous considèrent
comme promoteuses d'un antisémitisme,
machin. Mais il faut écouter tout le
monde.
Ouais. Et
et il faut prendre le temps et quand les
gens se parlent, les gens évitent de se
taper dessus. C'est vrai.
Donc sur les questions internationales,
la Cour pénale internationale, elle a
fait elle a émis quoi ? Alors, c'est la
Cour de justice internationale.
Alors, il y a deux affaires. La c'est la
Cour internationale de justice, elle
traite du litige entre les États.
Soutenez-nous sur Tipi.
Oui. La euh Cour pénale internationale
poursuit des dirigeants, des criminels.
Donc, il faut bien distinguer le mandat
des deux juridictions. Donc, du Hamas et
côté Israélien.
Et côté israélien. Donc, ceux qui
étaient poursuivis pour le Hamas sont
morts. Israélien
sont morts du côté de la CPI, de la
procédure de la CPI. Et donc du côté
israélien, c'est
mort de leur vie de leur vieillesse.
Non, ils sont morts dans les
bombardements israéliens.
Ils ont été liquidés.
Liquidés. Voilà. Donc les palisens n'ont
pas les moyens de liquider un Nanyaho
au galante. Donc
faire peut-être le poursuivre devant une
cour de justice internationale. Oui, je
pense que de toute façon euh c'est pour
dire que ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
a tendance effectivement à pardonner
systématiquement des procédés à Israël
qu'on ne pardonne pas à d'autres à
d'autres
dire si demain un État je sais pas
l'Iran ou je ne sais euh assassinait euh
Benjamin Netanyahu à juste titre on
trouverait ça purement inacceptable et
qu'on convoquerait justement le droit
international et la procédure de droit
international. Bah pour les
Palestiniens, on s'est je crois habitué
à ce queils soient comme vous dites
liquidé. Euh donc du côté palestinien
euh
c'est une guerre hein.
C'est pas une guerre.
C'est quoi
une guerre ? Ça suppose deux armées,
deux états. Et ce que dit et rappelle
très bien Francesca Albanaisé qui est la
rapporteur spéciale des Nations Unies
sur les territoires occupé, c'est
qu'elle
qui est poursuivie.
Elle est pas poursuivie, elle est
menacée par les États-Unis. on leur a on
lui on lui refuse l'accès au territoire
pour ses travaux parce qu'effectivement
on doit se rendre régulièrement au siège
des Nations- Unies et et donc pour la
dissuader de poursuit son travail, on
l'a on l'a interdit d'accès, il me
semble limiter en tout cas ses ses
déplacements aux États-Unis. Euh ce
qu'elle dit bien, c'est qu'elle dit euh
un état qui occupe un territoire, il a
des responsabilités vis-àis de la
population civile qui vit sur ce
territoire et il ne peut pas considérer
ne pas convoquer euh une attaque menée
par des occupés
contre des occupants pour dire on se
défend. Non, puisque la première
agression initiale, c'est celle de
l'occupation.
On n'est pas dans un contexte où vous
avez un état palestinien reconnu,
autonome, souverain. Israël ne touche
pas à ce territoire et puis bah les
palestiniens du jour au lendemain, ils
se mettent à attaquer les territoires
israéliens. Là, on pourrait dire que on
rentrerait dans une logique de guerre et
puis d'affrontement. Voilà. Mais
on peut faire une expérience de pensée
vous et moi.
Mais là en l'occurrence, on est dans un
territoire occupé par Israël depuis des
décennies. Depuis l'élection du Hamas
par ailleurs, il y a un blocus
humanitaire euh un blocus surtout par
ailleurs qui les Israéliens eux-mêmes
disent "On a ce blocus permet juste aux
païsens de survivre." Mais euh voilà en
terme de c'est vraiment c'est pour ça
c'est pas c'est pas pour rien qu'on
l'appelle une prison à ciel ouvert.
Voilà. Et même en terme de nourriture et
cetera, c'est pile ce qui permet aux
palissens de survivre. Donc la
l'agression du Hamas, l'attaque du
Hamas, qu'on le veuille ou non, c'est
une réponse à d'abord un contexte
particulier d'occupation d'asphyxie de
la population palestinienne qui ne
trouve pas par ailleurs un une issue, un
débouché politique
avec tous les éléments condamnables
qu'il y a dans cette attaque bien
entendu.
Et donc la riposte israélienne, c'est
une riposte faut la resituer non pas
comme une guerre mais sur un territoire
qui est déjà occupé sur lequel Israël
exerce déjà des violations du droit
international réputé. Je veux dire, on
peut citer les dates des guerres à Gaza
le 7 octobre
2008 mais avant le 7 octobre.
C'était inadmissible.
Oui bien sûr. Je l'ai déjà dit. peut pas
on peut pas reconnaître ça parce que la
pensée complexe parce que machin
mais non mais j'ai déjà dit que vous
pouvez condamner mais on peut on a le
droit j'espère pouvoir aller au-delà
juste de la condamnation on peut dire
c'est pas bien et c'est condamnable et
ça relève de telle qualification
juridique par ailleurs parce qu'il faut
aller au-delà de la qualification terro
ce qui nous intéresse, c'est la
qualification juridique
de guerre
mais il y a plein de chercheurs qui
utilisent jamais il y a plein
d'historiens qui qui ne rentrent pas
dans le jeu de du terrorisme de la
qualificaation terroriste. Il ils vous
disent nous c'est qualification
juridique.
Ils sont partis au 7 octobre du juif.
C'est un pogrome. Non, je suis désolé
c'est pas un pogromme.
C'est quoi ?
C'est pas un pogrome.
C'est une attaque avec un mode
opératoire terroriste. Mais ce que dit
Henry Lawrence, il dit "Mais les
Palestiniens sont pas antisémites en
fait par nature, ils sont
antioccupation." Ça veut dire que si à
la place des Israéliens c'était des
Chinois, imaginons que historiquement
c'est des
c'est les Chinois tranquilles,
peu importe des Français, les
Britanniques. Imaginons que les
Britanniques sont restés, qu'il y a pas
de projectionnistes, mais les
Britanniques sont restés et que ils ils
avaient imposé aux Palestiniens les
conditions vies qu'Israël a imposé aux
Palestiniens. Mais je peux vous assurer
mais je peux vous assurer que les
Palestiniens auraient commis le le même
type d'attaque.
Donc c'est pas motivé par la religion.
Et d'ailleurs euh les premiers grands
mouvements de révolte, les Palestiniens
sont dirigés contre les Britanniques.
369, l'État d'Israël n'est pas créé.
Donc
enfin, c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il
faut pas enlever les éléments de de Mais
dire ça, c'est pas dire qu'il y a euh
rien de problématique dans le
nationalisme arabe vis-à-vis euh
d'Israël sur qui on projette
effectivement des fantasmes parfois qui
peuvent être peuvent convoquer toute
l'histoire de de des clichés antisémites
et cetera. On peut être parfaitement
critique sur ça. On peut être
parfaitement lucide, honnête sur le fait
que les communautés juive ont parfois
été aussi ciblé dans le monde arabe
après les guerres israélo-arabes parce
que c'est devenu vraiment en source de
tension. C'està-dire qu'on par
en France aussi. Non mais c'està dire
que par exemple dans le monde arabe tu
as pu avoir des situations. On a dit aux
juifs bon bah c'est Israël ou faut
choisir quoi.
J'ai des copains juifs qui enlève leur
nom de la boîte aux LED parce qu'ils ont
peur de se faire emmerder.
Oui, bah peut-être, mais bon, je veux
dire, il faut resituer aussi en
parallèle les actes islamophobes qui ont
bondi. On est je sais pas si on
c'est une raison pour
mais je Ah non, je vous dis juste que
moi je je suis assez lassé aussi et ça
même les juifs antisionistes vous le
disent.
Euh on est assez lassé de la convocation
de l'antisémitisme
pour faire taire aussi les voix
qui réfléchissent, qui reproposent, qui
sont même militantes sur la question
palestinienne. Donc il faut aussi
resituer la même manière. Je crois qu'il
y a que a fait ça. Il y a un petit
reportage sur la la montée de de
l'islamophobie et de l'antisémitisme
après le 7 octobre. Est-ce que vous
pensez que le 7 octobre a été planifié
pour ensuite pouvoir créer encore plus
de martyres palestinien en sachant que
euh Tsallait
péter un câble et arroser tout le monde
?
Non non franchement non. Je non déjà il
faut dire que Israël a été prévenu ça
aujourd'hui. Euh
par qui ? Comment ?
L'Égypte. Euh l'Égypte et d'autres
sources de renseignement régional.
l'Égypte, les renseignements égyptiens
ont prévenu
lesquels ceux qui ont les grands mentons
noirs les noirs
de tr de tr les les le pouvoir en fait
égyptien a prévenu de tr semaines il me
semble avant l'attaque du 7 en disant on
observe quand même des entraînements
assez répétés de du Hamas euh des
entraînements militaires et cetera
il apprennent à piloter des ULM
donc on on on prévient en fait les
autorités israéliennes et les autorités
israéliennes je crois qu'elles étaient
tellement obsédé par la question
coloniale de la si Jordanie
que en fait ils avaient concentré
l'essentiel de leur
leur contingent contingent militaire euh
en territoire de la si Jordanie en fait
et donc ils ont manqué de renforts et de
réaction et de je pense de lucidité mais
et vous avez aussi des lectures et elles
sont elles elles doivent aussi être
entendues. Finalement, Netanou aurait
peut-être pas laissé faire pour aller au
bout de l'agenda qui est celui de
plusieurs de ses ministres et de sa
coalition qui est au pouvoir.
C'est prouvé, c'est carré, ça s'appelle
let it happen, laissez faire. Oui, mais
c'est en fait c'est on va dire on peut
naturellement se poser la question. Vous
êtes au courant, vous êtes à la tête
d'un pays qui on vous prévient qu'il y a
une attaque qui est en train de se
préparer. Vous savez que à la frontière
de Gaza, il y a des cliotes, qu'il y a
beaucoup de civils et cetera et cetera,
que forcément si les gens sortent, ils
vont avoir affaire certes à des
militaires mais aussi à des des civils.
Euh en responsabilité, vous intervenez
pour protéger la population. Si vous
intervenez pas, faut réfléchir pourquoi
vous intervenez pas.
Et quand on voit l'agenda,
c'est la lenteur administrative.
Je crois que là je pense qu'
moi je connais un pays européen où il y
a un premier ministre qui a été prévenu
par des Syriens qui avaient des mecs un
peu chelous qui se baladaient, qui voul
qui allit Oui oui, j'ai entendu parler
de Oui, mais ce que je veux ce que je
veux dire, c'est que il y avait deux
éléments, je veux pas je veux pas non
plus être complotiste au paranoïque. Je
pense que il y a bien sûr l'élément de
la colonisation, c'est-à-dire que ils
avaient vraiment tout misé sur je pense
la colonisation de la si Jordanie.
Voilà. Et donc les militaires étaient
essentiellement mobilisés sur ces
territoires-là. Euh donc ils ont
clairement manqué de renfort au moment
de l'attaque.
Expliquer la non réaction la non
réaction des autorités israéliennes
quand on sait ce qui se préparait le 7
octobre. Et je pense que le sacrifice
aussi des otages
lui des autorités israéliennes
actuellement, c'est-à-dire récup occuper
et d'ailleurs ça a été voté à la CN7
occuper en fait définitivement la bande
de Gaza et aller au bout du projection
sionniste tel qu'il a été défini
initialement, c'est-à-dire un projet
d'un foyer national juif mais sans les
Palestiniens. Le fait qu'il y a eu le 7
octobre, est-ce que le est-ce que ça a
prouvé que le Hamas, ils en avaient rien
à faire des répercussions sur les civils
?
Euh, je pense que les Palestiniens
palestiniens vous voulez dire ou
israéliennes ou les deux ? Ils en
avaient rien à faire de de qui ? De des
Israéliens. On avait rien à faire.
Attendez parce que j'ai Montréal qui
s'agite. Tu veux tu t'agites derrière,
d'accord ?
Est-ce que ça a prouvé que le Hamas
n'avait rien à faire des civils
palestiniens et qu'ils allaient être
utilisés comme bouclier ? Cherak ?
Non, je pense peut-être naïvement.
Peut-être naïvement. vraiment ça
n'engage que moi. C'est pour ça que je
je dis ça n'engage que moi. Je pense
peut-être naïvement que le Hamas pensait
réellement avec cette prise d'otage,
avec tout ce qu'elle a effectivement
d'éléments problématiqu de d'otage
plus que problématique.
Alors j'aimerais juste que vous soyez
aussi investi sur les otages
palestiniens. Vous inquiétez pas quand
on va recevoir l'ambassade d'Israël si
ils acceptent notre dans ce cas. Je me
permets juste de donner un chiffre des
organisations palisiennes qui
travaillent sur ce sujet.
Il y a plus de 10000 prisonniers
palestiniens alors on se parle dont près
de 30 % qui ne sont qui sont emprisonnés
sans charge ni procès sans sans pouvoir
se défendre.
Un peu comme un guantanamo.
Est-ce que c'est des otages ou pas ? Bah
pour nous c'est des otages. Voilà. Donc
ça on en parle pas. Et ça se compte en
en milliers. D'accord. Donc des
tortures.
Bien sûr, bien sûr qu'il y a des
tortures. Bien sûr. Et ça, je le relais
assez régulièrement moi sur mes réseaux
pour dénoncer effectivement euh
de quel type ?
Et bien, on sait par exemple les
tortures qui sont souvent utilisées,
c'est euh bon déjà, on utilise
récemment, on a utilisé les chiens euh
voilà, on a des paléens sont même fait
uriner dessus. On a aussi le il y a eu
des documentations par l'ONU de
d'agression de sexuel et de de recours à
même à des à des viols. Euh et on a
aussi voilà cette position qui revient
souvent dans les les témoignages, c'est
les Palestiniens qui sont sur une chaise
et en fait on leur ou un une table ou et
en fait on leur rattache, on fait comme
un cercle avec leur corps, on leur
rattache les mains et les pieds par le
bas.
Donc euh c'est assez fréquent donc et ça
personne en fait ne s'y intéresse depuis
des décennies en les présentant comme
des otages. Mais vous savez qu'en si
Jordanie, c'est un paliste un homme sur
deux qui a eu affaire aux autorités
israéliennes en terme d'arrestation. Un
homme sur deux
enf je dire avant le 7 octobre. Faut pas
me parler de
de de la question de la du convoquer la
question du terrorisme quand on a la
moitié des hommes palestiniens adultes
qui ont été un moment un autre arrêté
par les autorités israéliennes. Donc
très bien les otages, on peut avoir de
l'empathie pour eux, on peut convoquer
leur situation de otage. J'aimerais
juste qu'on ait l'honnêteté
intellectuelle d'en faire deux même pour
les Palestiniens qui sont oage d'un état
colonial, oage d'un état génocidaire,
oage d'un état d'apartide.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent en face ? Et
donc je pense cyniquement, pour répondre
à votre question, je pense que
cyniquement ou naïvement les les
Palestiniens, en tout cas le Hamas à et
les autres partis qui ont travaillé
à commanditer cette attaque, je pense
que il pensaiit pouvoir avoir une un
moyen de contraindre les Israéliens à
négocier avec les otages.
On peut planter, non ? euh pas forcément
parce qu'au début euh les premiers mois
euh même la première année, ils ont
réussi à les faire libérer plusieurs
centaines de prisonniers. Je sais pas si
vous vous en souvenez. Et d'ailleurs,
quand on voit les proportions, on mesure
quand même euh le le déséquilibre.
C'était euh 10 oages contre 180
Palestiniens. C'était c'était ça les
proportions. Donc
au début, je pense qu'ils ont réussi.
D'ailleurs, il demande également la
libération de Malwan Balrouti qui est
souvent présenté comme le mandela
palestinien qui peut rassembler, qui est
plébiscité vraiment par toutes les
forces politiques palestiniennes et qui
est prêt aussi au dialogue avec les
Israéliens, qui est prêt donc même le
Hamas demande sa libération pour
pour une relève politique. Après, je
pense Arafat et après Abas qui est très
décrié et qui est très dénoncé pour la
corruption de l'autorité palestinienne
et le discrédit qui est celui
aujourd'orité palestienne. Donc ça
aussi, il faut le resituer. C'estàd que
si le Hamas s'émerge avec cette
radicalité là, c'est parce que vraiment
il y a aussi en face une autorité
palestinienne qui est corrompue, qui
finit aussi par se retourner contre les
Palestiniens eux-mêmes, qui procède à
des arrestations, qui
ne représentent plus les intérêts du
peuple palestinien ni ses droits. Dans
ce contexte-là, je veux dire, on arrive
très bien en France parfois à expliquer
pourquoi les gens votent.
Alors, c'est pas la même chose, on est
d'accord.
Pour les gens ils votent Eren ? Bah très
souvent par désespoir.
J'espère que vous faites pas le
parallèle entre Amas et
non. Ce que je veux dire c'est pourquoi
un des citoyens
font le choix parfois de la radicalité
de parfois même des options qui peuvent
être
contreproductives. Alors je mets
absolument pas et ça même le conseil
d'État ne met pas sur le même plan. euh
extrême droite et la gauche de la France
insoumise qui n'est pas qualifiée
d'extrême gauche par ailleurs. Euh donc
du coup, il faut faire attention à ça.
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que
pourquoi est-ce que les gens vont voter
vers l'extrême droite ? Parfois on a des
discussions et heureusement qu'on les a
pour dire pourquoi
Jean-Jacques
de tel coin en France qui a jamais vu un
étranger de sa vie est obsédé par le
fait que il va se faire bouffer par des
vagues de migration en France.
Vous avez des enfants.
Il a sûrement été manipulé. Il a
sûrement été machin. Donc
vous avez des enfants ?
Euh non. Vous comptez vous comptez en
avoir ?
Oui, j'espère.
Inchallah.
Inchallah. Pour la transmission, c'est
important des luttes, des valeurs de
revenons à la commission, la la
communauté internationale. Donc il y a
les Belges, les Espagnes, il y a les
Étud Afrique, il a tout ça.
Ouais. Ouais.
Quand est-ce que le sang va arrêter
d'être versé d'un côté comme de l'autre
? Quand est-ce qu'on on essaie de se
réconcilier, on essaie d'avancer ?
Mais c'est très beau tout ça, mais c'est
pas la réalité du terrain. La réalité du
terrain demande du courage politique. La
réalité du terrain demande des sanctions
contre Israël.
politique dans la même phrase, c'est
compliqué quand même.
Bah, c'est pour ça qu'il faut peut-être
aussi parfois mieux voter. Il faut voter
pour des gens qui à un moment donné sont
dans un une cohérence et dans un courage
par rapport au moment historique que
nous vivons. Je veux dire, aujourd'hui,
on a le recul sur l'apparti de l'Afrique
du Sud. Ce qui nous rend fier, c'est pas
la décision de nos dirigeants, c'est le
fait que des citoyens français ont
massivement boycotté l'Afrique du Sud.
C'est ça qui nous rend fier dans
l'histoire de la France sur cette
questionlà. Et bien pour la Palestine
euh on est aussi dans ce même divorce.
On a des dirigeants qui sont
complètement à côté de la plaque sur ce
qu'il faut faire. Et l'honneur de la
France aujourd'hui, bah il est sur les
campus étudiants. Il est dans les
citoyens qui sont en train de
s'organiser pour boycotter. il est dans
l'organisation Stop Arming Israël qui
mobilise des citoyens, qui éduque des
citoyens sur la coopération militaire
avec Israël et l'utilisation de ces
armes contre les Palestiniens. Et il est
là aujourd'hui l'honneur de la France,
il est dans ces petites gens qui font un
travail que l'État est censé faire.
Quand l'ambassadeur des États-Unis en
France dit que la France fait pas assez
pour les questions d'antisémitisme, quel
regard vous portez là-dessus ?
Euh je dis que c'est une
instrumentalisation. D'ailleurs, Hubert
Vidrine que vous avez reçu ici euh vous
l'a dit que c'est depuis l'arrivée de
Nathanahu qu'on a une
instrumentalisation grossière euh de la
question de l'antisémitisme qui est même
convoqué pour terroriser des des
diplomates ou des des interlocuteurs
qu'on pourrait avoir qui serait source
de d'initiative, de dialogue ou de
d'ouverture vers les Palestiniens et on
va systématiquement convoquer ça. Donc
moi ce que je dis c'est une manière très
simple de clore ce sujet. C'est un
délit.
Si vous êtes convaincu que quelqu'un est
antisémite, allez saisir les tribunaux
et puis bah la justice tranchera. Je
pense qu'il y a eu assez d'affaires
malheureusement en France
d'antisémitisme pour qu'on ait
suffisamment de jurisprudence,
suffisamment de de maîtrise des de la
justice française de cette question pour
pouvoir reconnaître effectivement soit
des propos soit des actes antisémites.
Moi ce que j'observe c'est qu'aucun
membre de la France insoumise n'a été ni
même poursuivi ni condamné pour
antisémitisme.
La flotille.
Oui.
Vous étiez sur un bateau avec Greta ?
Alors vous êtes parti d'où ? Ça a duré
combien de temps ? Qui est-ce qui a
financé tout ça ? Vous avez quoi sur le
pont ? Qui est-ce qu'il y avait dessus ?
Il paraî que vous aviez des kilos de
drogue dans les poches.
Mais pas du tout.
Ah bon ? C'était du du sachet pour
mâcher du tabac que
Israël a pris en photo. C'est ça.
Ah oui, c'était pour un le ressortissant
turc qui avait apparemment bon ça ça
aussi c'est vraiment des constructions.
Israël sont de je pensais qu'ils étaient
forts en propagande en fait. qui sont
assez assez pitoyables. Mais donc sur la
question de la flotti, c'est une action
la plus importante qui est en train de
se dérouler maintenant par ailleurs.
Première chose, qui a financé ça ?
Combien ça ?
La coalition. La coalition. Donc les
gens pensaient que c'était l'argent
européen. Pas du tout. Moi, je suis
allée effectivement sur mes frais,
c'est-à-dire mon déplacement.
On est parti du port de Catan. Donc ça
supposait de port de Catan
en en en Sicile, pardon. Donc on est
parti euh
fallait être 2 jours avant parce qu'il y
avait
C'est quoi comme bateau ?
C'est un voilier.
Euh quel type ? Euh
je sais pas. Euh je pas le Beneto.
Ah franchement là je je suis désolée
mais je vais pas je sais pas une
cabine pas de cabine
je saurais pas vous catégoriser le Oui
oui on avait moi je qu' partagé ma
cabine on était trois dans la cabine on
avait trois lits dans la j'avais filmé
en plus pour vraiment montrer en toute
transparence où on dormait ce qui se
passait. On a pu lire dans la presse que
il y aurait un financier douteux anglais
connecté avec le Hamas qu' aurait
financer tout ça.
Non. Alors est-ce qu'ils ont ils sont
allés fouiller ? Mais ça m'étonne qu'on
passe énormément de temps sur ces
questions vraiment futiles que ça m'a
été aussi posé par vos confrères de R
sur image. Mais oui mais
ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est qu'est-ce
que vous vous avez réussi à trouver et
sur la base de ce que vous avez trouvé
on échange. Mais euh même sur R sur
Image journaliste quand même très
sérieux l'équipe très sérieuse on dit il
paraît que enfin je dire à un moment
donné moi je suis j'ai autre chose à
faire que commenter des épar soit vous
avez trouvé parce que vous avez fouillé
journalistiquement et puis on commente
ensemble. On n'est pas journaliste,
pas vous, mais je veux dire quel que
soit en fait votre statut dans une
préparation d'une interview, quand on
pose une question, on s'assure aussi
d'avoir des éléments de base pour voilà,
nous on vous propose une porte
parce que moi commenter les paris ça me
on vous propose une porte pour démentir
les paris
et bien je du coup je je vais le dire
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que en
plus de mon travail qui consiste à
démentir, j'aimerais bien aussi parfois
qu'il y ait un peu plus de rigueur c'est
je le regrette
mais vous me dites vous êtes pas
journaliste donc non mais rigur
journaliste phrase ça devient de plus en
Non non mais c'est vrai, on est d'accord
mais c'est ce que le c'est le reproche
que je fais justement à ce corps ce
corps de métier donc parce que j'y suis
souvent confrontée. Donc euh il se
trouve que un ancien personne enfin un
ancien membre de la coalition euh
c'est quoi la coalition ?
La coalition c'est une coalition la
fleutille la pour Gaza. Donc c'est une
coalition qui regroupe trentaine d'ONG.
Financé par qui ? Comment ? Bah
justement, c'est les ONG qui se qui en
fait mettent aussi de l'argent. C'est
différentes ONG qui mettent de l'argent
pour ces projets pour le bateau.
Et non, mais les ONG en question qui
est-ce qui les finance ?
Ah, je peux aller enquêter sur les 30
ONG qui financent, je veux dire.
Non, en non, j'ai pas fait ça.
Franchement, j'ai autre chose à faire.
surtout quand on sait que la coalition
en réalité elle existe. À la limite, si
c'était une initiative nouvelle, je
pense que j'aurais été un peu voilà,
j'aurais peut-être euh
peut-être fouiller et cetera. Mais cette
coalition, moi j'en parle depuis que je
suis gamine. Je veux dire,
depuis vous avez fouillé ou pas
depuis le blocus à Gaza. Euh non, j'ai
pas fouillé mais il y a pas matière de
toute façon. Je veux dire, à part des
médias d'extrême droite ou de
complotistes qui vous disent que c'est
lié au Hamas, personne le fait quoi. Je
veux dire et puis il faut dire aussi
historiquement c'est pour vous dire le
chiffre qu'il y a eu en France extrême
droite
je sais pas mais je veux dire qui ont
ligne en tout cas qui ont qui font qui
font peut-être de moi de par mes mon
engagement avec la France insoumise ou
ou mes origines ou je sais pas qui font
peut-être de moi une ennemi vraiment à
abattre quoi politiquement et donc il
faut absolument aller trouver des choses
à redire quoi. Donc voilà donc ça ça
fait partie des peut-être des méthodes.
Faut quand même dire aussi que il y a eu
des d'autres personnalités politiques
notamment du parti communiste qui ont
parti les rouges encore.
Non mais je veux dire il y a eu quand
même des initiatives de la coalition qui
ont été soutenues par des
bords politique progressistes des verts
de voilà qui on été souten de droite
euh non malheureusement alors que
franchement on a un héritage de de
Gaulle qui
je pense s'inscrirait s'inscrirait
pleinement là-dedans
même Chiraak
de du nonalignement de Chirak de
Villepin qui s'inscrirait dans oui je
pense vraiment dans un soutien à la
cause palestinienne Et c'est ce qu'on a
perdu en fait, la propagande israélienne
a parce qu'on a laissé cette cause
palestinienne depuis Villepin, depuis
Chirak, on l'a complètement abandonné et
c'est la droite aussi qui l'a abandonné
mais également Hollande Hollande SarkoZi
c'est du pareil au même quasiment mais
on l'a complètement abandonné et donc on
se retrouve avec vraiment une génération
entière de citoyens français qui n'ont
pas été sensibilisés à cette cause et
qui découvrent d'un coup comme ça la
cause palienne avec le 7 octobre.
forcément que euh ce que ça leur envoie
c'est "Ah bah les défenseurs de la cause
palestinienne c'est ça quoi." Mais non,
enfin je veux dire historiquement c'est
pas ça.
Et Greta Tenberg, qu'est-ce qu'il y a à
faire là-dedans ? Mais Greta Tenberg,
elle est dans une, je pense, dans une
une cohérence de la lutte écologiste. La
lutte écologiste, c'est une lutte aussi
décolonial. C'est une lutte pour les
peuples indigènes. C'est une c'est une
lutte aussi pour une
les peuples privés de leur terre ou qui
qui sont persécutés sur leur terre,
qu'on empêche de vivre et de survivre
sur leur terre et qu'on empêche de vivre
de leur terre. Les Palestiniens sont
très nombreux à à dépendre de leur
terre. Vous étiez sur le bateau,
certains ont croisé l'ont l'ont détaillé
comme la croisière s'amuse, d'autres
comme la croisière de la liberté, ainsi
de suite. Bon, vous avez été survolé par
des drones, ils vous ont envoyé des
petites saloperies sur le pont.
Ouais, on a on a eu du mal à identifier
au début, c'était une peinture blanche.
Apparemment, c'était vraiment pour nous
marquer parce que c'est une peinture qui
s'enlève pas. Je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle
en tout cas qui s'enlève pas. Qui a Vous
pouvez pas la
C'était où ? C'était dans les eaux
en eau international. C'était en eau
international. On a d'abord reçu une
demande vient nous demander de faire
demi-tour de Bingvir en personne dans la
presse et donc on a répondu par voie de
presse également en disant n on fera pas
demi-tour. Euh et rappeler encore une
fois le cadre du droit international,
c'est-à-dire que les rapporteurs
spéciaux des Nations-Unies ont
parfaitement euh 10 rapporteurs spéciaux
des Nations- Unies 2 jours après notre
départ, on fait un communiqué, une
analyse très précieuse en disant
premièrement que euh les Palestins sont
en droit de recevoir de l'aide
humanitaire par voie maritime, y compris
dans un contexte d'occupation. Donc
l'Israël peut pas convoquer le fait
qu'ils occupent le territoire pour
empêcher l'aide humanitaire d'arriver.
et que deuxièmement les eaux euh que
contrôle Israël sont des eaux
palestiniennes et qu'elles sont
contrôlées de manière illégale par
Israël. Donc ces rapporteurs spéciaux
des Nations- Unies ont venu poser un
cadre du droit international sur
l'action et effectivement nous avons été
interceptés en international et ça c'est
en violation. C'est un acte de de
piraterie en fait ce qu'on a subi c'est
un acte de piraterie. C'est-à-dire qu'on
est venu nous choper en international et
on nous a ramené de force à HDOD au port
d'Hdod en Israël alors qu'on se
dirigeait vers Gaza. Vous avez été bien
traité ?
Euh bien traité, on n pas été violenté
sur le port, ça c'est sûr. Après les
fouilles, c'est quand même voilà, on est
totalement nu.
On n pas le droit de euh enfin je veux
dire il a fallu faire quelques gestes
pour prouver qu'on avait rien caché dans
nos parti
ont fait le tout un coup. Bah moi pour
le coup, c'était me demander de
m'accroupir à plusieurs reprises. Enfin,
c'est quand même des choses très
humiliantes.
Et puis ensuite, on a été emprisonné
4 jours. Donc, puis moi, j'étais à
l'isolement parce que j'ai inscrit sur
le mur Free Palestine avec une plaquette
de médicaments que j'ai retrouvé sous le
lit qui appartenait peut-être à une
ancienne détenue. Mais il restait juste
une bout de plaquette de médicaments
vide quoi.
C'était quoi comme molécule ? Je sais
plus c'était quoi. Ça devait être
sûrement des trucs dépression, je sais
pas. Enfin des choses qu'on peut donner
dans un dans une prison contre l'anxiété
ou quoi. Du coup, je prends cette
plaquette et je gratte Free Palestine,
Nakba, euh Genocide
et ils sont furieux et puis ils viennent
me monoter les mains et les pieds et je
suis traînée dans un autre complexe, une
autre prison à l'isolement.
une journée du matin et le soir le
consul intervient pour
de le consul
français
intervient pour
pour nous faire pour me pour me ramener
à ma cellule initiale. Mais je veux
quand même dire la France est très
humiliée par Israël.
Le consul, je crois qu'il a attendu 3h
en plein cagnard, ne serait-ce que pour
me rendre visite 10 minutes. Et quand on
avait un entretien avec lui, il refusait
de sortir, de nous laisser cette
intimité de l'entretien. Il avait beau
leur demander, leur rappeler les règles
qui s'appliquaient,
je veux dire, un petit gardien de
prison,
je le dis très franchement, humilier le
consul
français. Bon, il sera pas très content
de ce que je vais dire, mais c'est la
vérité.
par ne pas respecter les règles qui
s'appliquaient, le laisser attendre de 3
heures en plein cagnor devant alors que
il y avait aucune raison pour ne pas
faciliter la visite en fait parce que
c'est un droit. J'ai le droit de de
Il était peut-être occupé, il av
peut-être pas assez de
Non, il bon lui-même il m'a dit il sera
peut-être pas très content que je
retranscrive ça. Mais c'est important
pour moi de dire que la France, l'État
français quand il prétend qu'il défend
un allié, c'est faux. Je pense vraiment
pas que les autorités israéliennes ne
respectent la France. Je pense vraiment
pas qu'on a à gagner à garder des liens
aussi étroit avec un état qui ne
respecte pas la France, qui ne respecte
pas le peuple français et qui
instrumentalise la solidarité
occidentale
à des fins
de crimes qui vont à l'encontre des
engagements de la France. Là, il y a une
deuxième flot qui est partie
aujourd'hui.
Oui. Alors, il y a des problèmes de
météo. Je suis en contact avec eux. Il y
a des problèmes de météo. Ils sont
censés partir
de quelques jours. Partiront peut-être
vendredi, de ce que j'ai compris. Euh de
l'Italie euh non, de Tunis, pardon,
excusez-moi. De Tunis, il y a une
converge. Il
a pas d'Espagne.
Euh les bateaux vous convergent vers un
départ collectif vers Tunis depuis
Tunis. Il y a combien de bateaux ?
Une quarantaine de ce que j'ai
de personnes
je sais pas. Euh je dirais euh plusieurs
milliers plusieurs milliers de citoyens,
je sais pas exactement dans chaque
bateau bateau ça fait beaucoup.
Oui, c'est vrai que ça fait bateau
beaucoup. Après ça dépend parce que par
nous sur notre voilier, on était 12,
c'était pas énorme. Je veux dire, on
était pas sur un don, je pense qu'il y a
des bateaux aussi de différentes
tailles. Certains pourront peut-être
accueillir 20 30 personnes et puis
d'autres peut-être une dizaine de
personnes. Donc j'ai pas encore vraiment
de visibilité sur le tout. Et je pense
qu'ils attendent qui dessus
il y a bah un peu de tout. Il y a bah
Greta repart de nouveau. Il y a
Greta gagne comment sa vie ?
Euh je sais pas, je pense que
non, je pense qu'elle doit être
soutenue. Je sais pas franchement
honnêtement je veux pas dire des choses
que je ne sais pas. Je pense qu'elle
doit
Je pense qu'elle doit être soutenue
peut-être, je sais pas honnêtement parce
que je pense qu'elle est très attachée à
son indépendance. Peut-être qu'elle
travaille ponctuellement pour des ONG
avec qui elle coopère. Je sais pas du
tout honnêtement. Je veux pas dire de
bêtises, faudrait lui poser la question.
Euh donc voilà, il y a les membres de la
coalition. Effectivement, je pense qu'
c'est aussi d'avoir des personnalités.
J'ai cru voir une actrice américaine,
j'ai oublié son nom, qui a été très
mobilisé contre le génocide.
Si vous avez son nom, ça m'aiderait. Euh
mais voilà, donc l'idée c'est un peu de
composer
ces bateaux avec personnalité politique,
personnalité euh personnalité publique
mais également des citoyens citoyennes
militants comme c'était le cas sur notre
bateau. Je veux dire, il y avait Greta,
il y avait moi certes, mais il y avait
aussi Rev, il y avait des militants je
veux dire. Sarondon.
Oui, voilà, c'est elle. Excusez-moi,
j'ai j'arrivais pas à ressier son nom.
Comment ça va se passer là ? Il y a plus
de bateaux. Vous pensez que les
Israéliens ils vont être contents ?
Non, Bengvir s'est déjà exprimé, je sais
pas si vous avez eu l'occasion de
regarder, mais il s'est déjà exprimé
dans la presse en disant qu'il fallait
que ces militants s'attendent à une
réponse extrêmement ferme de la part des
autorités israéennes.
Vous avez été incarcéré en Israël. Vous
avez signé le papier comme quoi vous pas
revenir pendant
Non non non, moi j'ai refusé de le
signer parce que
ça
Est-ce que vous comptez revenir ?
Non, parce que maintenant je suis
interdite de territoire pour 100 ans
parce que vous avez pas vous avez signé
parce que j'ai été jugée ensuite. J'ai
pas Alors moi j'ai pas signé puis
ensuite j'ai été euh jugé par une
enfin une procès vraiment ridicule au
sein même de la prison euh où
un avocat
Oui. de Oui oui un avocat Oui oui.
d'association palestinienne qui
travaille de ce qu'on appelle les Arabes
israéliens, donc les Palestiniens
d'Israël quoi, qui travaillent sur ces
questions mais avec aussi des juifs
israéliens, c'est pas c'est pas que des
Palestiniens. Et qui m'a dit "Vous être
interdit territoire pendant 100 ans et
je lui dis je suis vraiment pas sûre que
votre état dans sa forme actuelle tienne
100 ans."
Voilà. Donc chercher aussi
ça c'est bah c'est vrai c'est ce que je
pense. Je pense pas que Israël tiendra
100 ans dans vraiment pas
pour des questions économique pour des
questions quoi
non pour des questions de modèle ne
serait-ce que de modèle c'est un état
là aujourd'hui le nouveau paradigme de
la la question israélopaïtienne c'est
vraiment la partide si on ne comprend
pas
les conséquences politiques de la
partide que
la partide en Afrique du Sud il y a
toujours l'Afrique du Sud. Oui, mais
justement, c'est-à-dire que Israël,
je vous schématise très rapidement,
Israël se définit comme un état juif et
un état démocratique.
Depuis la loi de 2018, l'État nation,
c'est on avance plus vers une vraiment
une ethnocratie affirmée que vers un
état démocratique. Et donc en occupant
et en annexant des territoires
palestiniens, Israël se retrouve
confronté à ce à un dilemme qui lui est
propre, qui est même pas imposé par les
Palestiniens. Soit je suis un état
démocratique, mais dans ce cas-là, je ne
suis plus un état exclusivement juif.
Soit je suis un état exclusivement juif,
mais dans ce cas-là, je suis plus un
état démocratique. Je suis un état
d'appartide. Et c'est vers cette
tendance là qu'on est en train d'avancer
depuis la loi de 2018, voir même un peu
avant. Moi, mon ma mémoire de fin
d'étude, c'était sur l'appartid en
Israël. C'est en 2015 avant la loi.
C'était déjà ça faisait déjà partie de
quelques travaux de quelques réflexions
qui étaient déjà posées. Donc ça c'est
le nouveau paradigme. Et donc la réponse
politique à ça c'est pas deux états.
Quelle frontière ? C'est égalité de
droit. C'est vers ça qu'on avance. Donc
la forme actuelle de l'État israélien,
franchement, elle a tout cassé je pense
euh 10 ans.
Même moi. Je pense même moi. Et je pense
que Israël en refusant à un état
palestinien a finalement renoncé à son
projectionniste
de facto. C'estàd qu'un état juif
démocratique
bah c'est plus possible puisque le
projet sunnisme paraissent c'est un
projet aussi colonial qui pousse à la
conquête des territoires palestiniens.
Mais les palestiniens ne vont pas
disparaître. Ils sont même plus nombreux
que les juifs israéliens. Il va falloir
à un moment donné composer avec un état
démocratique, c'est-à-dire laïque, qui
reconnaît, moi je pense l'idéal, c'est
un état binational qui reconnaît des
spécifices, des autonomies de langue, de
culture, de gestion propre aux
différentes communautés mais avec et un
pouvoir politique aussi qui est reconnu
pour les deux. C'est-à-dire qu'on a des
ambassades qui représentent les
Israéliens, qu'on a des ambassades qui
reprennent les Palestiniens mais sur un
seul et même territoire avec liberté de
circulation, liberté d'installation. Et
il y a pas d'autres possibilité parce
que c'est déjà la réalité.
Il y a en Israël 25 % de la population
qui est d'origine palestinienne.
Et les rapports les rapports des des ONG
nous disent, ils sont déjà des citoyens
de seconde zone. Les Arabes israéliens,
c'est des citoyens même de 5e zone par
ce que disent les rapports. C'est qu'ils
ont vraiment pas accès à des libertés.
Euh je sais pas, ils ont ils ont ils
sont ils sont vraiment exclus de tout un
tas de mécanismes, que ça soit sur les
questions des impôts, des cotisations,
que ça soit sur euh euh la possibilité
de construire, d'acheter le travail, ils
sont vraiment voilà. Et vous rajoutez à
ça le fait qu'il y a maintenant près
d'un million de colons israéliens sur
les territoires palestiniens.
À Gaza, à l'époque, il a fallait sortir
les colons en 2005, il y avait 5000
colons, je crois un peu moins.
Il fallait en moyenne quatre ou cinq
soldats. Quatre ou cinq soldats
israéliens par colon
pour le protéger. pour les sortir.
Ah, pour les sortir.
Pour les sortir. Donc franchement, il y
a deux options. Si on sort les colons de
la bande de de la Sordanie, c'est une
guerre civile en Israël. C'est une
guerre civile. Il y a déjà une
fragmentation terrible. Moi, j'étais sur
les plateaux de c'est ce soir à l'époque
avant même 7 octobre où je disais mais
aujourd'hui le danger c'est que la C
païtienne comme les C israélien sont
très fragmentés.
Donc vous pouvez avoir des à une une
fissure en fait totale dans les deux
sociétés.
Revenons à la flotille.
Oui.
Ça va donner quoi ?
Euh juste pour dire quand même que la
partite c'est quand même les nouveaux
parading pour les gens qui nous
écoutent. Il faut vraiment commencer à
l'envisager comme le point de départ
d'une nouvelle perspective politique. La
flotti, j'en pense que c'est une
initiative très importante qui
a permis de remettre en action des gens
qui se sentaient très impuissants face
aux politiques. Et c'était aussi une
action concrète qui a redonné un peu de
souffle et d'espoir à des gens qui sont
dit "Mais moi, ça fait quasiment 2 ans
que je vois toutes ces images, je me
sens impuissant, j'en veux à la France,
à l'État français de ne rien faire et je
m'identifie à Reva, à Baptiste, à Rima,
à Greta qui à Pascal qui se à leur
échelle sont dit on va pouvoir faire
quelque chose même si on n'y arrive
C'est qui Pascal ?
Pascal c'était un des membres, c'est un
ingénieur à la retraite qui était qui
était parti de la qui faisait partie de
la coalition. Il y avait six français
quand même sur 12 personnes. La France
était quand même bien représentée. C'est
pas c'est pas un odain entre le
journaliste de Blast, Pascal Reva,
moi-même,
je la France était quand même
bien représenté et je trouve que c'est
aussi ça l'honneur de de cette France
là. Le déshonneur, il est dans la
politique qui est menée dans la
complicité du génocide et l'honneur de
la France, il est dans dans les rues,
dans les mobilisation que des millions
de de gens
voilà à travers lesquels les millions de
gens se sentent concernés en fait par
lesquels des millions de gens se sentent
concernés. Ils descendent pas tous dans
la rue, ils font pas tous des actions.
Mais moi, je suis convaincu quand on a
75 76 % des Français qui sont pour des
sanction contre Israël, c'est des gens
qui ont conscience de ce qui se passe.
Ils disent pas paix, justice,
dissanction. C'est une demande quand
même assez ferme, en fermée aussi. C'est
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à nous
conseiller ?
Oui, parce que je crois qu'on a un peu
tardé. Donc justement
3h27, c'est une petite
j'ai ramené des livres sur qui traitent
un peu de ces questions qui sont pour
moi des livres qui peuvent vraiment nous
accompagner pour qu'on prendre en
complexité la question palestinienne sur
des sujets qui sont pas très abordés. Le
droit au retour. Donc là, vous avez euh
une dizaine de contributions de
différents chercheurs sur la direction
d'Ia
qui traitent de toute la question autour
des réfugiés palestiniens,
des dimensions historiques, des
témoignages autour d'Acba, la question
des camps, euh l'économie dans les
camps, il y a plein d'aspects même euh
très diverses qui sont traités en fait
dans ce livre pour comprendre la
question de l'exil palestinien et du
droit au retour. Et il y a même deux
contributions sur le droit international
et la question du droit au retour. Donc
vraiment des analyses aussi juridiques
poussées. Radakarmi euh autrice
palestinienne Israël Palestine solution
un état. Donc pour commencer à réfléchir
sur l'alternative
euh poste Oslo qui fait pas du tout
partie des débats publics. Ça c'est
vraiment pour moi euh
un tort de pas de dire "OK, les
résolutions des Nations-Unies c'est deux
États, mais il y a aussi des
contributions qui datent de plusieurs
années israéliennes comme palestinienne
sur un état.
Euh deuxième lecture sur ce sujet
beaucoup plus courte et plus
synthétique, Eric Azan et Ilian Sivan,
c'est un cinéaste. Eric Azan, c'est le
fondateur de la maison d'édition la
fabrique. Un état commun entre le
Jourdin et la mer. Donc très
intéressant. Et un dernier, ça c'est un
peu le coup de cœur, c'est un livre qui
m'a ma mère m'a mis entre les mains
quand j'étais très jeune. Lettre à un
ami juif de Ibrahim Sous. Il s'inspire
de du modèle des lettres de Camu, un ami
allemand.
Pour Camu, c'est un ami imaginaire mais
pour Sous, c'est un vrai ami juif à qui
il s'adresse et à qui il expose sa peine
d'être palestinien, sa souffrance et il
demande à ce qu'il lui tende la main.
Donc c'est un un très très beau livre.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que on a
oublié ?
On n pas c'était un peu décousu, c'est
normal et c'est le format et je suis
désolé pour les gens qui voilà se sont
accrochés jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo.
Oui, peut-être je pense que
étabationale, on a pas assez creusé sur
sur cette option politique. On j'aurai
d'autres occasions, je l'espère. Et la
partille dont on en a parlé, je suis
quand même ravie parce que pour moi
c'est un peu le nouveau paradigme
au-delà du génocide, au-delà de la
colonisation et la question du droit au
retour aussi des camps palestiniens. Les
camps palestiniens, les dynamiques
d'encampement, les 58 camps palestiniens
qui existent, comment ils se
structurent, euh les revendications du
droit au retour, quelle perspective,
leur statut juridique. Vous savez que un
palestinien au Liban n'a pas le même
statut qu'un palestinien en Jordanie,
n'a pas les mêmes statutés qu'un
palestinien en Syrie. Puis moi, j'ai
visité beaucoup les camps parce que je
suis vraiment euh dans cet héritage-là.
Moi, j'ai pas accès à la Palestine mais
j'ai accès au camp. Donc euh j'ai
vraiment construit disons ma Palestinité
euh à travers l'exil quoi, à travers euh
l'exil et à travers les camps. Donc euh
c'est un sujet que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé.
Mais en tout cas voilà, les livres que
je vous ai recommandé sont assez
étauffés pour pouvoir réfléchir à ces
sujets.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable. Oui, je m'inscris dans
le l'appel de Stéphan Essel. moi que
j'ai dont j'ai pleuré la mort, je me
souviens, j'étais dans ma chambre
étudiante quand j'ai appris sa mort et
qui est un homme qui me donnait
énormément d'espoir et qui a écrit ce
petit appel "Indez-vous" qui s'est vendu
jus à combien de millions d'exemplaires
à travers le monde et qui les sujets qui
sont abordés dans ce dans ce dans ce
petit appel qu'il formule, je pense
essentiellement à la jeunesse par
ailleurs, bah sont toujours d'actualité.
Il est question de Gaza, il est question
de démocratie, il est question de de
solidarité des peuples, il est question
de l'état du monde, il est question de
d'écologie et et d'éveil un peu des
consciences. Et donc euh donc je
reformulerai cet appel là qui est
toujours d'actualité.
Rima Hassan, merci.
Merci à vous. Merci infiniment.
[Musique]